eu j'espère que vous allez bien on a un
poil en retard on a eu des petits
problèmes techniques euh euh Fab qui est
euh qui est la BUP à Paris d'ailleurs on
fera un petit raid en fin de de stream à
Kevin et euh du coup FB n'avait pas de
caméra juste avant le lancement mais
même Mo j'avais plus de souris j'avais
rien c'était la cata mais ouais ouais le
micro qui marchait à moitié la souris
qui marchait pas euh pas de caméra et
c'était euh pas évident mais on a réussi
à enfin il a réussi en tout cas à tout
gérer de son côté et euh et du coup on a
pu lancer euh donc euh donc c'est
parfait les parties qui vont commencer
dans un instant donc je vais vous
montrer un petit peu le format de euh de
cet événement euh d'aujourd'hui donc
vous savez on a passé depuis euh déjà
maintenant euh plusieurs tournois il y
avait euh champour je crois qu'il y a eu
peut-être six éditions et du coup là
c'est la grande finale tous les points
étaient il y avait des points euh
cumulés hein qui était et du coup euh
maintenant vous voyz la grande finale j'
un petit peu les joueurs déjà qui sont
qui participe on a al on a mvl on
a on a on a Carsen lazavic Nakamura so
et kwana quand même beaucoup de monde le
bracket qui est ici avec les joueurs qui
vont bien sûr arriver tout à l'heure
c'est pas encore mis mis en place le
standings est ici avec les joueurs qui
vont se mettre au fur et à
mesure on a aussi alors le format il est
assez spécial on va jouer en fait des
matchs des matchs qui donc aller-retour
ok donc c'est bo2 si vous
voulez donc si jamais je gagne le match
et ben je me qualifie point barre s'il y
a un
partoutù alors je me qualifie en
demi-finale en fait non non en fait
c'est pas ça je n'importe quoi je un peu
n'importe quoi parce que tu poses des
questions un peu piège j'éis pas prêt
mais en gros en gros je vous explique
alors jeis mettre les
caméras continuer l'explication et
d'ailleurs je vois absolument rien de ce
que je fais euh hop hop hop pour venir
ici vous allez nous voir en fait ce qui
va se passer Fab c'est que on a du
coup huit joueurs ici avec nous euh et
donc on va faire un système tout Trond
où tout le monde jouera contre tout le
monde donc aujh un par jour en gros
comment euh un match par jour deux
matchs par jour en gros de par nous on
fait de match d'ailleurs ça a commencé
on voit mais on a une minute de délai
vous savez donc ça va arriver et donc en
fait on
a on a comment dire une minute non
pardon on a deux matchs par jour h
joueurs une minute de délai voilàl et
donc H8 joueur combien vaut une
baguette c'était comme les petits
problèmes mathématiques quand on était
en primaire quoi oui oui oui mais ok
donc il y a deux matchs par jour et en
fait c'est comme si au li de jouer une
seule partie il se joue en petit match
il marque des points et à la fin il y a
un classement et il se qualifie pour des
demi-finales et Machin voilà pari
classement parmi les h les h joueurs les
deux premiers du circuit euh se
qualifient pour les demi-finales ok les
joueur de 3 à 6 inclus euh joue ce qu'on
appelle al je sais comment appelle mais
c'est un truc de je crois qu'ils sont en
mode survie je crois je CIS qu' ouais
enfin bon de toute façon du coup
aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas on a pas
besoin de tout comprendre quoi mais pour
que vous compreniez un petit peu comment
ça se passe 1 et 2 qualifi pour la pour
la demi-finale 7 et 8 Ciao
et euh 3 4 5 6 fera des matchs de
barrages entre eux pour deux
qualifiés avec voilà et du coup bon
c'est un peu ce qui se passe donc là on
est on joue d'ailleurs les bah les round
1 et 2 de ce euh de cette poule si vous
voulez et on a des très très beaux
appariments donc les parties sont pas
affichées chez moi alors pourquoi est-ce
que ça ne joue pas euh je vais essayer
de changer un peu on les voit jouer à la
caméra hein les joueurs ouais ok moi je
vois rien mais je te crois B tu vois mon
écran oui ben non enfin ton écran je
vois juste oui mais tu vois pas de coup
quoi non je juste je euh est-ce que
c'est normal ou est-ce que c'est pas
normal parce que là aujourd'hui je suis
connectter ave avec le compte chesscom
normalement j'ai pas de problème j'ai
prévu le coup euh attends vas-y Mo je
vais regarder si j'ai une partie ah
bravo évidemment il y a deux parties
c'est la partie en dessousoi euh donc là
bon ça mar alira firouja et on est ici
ok donc on a un petit peu de retard
alors cadence 15 plus 3 Fab c'est écrit
en haut et le gagnant c'esteli celui qui
gagne 1 et demi sur deux dans ce match
ou alors il y aura comme d'habitude un
Armagedon en système d'enchère comme
d'hab
ok donc il font ils font deux parties
s'il y a un partout il y a un arm Guedon
et s' y a un05 ou 20 bah tu as gagné
quoi et et tu joues ton deème match et
puis Bast c'est ça voilà voilà donc bon
ça y est je crois qu'on a à peu près
compris ce qui se passe oui oui c'est
assez simple en fait au final parce que
tu vois quand même le champion Gest il y
a eu quand même six éditions cette année
donc on commence un peu à voir comment
ça se passe même si là c'est vrai que la
nouveauté c'est qu'il y a des mod il y a
un mode survie au milieu ouais mais oui
ils te font des trucs où tu as perdu
mais en fait tu as pas vraiment perdu
enfin c'était jamais trop simple à
comprendre ouais ouais mais je trouve
que c'est pas mal cette formule je
trouve intéressant parce que bon tu
perds une fois ça peut arriver de faire
une après tu reviens mais tuas le mérite
de devoir gagner peut-être deux ou trois
matchs parce que tu as perdu un match
avant tu vois donc en tout cas
l'élimination donner une une troisième
vie quoi enfin comme ça on fait bien le
tournoi sur 15 jours c'est pas mal quoi
ouais non mais c'est vrai que les les il
y a il y a un petit peu le contrecoup
parce qu'on parle souvent des des
systèmes systèm coupe hein tu vois qui
sont l'élimination direct ouais où c'est
pas où c'est pas évident parce qu'au
final euh bah ouais la c'est fini ou
c'est court mais là du coup c'est court
mais c'est long tu vois donc la beauté
du truc c'est un peu comme la bénonie tu
vois mais dans dans dans l'idée vraiment
c'est c'est que voilà tu peux tu peux
être éliminé direct mais tu as une vie
quoi donc mais pas t que ça quoi allez
tiens reviens un peu exactement
exactement donc donc ok intéressant donc
là on a la belle berlinoise d'aliirza
donc une ouverture qui est qui est
extrêmement solide pour les noirs avec
la paire de fou mais un défaut de
structure avec des pions doublés sur la
colonne C exactement et donc bon c'est
su plutôt une une bonne une bonne
ouverture j'ai envie de dire hein s'il
joue pour l'égalité avec les Noirs etoi
les une bonne et une mauvaise ouverture
alors une bonne ouverture euh non mais
en fait dans cette position en fait il y
a un truc à à préciser quand même aux
gens parce que là on peut penser que
c'est bizarre cette position c'est une
finale il se passe rien et puis bon com
comment mat quoi mais c'est la vérité il
se passe rien mais mais en
fait mais passe un petit peu quand même
bah les blancs ce qu' peuvent voir paren
fait y a y a un truc stratégique quand
même qui est intéressant à voir et si
vous connaissez pas je pense un truc
quand même qui peut vous aider si vous
échangez toutes les pièces s'il y a plus
de tour plus de Cabal et plus de fous il
y a que des pions ok bah qui gagne ici
en fait comment on évalue la
position pas si évident si on connaitt
pas non parce que bon ben il y a autant
de pion chacunis d B peut-être match nul
quoi on sait pas trop ouais mais en fait
euh si on enlève toutes les pièces si je
je liquide toutes les pièces et que je
mets le roi au centre bah en fait les
blancs vont gagner tous les jours cette
partie parce que les Noirs n'arriveront
pas à se créer une percée ou une
majorité avec les pions qu'ils ont ici
vous voyez j'ai quatre pions ici contre
trois et cette majorité là n'avance pas
par exemple dès que tu vas avancer moi
je fais par C4 et en fait bon courage
pour te créer un PI passé dès que tuou
B5 je touche rien voilà faudra surtout
pas faire pion prend B5 parce que on on
va donner le pion C5 passé et si on fait
rien il prennent on reprend ils font
rien on fait rien et par contre les
Blancs euh bah en gros on a le pion e
qui y a personne devant lui plus et on
veut on veut l'aider donc on va essayer
d'amener le pion F2 en F5 et faire E6 E7
et une dame quoi donc oui les blancs
peuvent se faire un pion passé leur
majorité est mobile euh et on peut la la
faire évoluer alors que les Noirs eux
leur 4 contre 3 peut pas donc
effectivement les blancs bah ils veulent
miser là-dessus et en fait pourquoi la
Berlise du coup est jouable pour les
noirs et qui rentent quand même dans une
finale en acceptant ça bah c'est qu'en
fait c'est pas si simple à mettre en
place déjà ils vont pas accepter
d'échanger toutes les pièces en claquant
des doigts et de de on voit qu'ils ont
un beau blocage sur les ces blanches par
exemple là le cavalier F5 bah il est
implanté ici ils ont un fout de ce
blanche pas les blanc donc comme nous on
veut essayer de mettre le pion F2 en F5
bah il y a du boulot pour y arriver et
donc ça a fait ses preuves avec les
Noirs C cette ouverture c'est du robuste
ouais alors attends je suis en train
d'essayer de faire un petit truc parce
que je viens de d'ouvrir en fait le chat
twitch je l'avais pas encore ouvert et
je vois qu'on nous dit qu'on t'entend
trop fort par rapport à moi et du coup
j'étais en train de me de me baisser mon
volume ouais puis de rajouter un peu le
mien donc j'espère que ça va mieux
maintenant mais je sais pas si ça ça je
l'ai pas vu voilà et euh tiens je est-ce
que tu peux ou pasre le chat twitch sur
ce que je vois comme ça euh je peux voir
ce qu'il disent et sinon tant pis c'est
toi qui le gère et moi je vois pas ce
qu'ils disent et on s'en fout pas grave
non mais tu peux c'est bon s'il a des
questions tu pourras répondre maisors si
tu peux bah voilà quoi si je le
mets dès que je vais jouer une pièce ça
va s'échapper quoi ça va s'enlever ça r
d'être un Peas pas il y a un truc pas
mal
enfin c'est un pin un truc et tu le
laisses scch mais si tu l'as pas tu l'as
pas si tu si je peux le faire tu me dis
comment ça s'appelle je le fais en
direct mais sinon je euh je sais pas
comment s'appelle euh je l'ai sur mon
ordi mais là bon bien sûr je chez moi
ouais et c'est pratique ouais c'est
c'est une sorte de pins en plus le même
l'icône ou quoi mais c'est et en fait
c'est comme si tu tu mettais une punaise
sur une fenêtre et elle reste elle reste
au top tout le temps quoi que tu F ça je
le faisais pas mal quand j'utilisais euh
euh un comment ça s'appelle tu sais un
truc de de vidéo là euh VLC je crois VLC
ah VLC avec plot là ouais genre moi je
sais je genre j'avais un seul écr je
bissis sur Internet même temps jeter mon
film et là du coup mon film partait pas
quoi et ouais tu le ça tutais là ouais
non mais là je je sais pas mais après ce
que je peux faire à la pause
éventuellement c'est que je non mais
c'est pas grave t'inquiète enfin en plus
je peux ouvrir le chat sur mon téléphone
tiens voilà oui ben je pense que c'est
c'est la meilleure idée merci et vu que
libi ne voit pas le chat je vous invite
à à ne pas forcément être très gentil
avec lui voilà c'est gratuit fait gaff
j'arrive hein je va le voir je retiens
les noms et je vais bannir fait très
attention est-ce que tu as une épée
d'ailleurs hein j'ai des épées ouais ah
pardon je crois que j'ai des épées
derrière moi quoi non non non non je
teux parle si tu avais l'épée si tu
avais l'épée euh il est où le secret
link ouais je pense que
IP hop là les pasendu alors j'ai une
épée donc peutre je vais virer Robin
side il parle un peu trop je trouis
ouais mais je crois que tu peux pas le
virer on on fait un combat d'épée
quoi donc les pendules sont en place
toutes est en place voilà donc tour à 2
bon on veut mettre la tour probablement
sur sur la colonne D et doublé euh
doubler ici et en même temps on a évité
fou
C2 et en plus on a
cher fou C2 qui pouvit gagner un petit
pion voyez les Blancs ont fait un petit
peu la stratégie qu'on avait donné avec
C cette on va tir cette barrière de pion
qui fera que les Noirs ne pourront
jamais se créer un pion au passé vous
voyez si euh si les joueurs par joue C6
B5 bah nous on touche à rien et dès
qu'il veut manger d'un côté ou de
l'autre et ben je mangerai et du coup tu
auras des P doublés et tu pourras jamais
te créer une majorité alors que moi de
mon côté j'ai trois contre 4 enfin j'ai
quatre contre TR et quand les pièces
séchangeront je pourrais monter droit
pousser les pions et essayer de gagner
la finale mais bien sûr en contrepartie
ça ça pourrait quand même enfin ça
paraît facile pour les blancs mais en
contrepartie il y la paire de fou chez
les noirs qui fait que à un moment donné
ça avait ça va quand même pas être
facile et puis même ces pions quand même
pas mal de pièces mineures aussi euh
même les tours qui peuvent aussi passer
d'un côté ou de l'autre c'est pas
vraiment évident de de de de créer tout
ça avec les Blancs non en fait disons
les blancs euh ce qu'il adorerit faire
si on pouvait juste enlever une pièce à
l'adversaire enfin il changer ça serait
le fou F5 si on le dégage c'est cool
parce qu'en fait c'est la pièce forte
des noir qui peut circuler à droite à
gauche on voit que si on n pas de tour
par exemple justement il est rang C2
attaquer la la chaîne de pion des blancs
et ça serait un problème et du coup çaut
voilà c'est ce fou qu'il faut surveiller
donc si les blanc pouvait faire c H4 qui
il prend fou il serait ravi ou mais bien
sûr ça se il va pas il va pas te laisser
faire comme ça prend des5 puis on
prendain c'est un peu étonnant je trouve
non de prendre les 5 ouais parce que
j'ai l'IM enfin je sais pas mais de voir
de pion là ça me fait un peu peur mais
ouais ouais bah après je sais pas ce
qu'il devait faire ou quoi peut-être
tour A6 cétait un coup H5 com on voit
des fois après donc oui ce qu'il a fait
dans cette partie qu'on voit moins mais
je sais que c'est parce qu'il a amené le
r C8 d'habitude on voit souvent E8 ouais
euh alorson il des rqué dans tous les
cas de figure mais mais en fait souvent
quand tu vas par là-bas l'idée c'est de
le mettre en C6 en fait en C6 il aurait
été beau mais bon bah oui tu prend D5
mais il y a un coup si tu peux revenir
comme ça vous allez voir l'écran ouais
imagine R en C6 en fait il est
intouchable
ouais et du coup il peut aider et il est
cool donc souvent c'est c'est plutôt
connecté à ça et pour y arriver vu qu'on
passe pas par la colonne D tu peux faire
B6 ro B7 ro C6 et et voilà bon peu
importe mais ouais j'imagine qu' avec
les Blancs bah comme tu le mentionnais
il voulaaient doubler les tours sur la
colonne D peut-être rentrer
euh et il s'est dit vas-y je prends D5
mais effectivement d'avoir pris bah ça
nous remet alors ça donne une nouvelle
structure de pion du coup qui qui est
différente mais les de pion des blancs
ils sont ils sont qu même bien mais ça
me donne aussi uneoortunité d'un jour de
pouvoir essayer de me créer ce bien pass
je voulais parce que c'est on est plus
on a plus vraiment la structure d'avant
mais tu vois maintenant cette pollution
moi j'aime bien genre de qui4 cas
essayer de faire un truc du style la
tour là le fou en B2 et ça a l'air quand
même pas mal le fot cas noir pas
terrible je pense que les blancs sont
mieux en ça a l'air quand même facile à
jouer pour les blancs en tout cas j'aime
beaucoup la pollition de d' ici mais
j'imagine que pour mangant des 5 alira a
dû avoir quand même ses raisons parce
que c'est un C quand même
assez assez assez chaud quoi on a
quasiment un pion passé qui peut se cré
ouais donc de ton coup pourquoi pas de
donc ça momentané c'est bizarre mais dès
j'arrive en C4 ça peut ça va ça va
justifi direct sillumine ouais ouais ça
va être justifié très très vite parce
que B5 là maintenant je mangerai compar
tout à l'heure parce que B5 c'est pas
vraiment un coup même si je préparé ça
m'ouvre vraiment les colonnes tous les P
deviennent fa autour donc c'est pas
génial mais c C4 a l'air plutôt cool
pour blanc avec C4 qui peut arriver un
jour et le fou qui peut même venir en F4
ou un peu de partout je vois pas trop
j'aime pas du tout la position d'alira
ici je trouve que c'est très très dur à
jouer pour lui en on sait pas trop ce
qu'il veut dans la position ouais on
sait pas trop ce qu'il veut été joué
est-ce que fou D3 c'est un coup mais je
pense on va quand même en C4 et s'il
veut échanger en échange ouais en fait
bon je le fais alors j'ai vu que il y a
vis-àis et cetera mais bon je veux
jeouer contre ce cavalier mais c'est
vrai que sur ça bah maintenant c'est la
même position qu'avant sauf que ben j'ai
un pion qui qui va avancer et là il a
même plus la pour les noirs pour conter
tout ça donc ça l' vraiment pas terrible
non mais je sais pas trop enfin j'ai pas
malheureusement de bonnes suggestions
pour pour les Noirs c'est position dure
ouais tour D8 cavalier C4 c'est la
partie salut à tous dans le chat alors
juste pour vous pour vous rappeler de 2
secondes on a euh on a un délai euh avec
vous on a une minute de délai par
rapport par rapport au au chat et du
coup et pourquoi ça bah parce que c'est
un truc enti triche j'imagine oui mais
là en fait enfin je comprends le truc
d'habitude quand le mec joue sur
Internet là il jouent sur internet mais
il jouent en présentiel donc je veux
dire là ils vont pas tricher de Toronto
dans la salle
euh oui mais bon en fait on a on a un
délai on on va oui j' même pas vu jeis
désolé je suis vraiment désolé c'est la
ronde 1 je vous mets le côté noir plutôt
sera mieux avec alza qui est en bas non
je préfère les blancs ah mais si tour
che qui les pendules qui sont qui sont
toutes foutu mais on s'en fout un peu ou
pas parce que là maintenant tu vois sur
le en fait les blancs sont mieux put
j'ai pas trop envie de voir cette
position comme ça
moi le jour où il aura gagné un cavalier
tu remettras comme ça on sera du bon
côté comment oh je de la merde quand ce
cavalier sera
parti je disais j'aimais mieux voir la
position du côté des blancs parce que là
tu vois je suis là de vomir ouais ouais
c'est clè c'est clair oui alors en fait
le seul souci c'est que maintenant quand
on tourne les chqu et qu'on prend le
côté d'alirza et ben les temps sur Obs
vous allez voir que c'est pas très très
beau on a noir sur blanc mais sinon
j'aurais pu changer la caméra de place
dites-moi ce que vous préférez en fait
vous préférez avoir la vue de de de
alira ou préféz juste avoir avoir le
truc bien fait truc tout beau et et et
je change la caméra manuellement je peux
changer de PLACE c'est c'est en deux
clics je change je change les caméras
petit rock avec les caméras mais en fait
il joue sur un échiier les mec ouais
tuasis pas vu encore oui oui par que les
chest tour c'était tout sur Internet et
non mais ouais mais du coup je pensais
que la face finale je savais qu'il jou
en présentiel donc c'est bien mais qu'
jouit sur un ordi quoi moi aussi je t'
face à face là du coup je vois qu'il ont
échiqu je t'avoue que j'ai j'ai installé
le setup hier et j'avais déjà les les
caméras avec les gens qui installaient
la salle et euh il y avait un gros
carton sur la table je dis Mo ça unordi
quoi enfin ouais en fait non c'éit gr
carton un gros carton des GT euh et euh
et du coup euh j'ai eu la surprise quand
ils ont déballé moi j'ai
pas sais tuattends le ton ton ton ton
petit cadeauo tu tu penses qu'ils vont
déballer le truc mais en fait euh tu es
pas enfin voilà tu crois qu'on qu'on
t'offre un ordi et non
oh tu es content tu échiqu c'est ouais
c'est des beaux jeux hein GT il sont
bien qu
moi j'ai un DGT à la maison mais mais tu
as les pièces tu as tout tu tu peux te
non non non j'ai j'ai le DGT qui va pas
sur Internet ah bon mais en fait moi je
m'en fous d'aller sur internet mais mais
tout seul quoi tu te bouches tes pièces
non mais tu sais qu'il y a des gens qui
font ça tu peux en fait brancher un
échquier à aux plateformes aux
différentes plateformes pour pouvoir
jouer depuis ton ton vrai échquier et tu
joues contre enfin tu joues sur mais
avec ton vrai échquier tu peux en fait
c'est possible il il y a plein de manip
à faire mais tu peux le faire mais moi
je pas le faire c'est pas l'idée jeis du
bulette je vais être content de bouger
de pièces mais mais en fait l'idée c'est
que avoir un bel échequ à la maison moi
j'aime bien tu des fois tu même tu fais
des Blitz ou même quand l'envie te vient
c'est très rare chez moi de de d'essayer
de travailler un peu les échecs et ben
tuas tu as un bel échequier pour
travailler et et ça bel environnement
oui non mais c'est vrai c'est cool
d'avoir un bel échquier donc j'ai un bel
échquier c'est un DGT mais il va pas sur
internet donc en fait c'est c'est
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup moins cher
que le vra DGT par
l'électronique alors que franchement la
technologie est pas ouf en fait en soit
enfin ouais ouais bon ça il y a des
capteurs pièces tout ça oui mais bon
voilà bravo mais oui non c'est quoi
c'est 500 balles un échquier un ça
ououais c'est hyper cher oua alors que
moi j' eu
150 mais j'ai vu ouais tuas des beaux
échiquers
euh enfin souvent nous on les trouve une
centaine d'euros mais euh mais genre en
Pologne ou quoi j'en ai vu gen à 50 quoi
tu vois enfin
is donc en fait c'est possible de
trouver des B Chiquet sans ruiner ouais
et d'ailleurs beaucoup beaucoup de de de
bah de marchands si tu veux en fait font
font leur leur course en Espagne
oui ils ont des beaux arbres voilà non
mais il do avoir des
en espne tourneries et des trucs en
Espagne il y a beaucoup beaucoup de gens
enfin il y a beaucoup différents et moi
le mien je l'ai acheté euh c'est il est
nickel hein je l'achète à 100 € à peu
près le mien il est nickel hein
franchement belle pièce hein tu crois au
champ du monde et euh et voilà mais
après il va pas sur internet mais ouais
mais bon pour le coup on s'en F pas de
montrer tous mes talents aux gens déjà
il y en a assez bon tu en as on en a
jamais assez hein
quand même non non on veut on veut voir
ça on veut te voir l'entraînement et que
tu t'entraînes comment tu fais quoi mais
moi je quand quand tu fais bah en fait
ça fait ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas
que j'ai pas travaillé donc je m'en même
plus mais non mais en fait c'est juste
le kiif d'avoir un bel échequier mais
bien sûr non mais c'est un bel objet en
soit toute façon même si tuen fais rien
il est là quoi ouais tu peux l'exposer
c'est c'est noble donc là ça fait un
moment qu'il est là-bas il a pris la
poussière et puis il y a les chats des
fois qui montent dessus mais en plus si
ça fait table de chat ouais ouais mais
bon ça va il faut pas la GRI dessus donc
ça
vaon tu le fais un peu luir tu mets un
truc le chass faire il va patiner il va
pas être bien
quoi non mais toute façon maiss que tu
sors les pièces là c'est là c'est c'est
casino
quoi ça joue à fond avec les
pièces
en Inde non mais après tu peux toujours
commander après je sais pas moi je mais
j'imagine que même quand tu prends un
truc en Inde par exemple tu peux
peut-être trouver des trucs pas cher
mais pour te le faire livrer chez toi ça
ça coûte le prix du du truc quoi donc
ouais donc compliqué ok es en Inde oui
que tu te le ramènes oui après la
valise tis bagage en sout c'est bon euh
bon ça fait longs que je suis pas all en
Inde mais mais je sais que dès que tu
veux voyager alors en Espagne toutes les
compagnies maintenant dès que tu prends
un sac c'est 50 € minimum quoi mais bon
si tu voas en Inde je te conseille quand
même d'amener quelques habits quoi tu
vas pas Jer avec un sac à
dos enfin faites que vous voulez en même
temps les gars c'est et je vous aurais
imaginé et puis bon si tu veux faire
deux trois petits cadeaux outre acheter
des échiquets euh ça peut être bien et
puis sinon tant pis quoi tu tu payes ton
petit supplément et puis voilà
ou sinon vous pouvez y aller en voiture
ramener plein d'chiqu tu prends le
camion tu vas en tu revive ta cette et
tout et puis en plus là c'est économique
parce que tu tu peux te mettre une
couchette et dormir en fait tu es bien
quoi voilà si quelqu'un dans le chat
veut se faire ce périple et après du
coup vous faites êtes le fournisseur des
chiqu des autres c'est un business plan
on vous trouvera le contact pour acheter
làbas bon F3 ça a l'air un peu étrange
on a l'impression que les Blancs veulent
faire G4
ouais monter mais oui mais du coup H4
c'est le coup maisant H4 on a
l'impression qu'on bloque là mais j'ai
peur que ce pion soit un
peu été joué problème sur B6 aussi quand
tu bouff là je peux aussi manger
l'intermédiaire ou donc
j'imagine onataque pas tellement le fou
on croit qu'on l'attaque mais tourné en
l'air
ouais prétend l'attaquer donc faire ce
qu'il veul faire7 j'imagine c'est un
coup comme tu dis par que si tu prends
là prend sur et en plus on prend leou
bonus quo en plus tu prends
F c'est terminé donc7 intéressant
et j'ai pas d'autes coup pour Esser
d'attaquer le pion un cou
supplémentaire mais on peut imaginer que
prochain coup des blancs ça peut être ça
mais j'ai quandme après fou G5 qui peut
encore une fois être pas mal
donc moi j'aime bien B7 prophylaxie tu
défends B6 il f alorsid voil
illimer le défenseur pour essayer
d'aller bouffer là peêre F4 donc là il
vair défendre et sur F F4 là du coup je
continue C B7 tu V finir
PAR2 je pourrais plus faire fou G5 que
j'avais avant voilà
et est-ce que tu penses que ça peut se
terminervec opposé euh tu
styleah en fait ouais tu prendre en D6
et je prs du cavalier
ouais mais je prendrai du
pion en fait ton fot case noir je trouve
moche désolé de te le dire non mais
c'est pas le mien tu peux tu peux hein
ouais mais c'est ton é chiqu euh
ok il a fait t
euh du coup ça F prend C4 il veut puis
on prend le 7 et là on les fout reposé
ouais maisfin fout opposé pas sûr parce
que peut-être que je per la partie
direct
non vite oui mais je pe ah merde [__]
pardon il est fatigué
aujour'hui euh effectivement oui si tu
prends che échec et si tu bouges la tour
je prends ton fou donc là tu fA ou moi
j'étais là à me dire ouais mais si tu
fais tour V j'ai fou G5 du coup je
contrer D8 déjà c'est chiant mais bon i
juste prend fou donc là il
I Je
P
alors le coup est qu'il a joué ou ch il
a jou
il il per
coup ok mais est-ce que je peux
maintenant manger là et manger
là parce que j'ai un pion mais est-ce
que je peux récupérer mon sty Bou CIS
qu' est ravi il est ravi il préfère
avoir un de plus sil peut mais en fait
avec ses deux pions il va bloquer tes
tro et il va jouer sa majorité
roit donc c'est pas la fin de nos
problèmes ouais
ouais il y a plein de problèmes tout le
temps mais bon ok si jamais
j'arrive à à planir un peu la PO ça peut
être pas mal pour les Noirs
mais faut voir encore cette paire de fou
peut être pas mal puis a toujours aussi
des des moyens de rentrer dans les
positions de poser à n'importe quel
moment bon là j'ai pas encore le truc
mais par exemple même prise cavalier
prend comme tout à l'heure on en parlait
ouais pr fou prend puion prend et ça va
on est ouais là bon j'ai un pion de
moins mais Bonon ça mais sans vraiment
parler de manière de manière vraiment
brute de la position très concrète là
c'est opposé même s'il y a un plan plus
ici c'est très très dur de faire des
progrès et ça pourrait peut-être allez
le le bémolin cette histoire des foot
composé tant qu'il y a les tours on
garde quand même des belles chances de
gagner avec les blans il n y aurait pas
de tour ça serait nul direct c'est ça
c'est ça en gros euh donc petit conseil
vous pouvez garder en tête oui voilà
dans vos propres parties si si jamais
parce que même pour pousser en fait on
dit que F c'est nul mais tuas encore les
tours ça joue encore en fait tant que
tuas encore les tours puis même quand
quand tu as que les fous ça gagne des
fois ces positions pe gag en fait c'est
beaucoup de calcul les fin reposé et euh
en fait euh le seul truc c'est pourquoi
ça cette tendance nulle bah c'est que
c'est deux fous qui qui peuvent jamais
se rencontrer donc tu faire un blocus
sur une couleur et l'autre pourra pas
contester donc des fois tu as même pe
avoir deux pions de plus tu te fais
bloquer et bah merde j'avance pas
euh et et voilà c'est un fou sur une
même diagonale peut stopper autant de P
qu'il veut en fait h
[Musique]
euh donc ça donne une tendance comme ça
bon il a fait B du coup il va jouer avec
un P de
moin donc donc il va jouer avec son pion
de MO ouais prise C7 B faut lichon tout
ça dis donc ouais ouais ouais alors il
aura une idée c'est de faire B5 en je
sais pas quand mais un jour et sur prend
B A4 ouais en fait c'est vrai que ce fou
sur 15 blanche sa structure derrière de
pion surant elle est assez faible
et et après B5 on va dstabiliser en fait
deux pions et surtout celui-là qui
défend le cavalier et donc si on fait B5
puis on prend
A4 ben
j'attaque le pion qui défend le cavalier
en fait donc donc ça peut être ça sur ça
quiitable pour pour essayer de faire un
truc peut-être
foue fou he
ouais tu attaques le pion à 5 surprise
ça du coup ch donc Sam qui n qui nous
rappelle dans le chat qu'il y a d'autres
parti à regarder alors on était plus sur
alira et sur Maxime on n pas encore
regardé Maxime d'ailleurs tu un petit
tour sur Maxime rapidement ou si tu veux
ouais c'est vrai qu'on était vachement
sur
alors alors il est pas très bien je
crois que c'est la 4 parce que j'ai des
scènes aussi comme ça il range ses
pièces il range ses pièces ben je le
vois à la caméra il range ses pièces bon
bah a priori il a perdu enfin parce que
vu la position j'imagine pas avoir fait
nul ou gagner en une minute ouais bah il
y a un pion de moins et il y a le pion à
passer et puis il y a des faiblesses et
voilà c'était quoi la partie juste siux
cliquer pourquoi très très rapidement
ouais c qume bien maccepter en je sais
pas pas vraiment non pas du tout en fait
les caméras qu'on les voyait r C piè
c'était la caméra de début en fait il y
a un petit délai donc là on les va
encore réfléchir la partie elle est pas
terminée
encore et en fait nous on a un délai
avec le chat par contre les parties sont
en direct on a pas de délai sur les
parties et sur les caméras donc c'est
j'arrive pas à comprendre trop l'intérêt
mais euh
pour pas que le chat nous parle en
direct
ouais et pourquoi c'est mal euh je sais
pas
ouais c rouge CIX
rouge prise prise F F5 D6 et ouais
ouvrir le foot case
blanche ce P trîn je vois qui va chaque
fois dans les grunf le pion 2 il est
chiant
ouais
euh
ok bon il une finale un peu difficile et
qui par va tenir ouais car en ce moment
il est il est extrêmement chaud aussi
c'est
pasud en forme quoi il a repris du poil
de la bête ouais il était descendu dans
un cam il a une très très mauvaise
mauvaise phase le
pauvre fait moi je trouvais qu'après son
championat du monde cétait mis à moins
bien joué
ouais ouais c'est pas de
maintenant c en 2018 cette histoire et
il était monté à 2832 à ce momentl il
était quasiment enfin car av 2835 il
était qu points et l de lui ouais il AV
et puis le match il av bien joué il av
fait 66 12 nul 0 défaitere Carlsen bon
après il a perdu en rapide les
départages mais donc finaliste du
championnat du monde presque numéro 1
mondial enfin il était il était au
sommet de de ce qu'il savait faire et
après il y a une lente des gringolade où
je pense qu'il a
décompressé il est humain je veux dire
je sais pas il a sûr moins
bossé un peu moins motivé un peu je sais
pas en fait he je sa pas je pas dans son
entourage mais en tout cas ça se voyait
et il avait perdu un truc en précision
il y ait des parties où il était bien et
il avait pas à finir je me souviens
ouais mais peut-être des fois c'est des
fois c'est juste mentalement hyper
difficile de te remettre de de de ah
c'est tellement des forces Championnat
du Monde ouais bah ouais ça fait 6 mois
que tu bosses pour championnat du monde
tu fais un match qui dure qui dure un
mois et et pas était pas loin et et en
fait la déception é tellement grande que
des fois en fait juste tu tiles quoi he
mais euh mais donc oua même sans être au
sommet de son art ouais surtout on
récupère le fou même sans être au sommet
de son art après il avait pas enché
enfin il a toujours été top 10 mondial
clairement même top 5 je pense et il
sétait quand même qualifié au candidat
et il était quand même là
mais mais là en fait on voit qu'il a
remis la marche en avant et qu'il est
qu'il est à nouveau dominant quoi enfin
ah oui là franchement il aé 2008 il a il
a grand Suisse il a été hyper
fort en fait il est revenu aussi fort
qu'il était avant d'arrêter quoi exact
et du coup c'est peut-être aussi le fait
de voir que tu peux devenir champion du
monde qui l'
remotivé parce que bah déjà c'est plus
Magnus Magnus sorti du cycle donc tu dis
bah ouais ok pourquoi pas moi enfin en
fait c'est probablement le en ce moment
le meilleur joueur au
monde ok c'est s car je dire mais dans
les joueurs qui qui VE prétend être
champion du monde ouais et donc il
serait plus ou moins favori après bah
c'est très dur parce que bah dealifier
au candidat on lui il l' et puis il faut
faut les gagner et bon ça c'est pas
simple et puis après fauda quand même
Batt Ding en match ce qui pas fait mais
en gros il a sa chance voilà ben Magnus
est sorti un peu du circuit donc
maintenant j'ai envie de dire que la
porte elle est elle est ouverte quoi
ouis ouais et tout le monde un petit peu
est capable s rid dan ouais bah ouais
tout le mondetin c'est l'opportunité
pour être champion du monde quoi et donc
bah ils ont bien raison tout simplement
ouais et et là carwana qui revient en
forme pour moi c'est le le Clair numéro
2 actuellement en tout cas et bon ben ok
après il va plus ou moins se faire se
faire rattraper par par la jeunesse he
par les prages les goouches qui montent
et cetera mais mais bon actuellement
c'est quand même le CLER num il est plus
fort mais oui toute façon un jour il y a
une passation de pouvoir comme ça avec
les générations et c'est bien normal
c'est pasment que les gens jouent
forcément mieux après he mais c'est
clairement tu as une usure aussi et
compagnie voilà quoi
mais mais mais quoi mais mais donc ouais
caroana en tout cas qui sera favori au
candidat euh mais c'est de gagner
d'avance ces candidats c'est c'est c'est
c'est le temps je préfère suivre en fait
ouais parce que là tu joues vraiment
sûrement sûrement tuur F 5 t H5 là pour
les blancs il est terminé il a pas fait
ah 3 il enêche 3 B4 ça permet aussi
d'avoir une cas de secours
quand je fais échec et que je vais faire
un truc que ça va l' quand même pas mal
aussi j'aimais
bienchanges des tours tu défends tes
trucs tu t' activés au d' là défendre
tout tout tout va pour lui il est
vraiment gagnant là ça va probablement
être joué d'ailleurs après il peut même
prendre son temps tu vois
oui faire tour F5 F4 en faitiment faire
ce qu'il veut son compltement fini en
fait il va avir passer de partout ce
pion qui va tomber objectif qui fait
avoir de contre 1 mvl qui a plus que 9
secondes à la pendue contre une minute
et
euh qui probablement perd cette
partie qui et qui devra qui devra à tout
prix gagner avec les Blancs la partie
d'après pour forcer un dramagedon en cas
de défè sinon sinon il aurait perdu ce
ce micro match contre carwana et euh bon
il y a rien de grave évidemment vous
avez compris que ils vont jouer contre
tout le monde mais étant donné que le
but c'est d'cider dans les deux premiers
pas c'est pas spécialement de bon augur
quoi
ouais alors du coup mvl ce qu'il a fait
c'est pas mal en pratique tu vois il a
quand même ouais mais t B2 ouais en fait
je vais réussir quand même à gagner mais
il y a des finales où quand j'ai
deuxs et ben ça suffit pas et mais bon
là ici j'ai tbé de je vais gagner je
vais garder celui-là et si par exemple
position j'enlève le pion h c'est
censéêtre nul nul bon moi je sais pas
faire mais c'est censé être nul eux ils
doivent savoir faire c'est leur problème
c'est le parti en même temps ouais ou
c'est leur problème mais exactement mais
c'est pour ça que du coup c'est assez
tricky et mvl a volontairement rendu le
pion dans ces conditions là pour essayer
en pratique de trouver un truc mais bon
la position était de toute façon trop
trop difficile allez onetourne sur sur
ala bon on a les fameux reposé mais ça s
amélior quand la donne il a plus rien Mo
de
plus et je
cé est
cont ça va les caméras qui sont par mais
qui vont revenir j'imagine ça un peu de
temps
ok très
vite qui blo le RO et on est fé on en a
parlé cette finale là fameuse et c'est
pas facile de trouver un chemin quandme
c'est ça c'est le blocage sur les
couleurs il veent le mater en fait bon
là si tu fais pr tour tu fais nul déjà
parce que le fou arrête les deux pions
en si flotant et donc tout le monde AR
tout le monde il se passe
rien sur la grande diagonale et c'est
tout là c'est P de partout le est en
prison ouais sortira pas je crois et le
roi blanc suto emprisonne en
emprisonnant l'autre donc il sortira pas
ouais et les fous bougent et voilà bon
nul pour pour Alireza avec les Noirs
donc c'est pas une mauvaise une
mauvaise opération pour lui Magnus a
battu laavic je viens de le voir et
Nakamura il joue encore contre je pense
qu'il va perdre toutous ces matchs on
peut aller voir si vous voulez Nakamura
qui ouais Nakamura qui all les blanc
dans cette partie d'ailleurs donc je
vais vous changer pourquoi il s'est levé
il a qu'un je crois qu'ils ont fait nul
ou pas excuse-moi par là on a un petit
retard euh euh fa la gueule de la
position
euh je sais pas trop non ça joue encore
mais les les joueurs sont
partis en fait les les les gens se
mettent devant la caméra c'est cool du
coup on voit rien peut-être
l'arbitre mais euh camura elle est blanc
en plus donc c'est tout
inversé mais il pas bien
ouais
H2 la Camal est noir he
e no il va gagner mais j'ai cam en
[Musique]
fait j
fac
TR des trucs chelou je pense pas en
fait éta en ha
oui ok ok ok ok non c'est trop chou ce
[Musique]
passe non mais ça
sur c'est différent
deif six
tournois enin six on va dire tournois
pour se qualifier à celui-là il y avait
plein de champion chest tour qui étaient
qui était qui ont été organisé et puis
du coup la Phe finale se joue en live et
puis pour répondre à à Pierre sur le
chat en fait juste pour vous dire les
gars on a une minute de délai par
rapport à vous c'est pour ça qu'on peut
pas vous lire en temps réel donc on fait
ce qu'on peut mais il y a pas du tout de
de on peut pas vous lire en fait tout
simplement le délai c'est c'est chascom
qui le met et nous on on subit on subit
et puis on vous lit une minute après
mais c'est la vie on y peut
rien après c'est pas grave hein enfin
non oui c'est pas grave hein mais après
s'il y a des questions et cetera on peut
vous répondre mais sachez que on aura
toujours une minute de retard au moins
par rapport à la question que euh que
vous poserez quoi ouais genre si vous
demandez un coup précis à un moment le
problème c'est le moment où Onira il y
aura une minut sera passée peutêtre la
évolué à ce momentl ouais ça servira
plus à rien mais malheureusement le
délai imposé par chesscom ben nous on
s'en passe très bien mais mais c'est
comme ça tout simplement
ouais le plus qui été perdu
chez
che et je crois qu'il avait réussi à
revenir dans la partie Naka avant de se
faire retourner en tout cas je l'ai vu à
son body
language je sais pas je vois la Jae qui
bouge et qui plus MOS égal mais en prque
ouais ouais c'est très dur hein il est
chiant et ok on a une qualité de moins
mais fou de pion c'est quand même qu'une
tour en fait ok mais là il pe pas faire
échec échec au lie de faire t reprend G3
il a voulu mater mais euh mais mat quoi
enfin je comprends pas il il a juste
oublé qu'il a F H6 je crois qu'il a d
même si tuas pas F H6 tu fais juste pas
H2 quoi enfin tu ref H4 et au mieux tu
fais nul quoi je veux dire oui oui oui
bizar donc est est-ce que y a deux coups
juste au lieu de faire c'est juste une
question que je me pose qu'est-ce qu'on
a loupé pourquoi il fait pas Échec tuur
ch échec non mais en fait je pense qu'il
a en fait dans dans dans dans les deux
cas il fait nul mais je pense qu'il a
voulu moi je pense que Naka pensait que
c'est lui qui mettait pression et c'esti
qui choisit quand je fais nul tu vois il
s'est dit bon ok je fais t reprends ser
quandme nul quand même et puis après je
me Lass je me lasse des choses mais il
est vrai que si un si a un un réseau de
mat peut-être qu'il a une chance d'un
jour de chiper le P hche et le problème
c'est que même lui en fait il va être
bouffé un jour donc tu auras quasim pas
comment les blancs tu peuvent penser
bien quoi c'est biz c'est déjà bien
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est
c'est l'anniversaire d'ailleurs de Naka
je sais pas si tu as vu ça Fab ben je
l'avais mis dans l'Almanac il a sa page
oui voilà donc du coup Naka qui fête son
anniversaire aujourd'hui et qui cette
partie c'est pas la meilleure manière
mais
mais mais euh voilà alors du coup euh on
va faire une petite pause Fab pendant
que ah ah oui toujours toujours ouais
vous savez qu'on a qu'on a beaucoup de
sponsor qui participe à cet événement et
on a l'obligation de vous montrer les
pubs des sponsors tout ça alors on a
quoi comme sponsor là alors on en a
d'autres qui sont aajouté d'ailleurs qui
sont rajouté et je vais vous les montrer
directement en vidéo donc vous allez
voir direct euh que je me trompe pas et
je vous dis euh à tout de suite
tout de
[Musique]
suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhaner you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from Chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolf magnet kit
and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
chess
[Musique]
displate.com
tr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour avec avec Fab
j'ai pris la mauvaise page bien sûr où
on voit pas notre ami notre ami Fab on
est là avec les joueurs qui qui sont en
train de
s'installer euh donc rappelle un petit
peu des scores on a Alireza qui a fait
nul avec les noirs on a Magnus qui a
battu laavic avec les Blancs on a so qui
a battu euh Nakamura avec les Noirs
Nakamura qui fête aujourd'hui son
anniversaire et on a aussi par contre la
mauvaise nouvelle de la journée c'est
mvl qui s'est incliné avec les Noirs
face à carwana et donc du coup pour tous
ceux qui ont perdu et ben c'est victoire
obligatoire pour euh forcer l'armagadon
on encore gagner voilà gag deux pour
gagner voilà c'est ça
donc donc Maxime un peu de au mur on
camura aussi qui est de au mur et on a
lazavic lazavic céit un petit peu quand
même c'est pas une surprise car quand
même il avir beaucoup de mur dans le dos
je crois dans tout semain après bon il
peut toujours perd une partie hein mais
quand même c'était quand même parce que
Alireza Abdou c'est quand même très très
chaud sonaka c'est très chaud et Maxim
Fabiano c'est très très chaud ou il y a
aucun match qui est qui est évident quoi
alors que alors alors que bon quand même
ça serait une grosse surprise que Magnus
gagne pas
quoi ça c'est ça c'est clair ouais donc
est-ce qu'on suit plutôt Maxime dans ce
dans pour changer un petit pe tu veux
mais ouaison a beaucoup suivi alira
ouais Max qui doit qui doit gagner unu
près cette partie avec les Blancs alors
qu' peut faire nul et et après il y aura
un comment s'appelle un don si nul donc
c'est
ça donc donc voilà al les caméras des
fois qui
sont qui sont pas
[Musique]
euh attends ça je vais faire comme ça je
v vous mettre le score à jour
d'ailleurs je mettre le score je trouve
pas le score il est
où
[Musique]
euh
je un truc pour mettre le score je
trouve
pasb de quoi mettre le
score normalement j'ai un petit truc qui
me dit
score pour l'instant les retenir les ah
je crois que c'est ça ouais j'ai
trouvé bon allez
hop
je pense que la finale sera Magnus et
carwana bah c'est probable c'est
probable on sait
pasonde Maxime qui peut
faire après après bon sur un vra j'ai
l'impression que Magnus encore plus
dominant que sur internet quand même par
rapport aux
autres moi je dirais un petit Magnus
contrepr pièce
tu après c'est c'est tout pas clair tout
est tout est pas clair pour moi ça peut
très bien être al comme Abdou comme
carwana comme so comme Naka comme Maxime
comme ça peut être tout le monde en fait
mais je pense que Magnus il est encore
plus fort je pense en
ouais ok donc ça va commencer dans un
instant on te
qui qui réfléchit c'est pas trop j'ai
l'impression bon soit il son
complètement soit il pense à la BUP qu'
l' raté
c'est plus je perd contre carwana
j'aurais mieux fait d'aller à la BUP bah
ouais il aurait été il aurait été
bien probablement gagné le tournoi il
aurait été acclamé et puis il aur à
domicile bon ok il Toronto c'est
peut-être une ville sympa quand même
ouais je suis jamais allé au Canada
d'ailleurs moi non plus ça serait une
bonne ouais je pense c'est un joli pays
enfin j'avais prévu d'y aller 2020 euh
année covidesque ouais et ça s'est
annulé évidemment et et voilà du coup
j'ai jamais et cette année pour ceux que
ça peut intéresser et bon à vérifier
hein mais je crois qu'il y a tu chaque
année il y a la francophonie là qui
quianise des tournois ah oui ça vaê là
et cette année c'est au Québec je sais
pas trop où mais ça é là-bas si je dis
pas de bêtis ah peut-être mais c'est
censé y être en août cette année je
crois que moi perso les vont pas m'aller
parce que parce que comme faire notre
stage et voilà mais sinon j'y serais
bien allé mais donc si des gens se
disent ah tiens une pierre de coup je au
Canada je joue un tournoi et cetera ça
peut être l'occasion c'est cl c'est
clair commencer c'est
l'esagnol
l'espagnol avec C3
qui vient d'être joué donc ça c'est
hyper classique ce qui se passe la petit
rock a été joué et Maxime qui est oblig
j'ai de gagner cette partie pour se
qualifier donc la vidéo et la partie
sont pas en décalage route c'est juste
nous twitch on est en décalage par
rapport à vous twitch YouTube tout ce
que vous voyez en fait nous on a une
minute de délai par rapport à vous
mais tout le reste tout le reste c'est
c'est du du
direct donc A4 a été joué pour affaiblir
un petit peu le pion B5 très souvent ici
on joue tour B8 réaction assez standard
pour s'enlever du vis-àvis sur la
colonne A iever le fou aussi fou D7 par
exemple aussi fou D7 peut être une idée
pour défendre la tour comme
ceci c'est la
partie et ici sur Carana qui va jouer J
pour l'égalité hein dans cette partie
c'est des mini matchs de deux parties
euh donc pour l'instant 1-0 pour carwana
si kwana ne perd pas ce cette partie et
ben il va avancer en demi-finale
euh par contre si Carana perd cette
partie il y aura un Armageddon avec une
dernière partie qui va se jouer entre
les deux
joueurs donc un maxime est juste obligé
quoi de gagner hein donc cavalier à 5 ok
on va bouger le fou j'imagine qu'on va
le mettre plutôt en C2 pour garder quand
même un œil sur le pion à 4 c'est ça qui
a été
joué et euh et les Noirs prendent le
centre donc C5 on peut imaginer quoi t
peut-être cavalier B3 ça peut être aussi
un
coup la prise aussi ça peut être un coup
mais l'idée c'est quand même
généralement on va quand même jouer pour
essayer de la de pousser des qu he c'est
a c'est qui est thématique ouais c'est
vous avez vu 1000 parties comme ça
c'est aucun problème donc cavalier G3
D4 et et tout devrait bien marcher ici
ouais les noir
ouais
ouais G3 F F F T4 doit être la suite
ouis c'est des c'est des positions qui
ont été vu et
[Musique]
revu par tous les joueurs position on me
dit que j'ai un problème de de micro
alors attends l'HE je l'ai changé sur
une scène peut-être que je l'ai pas
changé surette scè non je pense pas
normalement m'entendre bien je pense
peut-être que tu es trop fort mais je
pense
[Musique]
pas dites-moi
si
balance de son je me suis mis un gain un
gain sur mon micro ciel bleu comme
j'avais fait l de mes streams précédents
avec Tc mais ça marchait bien je me suis
mis un gain de 7 7 et dem et normalement
ça marche bien moi je m'entends pas
malheureusement
mais c'est vrai que Fab il est assz fort
mais je le baisse encore un peu
peut-être
mais est trop fort en fait il est grand
maître
il est grand maître non pas en oui
mais pas trop fort aux échecs d'ailleurs
il s'est passé comment le tournoi à kil
Kenny parce que j'ai pas eu de nouvell
je sais que sais
que Kevin TER il participait ouais et il
était très content l'idée d'y aller et
du coup j'ai pas du tout de
nouvelle ça va il a tenu le
choc il a fait les
soirées euh non mais k Kenny non ben le
tournoir c'est cool Mazo a gagné ok
euh après on a fait une flopée de 2è
execo et moi j'ai gagné le tourno de
Blitz ok bravo et j'ai gagné enfin
j'étais récompensé du du polo enfin de
polo c'est une sorte de petit pull avec
un écusson ou quoi j'étais très heureux
de l'avoir très fier euh parce que
killkenny je joue toi depuis 2010 tu
vois donc j'ai dû faire 14
participations pour enfin avoir le le
polo et donc on peut dire que j'ai
réussi ma vie ça
ben écoute non mais c'est cool Mo ça
fait longtemps que je dis que ce tour
j'ar bien le faire parce que
c'est prochain mais bon ouais il faut
que je m'organise faut que je m'organise
un weekend ça va c'est cool c'est que 3
jours vendredi samedi dimanche il y a si
parties une le vendredi TR le samedi de
le dimanche c'est assez physique c'est
pas temp de jouer au échec le problème
mais plus c'est des parties assez lentes
compte pas pour mais ils ont trouvé truc
le plus l que tu peux faire pour que ça
compte pas ils ont parti de 1 he 30 plus
15 secondes pars
ouais donc en fait tu tu jouche tout le
temps et et c'est du jeudi au dimanche
c'est ça non non c'est du vendredi au
dimanche ah oui c'est 3 jours quoi c'est
3 jours mais tu peux partir le vendredi
matin c'est bon parce que ça commence
dimanche vendredi soir après souvent ce
qu' pas con c'est partir le jeudi si
tuas envie comme ça tu TER à Dublin et
tu peux te faire une petite soirée à
Dublin voir un peu la ville et cetera et
euh et puis après tu as ton vendredi
tranquille pour aller à kinkenny tu peux
aller en bus ou en train train est pas
mal
eTTH voilà mais bon on en reparlera on
en reparlera mais ça peut me beater pour
la prochaine fois bah c'est toujours
enfin les dates sont assez fixe c'est
soit enin c'est allz entre le 15 et le
30 novembre quoi donc tu tu tu tu peux
déjà regarder ton calendrier maintenant
pour cette date là ouais Mo faut que je
me il faut juste que je m'organise à
l'avance mais mais oui c'est la large
large fa cible
tournoi très sympa toujours bien
accueilli c'est une petite petit Blade
en Irlande mignon et
euh voilà c'est cool euh là j'étais moi
j'étais parti quelques jours avant pour
un peu me balader euh j'avais loué une
voiture et j'étais allé à galouet euh
petite ville sympa et une autre ville
j'ai trouvé bien c'est
liimérique en fait j'ai
pris les Ch de s ouais j'ai fait toutes
les vill parari tout ça non j'ai fait
que les deux autres mais oui en fait
c'était vraiment et en fait à vrai dire
j'aurais aimé pouvoir rester plus parce
que le conara était pas loin mais du
coup comme j'avais déjà pris mes trucs
j'y suis pas allé mais j'aurais bien
voulu visiter il y a le fameux ring of
carry qui vaut le coup et donc faudrait
en prochain que refasse un peu plus quoi
que je parte avant le lundi l'année
prochaine peut-être si si je suis chaud
on se le fait quandme voilà tu vas con
et on chantera tu tête ah oui non mais
karaoké dans la voiture non mais c'est
clair que c'est des trucs à faire quand
tu es là-bas tant qu'à faire c'est cool
et et voilà mais ouais moi j'aime bien
voilà c'est un pay que j'aime bien je
connais pas très bien enfin je suis allé
souvent donc du coup Ken je connais bien
Dublin du coup je suis allé c'est
souvent mais le reste du pays non et euh
donc ouais moi je suis allé une seule
fois euh c'était un voyage scolaire
j'avais euh ouais j'étais en collège
quoi
donc je dois avoir 13 ans quoi et euh et
on a visité le l'usine Guinness à Dublin
et bon enfin tu as 13 ans tu sais donc
bon à la fin il te il te donne à boire
mais tu sais il y avait tout le monde
qui conait sa Guinness mais sauf que les
enfants ils avaient ils avaient du coca
comme ça ou mais bon ok mais mais
c'était assez cool c'était cétait
immense l'Usine C c'était bien à voir
c'est très intéressant mais j'ai
toujours pas vu la fois où j'ai voulu y
aller ils m'ont dit ah ben non fallait
rerver à l'avance ah oui ok ouis ça a
l'air d'être assez full et j'ai voulu
visiter autre chose aussi réservé avance
qu' faut quand même résver à l'avance
dans ce pays ouais a des touristes qui
sont là et il paraît que mon son n'est
pas ouf je sais pas et je crois que
c'est ton micro en fait c'est vrai qu'il
est il est très très fort dans mes
oreilles je pense tu peux le bouger un
peu peut-être l'éloigner un peu de ta
bouche comme ça fais voir
parle comme ça euh je pense c'est mieux
ok ben je peux très très loin là là là
là là tu es vraiment très loin mais oui
mais les ça moi ça me fait moins mal aux
oreilles ah ah bah désolé de te faire
saigner des non mais c'est pas grave
t'inquiète bah si j'ai mes tampon là ça
se voit pas
mais mais ouais je pense que le chat il
va va aimer parce que ça je pense c'est
ça le problème en fait ça le problème
ton micro il est un petit peu trop trop
près ok donc cette position il y a eu
dame prend
D3 je pensais qu'il y aurait eu fou pr
tu vois pour attaquer le petit pion en
B5 mais non fait on l'attaquit vaguement
parce qu'il y avait 4 quand même à
surveill et pas envie forcment de Don B3
ou quoi j'en sais rien c'est vra dès que
tu prends là à la fin il y a cavalier
prend 4 et peut-être qu'3 qui gênit mais
après tu prendre les TR ben tu veux en
fait taper sur le P D6 et taper sur la
case D5 avec une pièce donc c'est pas du
tout quelque chose de surprenant je
pense qu'il a envie de jouer B4 si çaie
de jouer ouais B4 et essay de faire C4
un jour mais de toute façon le tu le
domines parce que si VI en C4 tu gagnes
un pion si' va en B7 bah c'est un
charlot ouais et euh dans c'est si c'est
il faut regarder ouais faut regarder si
tu prends mement vis-à-vis donc c'est
intéressant et euh en gros hein la
position qu'on a là euh on me demandera
de quelle ouverture ça vient j'aurais
pensé que ça vienait d'une sicilienne
plus que de 45 parce qu'on a la
structure où le pion d des blancs se
fait échanger contre le pion C des Noirs
donc qui est typique des siciliennes et
des variantes avec le le fameux trou de
woleslavski la caisse D5 et donc les
blancs euh pareil d'un point de
stratégique euh si jamais eux ils
pouvaient changer pas mal de pièces
adverses c'est les trois pièces légères
les cavaliers et le fot cas blanche et
les noir que avec le fot cas noir bah
les blancs seraient mieux parce qu'il
serait une pièce tout pourri à
l'adversaire et il pourrait aller sur la
case des 5 avec ce qu'ils veulent si on
pouit changer ça oups pardon mon micro
ça contre genre ça euh on serait content
parce qu'on mettrait lui ici et le fou
en F8 pleurerait derrire structure il
fait ce qu'il veut mais il est nul quoi
ouais c'est ça c'est un peu l'idée mais
bon carwana il va pas se laisser changer
tout comme ça gratuitement et euh
d'ailleurs très souvent aussiid des noir
ça peut être un jour de jou des 5 hein
sont très heureux tout à fait ouais gen
dame B7 F C6 et c'est de jouer D5 c'est
un thème assez récurrent dans ses
positions trois choses l'une des c
ça ça empêche ça prive les blancs de la
forc D5 du coup comme il sert occupé par
les noirs et qu' AA un échange ça enlève
la faiblesse noir en D6 par la même
occasion et ça ouvre le fou et fite qui
devient une bonne pièce ouais c'est ça
c'est le coup libérateur hein c'est le
coup libérateur dans toutes les
siciliennes de toute façon on vous dit
que D5 c'est le coup que que tu depuis
le premier coup de ta sicilienne tu veux
jouer des5 en fait pourquoi pas jouer la
scandinav en fait ça il y a pas il y a
pas de problème sur le P
des6 là après tu peux toujours avoir
unable toujours arriver à un petit un
petit prend D6 qui arrive à un moment
donné je sais pas pourquoi mais
d'ailleurs la scandinave avec avec deux
cavaliers FC elle est pas bonne à Cuse
de
D6 et je te rends ton pion AR quoi donc
je prends de la
dame ok VO là j'ai plus rien à dire j'ai
plus de j'ai plus d'arguments mais tuas
le deuxième pionné que tu pe essayer de
tu fais des 4 des 5 des si mais tu tu
vas me jouer 6 je pourrais pas passer la
5è ça qui me dérange mais mais
bon ok donc en tout cas mvl qui a un
grande réflexion ici et euh
eTTH et c'est compliqué un gros barrage
là par par caroana on sait pas trop
comment on va passer va aller B4 mais
c'est il a joué quoi la Carona c'est
dernier
coup il a juste poussé a 6 B5 C4 en gros
ouais et il est k [__] il a il y a eu
C dame C7 pour mettre le car en C4 et là
on a un pion passé protégé pour
l'instant alors bien sûr encore très
loin la promotion mais on sent peut-être
que ça peut partir de là mais il a du
potentiel ou il y a du PO tu c'est une
position un petit peu la structure elle
est pas symétrique il y a il y a des
choses à faire bah lesén veul faire des5
toujours je pense ouais des5 ça va être
l'idée je pense B7 F6 ça va être pour
Rais tout à l'heure mais ouais voilà et
puis même ce P il quand même t à passer
j'ai ma part de fou qui
pas génial derrière mes pions mais bon
j'ai passé ce pion C4 qui peut toujours
être un peu faible j'aimerais bien que
le C soit E3 PL F3 mais c'est beaucoup
de boulot pour y arriver ouais bah si je
pouvais être là ça serait quand même
plus sympa C4 tu peux avir çac tu tu
canalises le D5 mais du coup pour y
arriver faudrait jouer tour B1 fou K2 C
cavalier3 c'est très très lent ouais et
le problème c'est que les Noirs vont
avoir le temps de de faire des choses
pendant ce temps-là
quoi euh donc là regardez si D5 déjà
jouable sinon il peut faire un coup
comme fou B5 histoire de bloquer un peu
le pion défendre C4 et compagnie G6
j'imagine do pas être trop naz histoire
deêtre le fou en G7 et préparé peut-être
enlever le califire F5 peut-être si tu
fais des 5 un jour de toute façon tona
pas trop mal donc ouais je pense soit il
va essayer de faire marcher des5 dès
maintenant soit fou B5 pourquoi pas soit
G6 je pense c'est trois coups
raisonnaablees
ouais je regarder le
le le les horaires là des trucs parce
que en fait je vérifie bien ce que
j'avais tout à l'heure il y a bien une
demi-heure de pause entre les deux
matchs et
ok bon on verra sur le le moment
venu tout est écrit avec l'horaire local
donc c'est bizarre pour moi mais chez
eux il est tôt encore chez eux là 6h de
moins làbas non 6h de moins
bah ou au moins quoi ENF je 6h au
minimum la round 2 elle a commencé à
1045 euh donc c'est 7h de Mos en fait 6h
moins 6h CIT 18h45 ouais après ils ont
une pause ils reprennent après mais
attends ça part à 45 ça fait pas 30
minutes qu'on regarde ça là déjà
euh ben
peut-être non je pense pas ça fait
environ demiheure je pense 25 minutes je
crois ça
repris une très très très bonne question
de Lopo dodo qui demande si la qualité
de l'air peut faire la différence et
avoir son mot à dire parce que l'air est
seulement faer il est pas tu vois il est
pas pur très net et effectivement
effectivement là c'est les joueurs qui
se seront entraînés à haute altitude qui
vont peut-être faire la différence qui
onont monter
leur taux de globule dans le sang euh à
noter hein que là tous les joueurs
jouent du même endroit donc voilà ceux
qui é habitués à vraiment avoir le
bonheur chez eux à bien à bien tout
contrôller avec le boîtier jouer fenêtre
ouvertees bah là ouais ils sont au
Canada c'est l'hiver fenêtre fermée tout
dans la même salle ça suit un peu donc
ouais ouais ouais bien sûr ça ça peut ça
peut être important et comme je te dis
là ceux qui seront entraînés en haute
altitude à mon avis ça pourrait parler
alors peut-être pas dans les premières
rondes là on est en début de tournoi
mais après de TR jours de jeu les
parties du soir là ça commence à tirer
dans les jambes quoi en dans dans les
doigts du clic
ou euh alors il y a eu des coup tour à 5
donc là il a la position qui s un peu
décanté avec le pion 4 qui a été qui a
été changé et donc les fou qui pourrait
peut-être un jour être plus actif en
tout cas j'aime bien le tour à 5 de
Maxime qui attaque le cavalier et qui
menace aussi de pousser un petit peu sur
le long terme
le pion ces pions qui sont toujours un
petit peu faibles tu vois que le pion C4
il est pas facile à défendre euh le pion
4 il il est en prise mais bon il y a un
clouage c'est pas sûr du tout que j'ai
vraiment envie de le manger on tout cas
pas tout de
suite le défendreer cavalier F6
ouais écoute je suis pas je suis pas
mécontent de la position de Maxim je
pense qu' potentiel il y a clairement
des des choses à faire avec ce pion qui
il faut il faut vraiment attendre tu
vois de bon moment pour le pousser pas
aller trop vite non plus parce qu'après
il peut être faible il peut être bloqué
et faible mais c'est pour la finale qui
peut être vraiment potentiellement très
fort en tout cas les blanc on gagné la
colonne et maintenant il faut essayer de
trouver comment jouer qu'est-ce qu'on
peut jouer il fauter le cavaliier j'im
cavalier F6 m' l'air très très
logique cavalier F6 comment est-ce que
je peux continuer
euh comment tu joues sur sur sur ton sur
C là en fait j'ai pas de plan
malheureusement pour continuer quoi
peutre on fait FO 4 F 4 tu veux changer
le fou ouais mais je sais pas si je veux
mais ouais non plus c'est pour ça que je
sais pas si on mais bon vas-y on le fait
quoi mais c'est vrai qu'en fait si tu
restes avec ce fou là à la fin même si
tuis tu pas si mal d'échanger et après
C je sais pas trop como faire en fait je
suis muré par les pions adverses ouais
et en plus après j'ai même du B5 qui
peut être aussi intéressant peut-être je
fa dame D1 dame1 ça j'ai pensé aussi
dans l'idée parce que même là en fait je
pensais à ça ça et même ça un petit
passage sur F4 un jour et puis après là
bien sûr c'est cavalier parti en F6 je
pensais parce que là il aur cavalier pr
F4 bien
sûr en tout cas petite pression quand
même pour pour les blancs il y a aussi
même un un fou qui pe sympa j essayer
Decher par sur la case A7 pour rentrer
un peu
plus on veut le manger je
[Musique]
pense c'est un peu tout qui en prise à
voir si je peux tenir peut-être dame D2
et et
E3 pas
évid puis il y a même du foupran B4 a
qui peut arriver parce que le cavalier
sera en prise une fois que tu manges en
B4 si ça ça donne pas trop envie il faut
pas prendre
C4 F4 ouais mais du coup tu peux C mange
etre un alors j'ai3 tu as pas envie de
le faire à cause des cas
blanches mais peut-être qu'on va le
provoquer parce que je enfin je si je
veux je te ferai F des 6 quoi est-ce que
d'ame 3 c'est coup par exemple est-ce
que la finale elle est pas si mal pour
moi en me disant que tes pions sont
faibles et que ma tour est là et que
je potentiel tu m'empêches de
passer je suis pas sûr de vouloir
échanger comm pas pas vraiment ti il a
joué il a joué un il a joué un cou on
pas pensé du tout il a je E3
euh hop il a je E3
ok ah euh ouais mais je sais pas trop
pourquoi encore mais euh voilà euh il a
fait TR quo ouais alors on demande dans
le chat si c'est l'ation directe et ben
non c'est pas l'ion directe pour
l'instant là on est en phase de pooule
on est en face de pooule donc il y a
huit joueurs qui se qui se rencontrent
les deux premiers de la pooule sont
qualifiés pour les demi-finales euh les
deux derniers sont éliminés et euh les
quatre du milieu joueront des phases on
va dire à enfin des phases oui je crois
que c'est pas ça un mode Survie je crois
c'est une sorte de oui de d'élimation
directe quoi pour se qualifier pour les
demi-finales donc là c'est pas c'est pas
encore élimination directe hein là on
est encore dans
le dans le truc donc même si Maxime perd
il a encore il a encore des des bons ESP
de quoi faire quand même hein euh il va
jouer contre tout le monde fa capter
pourquoi il un P
car alors que j'ai pas trop regardé vu
que je regardais non mais il a fait TR
bah Max a pris le cavalier il a pris le
four voilà prend ah oui ok
euh bon voilà enfin du coup les blancs
sont mieuxpr je sais pas ça va gagner
parce qu'il y a quand même la paire de
fou en face
et voilà mais bon il a quand mêmeasas
déjà juste un pion pour rien de plus et
c'est ouais tu un pion plus le fou qui
peut peut-être sortir un peu de tout ça
et ce pion qui peut être sur le long
terme perdu aussi ça m' l'airêtre quand
même une très belle position pour Maxime
je crois fa je crois que il peut il peut
égaliser allez on risque
d'avoir tu veux on peut aller voir un
peu le reste mais on reviendra voir
Maxime attentif allez on va se prendre
un petit peu alira alira qui table 1
avec les
Blancs contre ils ont fait nul à la PR
partie donc là c'est la deuxème
partie donc c'est quoi l'ouverture juste
cuosité
l'ouverture OK
je passe assz
vite direct
voilà ok
F1
H3 moment donné 4 àond mais blan le
intion c'est ça et la
prise pas du tout
alorsarve ou ouais moi je pensais
directement à qu'avaller prendre le 7
suivi de prise en en E4 avec essayer de
faire un truc comme ça ça pe hein mais
je crois que la jauge elle est pas
d'accord avec ce que je dis la jauge
elle reprend juste si j fa voilà on a
rien à chercher mais c'est vrai que ça
et ça ça l'air quand même assez fort he
ça a l'air sympa ouais ça a l'air assez
facile fait quoi fou à
deux euh ok il veut échanger le fou B1
pour prendre 4 mais euh mais bon
euh
là là il est clairement clairement
clairement dans dans ce qu'il préfère la
tactiqueattaque donc là j'ai
absolument aucun doute sur le fait qu'il
vaorter la
partie est très loin ce fou fallait le
voir le
voir ou si tu veux faire çare faire5
d'abord ou je sais pas quoi mais en gros
faire gaffe enfin par qu'il est il a de
la ressource
oui Abdou il est il est extrêmement mais
ouais peut-être juste prendre C5 toi qui
s barré ouais tu prends là et tu prends
là et manger du pion et je prends deux
fois mais je prends 4 ou on prends des 7
tu prendras E2 bon HM tout
déchanger et j'aurais rien en plus pas
génial de
rien euh4
[Musique]
ouais peut-être faut prendre je sais en
fait ça me semble pas si simple la jeu
j'ai très énervé mais
ouais c'est il y a quand même une grosse
pression là-dessus quoi Mo disons je
sais pas je je me senstir mieux avec en
fait j'aime pas alless un centre mobile
ça me tuas une épée de damoclassus de la
tête c'est toujours chiant je trouve à
jouer h euh mais pour autant c'est
pas je vois moi qu' a un gain clair en
force
mais c'est encore trop net quoi je monte
juste o pr G3 pour ciel bleu les enjeux
de tourno ben il y a il y a des il y a
de
l'argent a de l'argent et puis c'est la
finale du gros tournoi internet de
l'année bon là ils sont plus sur
Internet hear mais bah les prix je peux
vous les montrer hein ah alors la
cillass euh alors le
premier prend 200000 € quoi 200000 le
premier € pas mal pas mal mais de boulot
c'est bien c'est un tournoant en fait si
tu veux il y a eu six tournois quand
même euh ils ont déjà pris de l'argent
avant d'ailleurs voilà il ils ont cumulé
pas mal de tournois tout au long de
l'année avec plein de mini tournois et
là c'est la grande tunnel avec 200000 au
premier donc après ils ont ils ont déjà
des tu vois et donc il y a eu plein de
califes donc donc 2 200 au premier
100000 au 2e 3 4 50000 chacun 5e 25 6e
20 7e 15 8e 12000 et en plus il y a 1000
€ enfin 1000 dollars pardon en
prime pour chaque gain dans le tournoi
tout ronde dans électrique ok donc donc
déjà car qui a gagné la
partie encaiss c'est quoi c'est les
matchs gagnés ou c'est les parties gagné
ah il parle de match gagné
effectivement dans le tout Ron ok ouais
ok donc là il a pas encore gagné son
match ça c'est inpide quoi non c'est
cool non
maisp mais je dire quand tu gagnes
200000 tu vois bon
ou ou ben je me je me souviens pour
boire quoi je me souviens à l'époque
j'avais tu sais il y avait le le le le
fameux Amber qui se jou à Nice là avec
tous les kraamniic Anand et cetera et
puis bon moi céit àce donc j'étais tous
les jours là-bas jeais tout le temps et
puis il y avait l'arbitre qui à côté de
moi il avait une feuille dans sa main
avec les prix et puis les résultats il
marquait tout à la main et puis j'avais
vu les pris c'était hallucinant parce
qu'à l'époque tu avais pas internet
maintenant enfin comme avant tu sais c
et en fait euh comme je savais que
c'était 1000 € en prime par partie gagné
ouais et euh et donc en fait j'ai vu
qu'il y avait il y avait une partie de
donc c'est partie à l'aveugle tu sais
qu' on joue à l'aveugle et en rapide et
la partie
ou C
g7is ouais ouais mais ça ça fait un
moment que qu'on s'y attend clignotit le
truc ouais et et du coup il y a eu an
qui a eu cette fameuse partie avec de de
cavaliers contre un pion tu sais ah il a
mettait bah non il il a eu la flemme ah
ok je m' f ouaisoua Il il a fait Pat
mais par enfin il a fait exprès mais
c'était nul ou c'était une dé position
gag alors je crois que ça a gagné mais
bon c'est une partie qui joue à
l'aveugle bon je peux comprendre qui
mais bon pour 1000 € je vais quand même
essayer de faire un effort quand même
mais lui je crois qu'il s'en
foutit mais je comprends il y a
tellement d'argent en fait au final 1000
€ c'est quoi bah c'est le tu vois c'est
le c'est le pourbire quoi ouais c'est le
pourbire mais mais bon 1000 € pour faire
un effort de 5 minut nous normalement on
Fa les open pendant 10 jours et si à la
fin on gag 1000 on est content quoi
ouais c'est ça c'est pas pour une partie
gagnée sur un on va tu avais tout fait
tu avais tout fait hein la position
cétait la fin de la position je crois
que c'était gagnant bref mais bon éce
qui va gagner si tu veux on peut
retourner voir Maxime il va gagner hein
ça ça sûr que ça va gagner ça c'est
terminé on va tomber chez Maxime qui qui
qui doit gagner pour pour rester hop
c'était là numéro 4 il me semble ou
chercher l'armon alors il a j son pion
de plus
euh c'est bien ouais il a réussi à
ramener la tour A7 et H5 qui va arriver
avec le visàis là 15 secondes ouais ça
l'airement gagnant les caméras ai ça
gagne de partout cocorico allez ouais
arch gagné Maxime qui va qui va
remporter G3 très solide professionnel
moi j'aurais fait H5 ah bah tiens
professionnel il a peut-être dû
m'écouter il s'est pris un deux points
d'interrogation euh fou D5 ok h 5 on a
quand même envie de le faire encore il y
a le GR visis
ok je te mette pas quand même non non
peut-être pas je sais pas moi de toute
façon tu as pas le choix avec les noir
tu pas mat tu es pas mat mat mat mais
j'avais pas vu ta menace mais alors
juste je je vais tricher une secondde
jeis mettre
l'ordi pourquoi est-ce que alors bien
sûr H5 c'était mon coup
fait et là il fallait faire fout des qu
what qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ah
tuinterceptes ah ouais mais bon ça puis
on prend je prends la tour une photo
tiens
vas-y prends la photo fou des4 ah c'est
ouf et c'est le seul coup c'est pour ça
que j'ai TR est pas bon ils ont raté ça
ouais c'est c'est c'est extrêmement
difficile hein bon ben de toute façon H5
il va faire mais c'est pas facile enfin
je dire il va faire faut calculer et
puis tu donnes une pièce quand
même donc en fait c'est pas si simple
pour ou en fait je pense quec 3 minutes
contre 8 secondes tu te
dis en si tu peux gagner tout seul que
ça gagne tout seul tu tu as envie de
faire quoi ouais et c'est Ccile qui qui
voudrait se mettre aux échecs du coup
que TR c'est pas mal de gag 50 K comme
ça je suis d'accord ah ouais ouais non
mais moi j'aimerais bien faut être forte
mais
mais ouais c'est c'est il y a beaucoup
d'argent en fait dans les éches bah au
très très haut niveau ça marche pas mal
mais mais bon il faut se lisser dans les
10 premières dans les 10 premières
places mondiales et là tu as une chance
peut-être de de bien vivre mais sinon à
part ça très très bien vivre ou Roy tu
es Roy le bar quoi ouais non mais après
sinon niveau en dessous comme nous bon
on peut donner des cours et cetera et on
peut s'en sortir mais de juste être pro
par le jeu on n'est pas assez fort ouais
ouais clairement pas bah il faut pour
être enfin pour pour vivre correctement
je pense qu'il faut environ peut-être
2006 20650
euh pour très bien vivre il faut au
moins 2007 et encore tu es peut-être pas
forcément si bien que ça je pense que
2007 50 tu vois non mais bon avec toute
les ligues les machins selon dans quel
pays tu es tuasir les équipes nationales
ton championnat national ton machin bon
tu V
euh bon
écoute Maxime qui a pas trouvé le H5
ouais qui était pas facile ça dev une
pièce autant cel que tu vis jouer toi
tout à l'heure méga logique mais je
crois qu'en fait c'est plus hisire pour
il a voulu assurer ouais ça gagne petit
à petit tout seul mais en fait il va pas
tomber Carana parce qu'il y a du rajou
de toute façon et et en fait si jamais
il te fait dame D2 qui t'change les
dames ou quoi tuas C3 qui peut tomber
enfin pere tu vas pas gagner en
fait enfin là ça pr tour tout d'un coup
la partie je sais pas c'est tout allait
très bien c'était autoroute vers la
victoire et là tout d'un coup sur tour à
7 il aur pas d'AM des de bah ce que je
me dis Mo ouis et ce pion il risque de
tomber un
jour le jour est proche quoi il est pas
lointin donc 8 secondes à la pendule
mais il y un incrément de 3 secondes
donc en fait normalement tu tombes pas
c'est la partie faut prend G6 ou il y a
des choses qui se passent là sur F pr il
y avait d' pr le6 donc il a mangé du roi
qu'est-ce qui se passe et maintenant sur
F5 je prends le fou et sur fou F5 qui
m'a l'air d'être un peu un seul coup il
F65 avec une seconde à la pendule
jouer h 5 ça a l' ça a l'air pas bien
faut trouver encore le il faut trouver
le G c'est ça que G4 peut-être G 4
comment je te term
ou F3 et en fait le qui part ici je te
mange terminé ici et Maxime qui égalise
cette partie pour arriver au un
Armagedon qu'on va voir d'ici un instant
ah al un instant un instant bon quand
même ils vont nous faire un peu
patienter il a une petite pause quand
même parce qu'on aime bien les Paes la
MO des
chosesou on peut aller voir peut-être
ouais Magnus qui a gagné
contre alira a gagné aussi et on va
voirarou ikarou il y a personne à la
table mais je pense c'est normal parce
qu'en faitou il noir il
je va il doit gagner en
plus bah il su il va fa bouffer à 6 la
tour va bouger il va faire pousser le
pion a tour B si un truc comme ça
non c'est complètement fini hein ikarou
qui qui fête son anniversaire
aujourd'hui avec un un petit 0 sur de ça
pas être son meilleur anniversaire je
pense du coup il y aura que un seul arm
guedona CELI de de Maxime alors est-ce
qu'ils font leurs enchères et tout ça là
je crois que
oui enfin en tout cas je sais qu'il y en
a magedon je je sais pas je vais
regarder mais je je vais je vais je je
lirai pendant la pause pendant la pause
je lirai et je vous redirai si euh s'il
y a des enchères de toute façon je j'ai
j'ai j'ai tout ouvert je vous regarderai
ils ont fait nul alors bien évidemment
euh so a pas voulu se prendre la tête
parce que euh voilà le match est gagné
donc je vous rappelle c'est des matchs
en deux parties aller retour en cas
d'égalité il y a un Armageddon s'il y a
un joueur qui fait 1 et demi sur de il
est gagne le match et puis basta et donc
du coup il avait gagné la première
partie donc il a aucun intérêt de gagner
la deuxième alors bien sûr s'il gagne
c'est bien mais de gagner la partie sur
match nul c'est exactement la même chose
donc bah répéter c'est comme gagner en
fait c'est comme mat enfin c'est pareil
il y a aucun incidence sur Leo
euh voilà puis en plus comme tout à
l'heure on l'a dit financièrement tu
gagnes 1000 dollars de plus parce que tu
as gagné le match je pense ikarou il est
en PLS de pas avoir gagné
son je pense qu'il est pas bien
euh c'est pour ça d'ailleurs rich quit
la
salle bah ouais 0 sur de quand même
c'est c'est quand même dur pour lui euh
c'est sévère je trouve mais c'est comme
ça donc là on a Alireza qui gagne 1 et
demi à 0 et demi contre absorov donc il
prend une belle option quand même dans
ce tournoi on a Magnus qui fait aussi un
et demi sur de contre
lazavic on a westle qui gagne 1 et demi
du coup 0 et demi contre Naka et mvl qui
s'est bien refait et qui a gagné la deè
partie pour forcer un Armagedon contre
carwana
donc donc du coup on va attendre une
petite pause alors si si je pas de
bêtises
il y a
[Musique]
normalement il y a un peu de retard par
rapport à ce que je vois mais mais il y
a une petite pause alors je dirais que
là il y a combien de temps une demiheure
une demiheure expliquer l'histoire des
enchères 15 minutes excuse-moi bon les
enchères c'est simple en fait en gros
l'armagedon le principe c'est que les
Blancs ont plus de temps que les Noirs
la pendule donc historiquement céit 5
minutes 4 mais obligation de gagner
c'esten qu de parties nul les Noirs ont
gagné voilà donc c'était le but bon là
ils ont fait une petite variante c'est
des parties qui durent 15 minutes comme
vous voyez donc ils font de l'armon sur
15 minutes mais du coup ils disent pas
tu joues 15 minutes contre 14 ou quoi il
disent tiens vous enchérissez celui qui
demande le moins de
temps bah aura les Noirs donc après
c'est les joueurs qui voient à quel
point ils veulent il préfèrent les noir
les blanc genre en si tu'en veux pas tu
notes juste que tu veux 15 minutes quoi
et puis bah en gros tu t'assois tu dis
bah j'aurai les blancs et puis je m'en
fous mais sinon en gros quand même c'est
normalement mieux d'avoir les Noirs
parce que tu joues pour deux résultats
et pas que un et autant quand c'est du
Blitz tu peux te faire tomber enfin
quand c'est 5 minutes contre 4 à un
moment même si la position égale tu as
quand même joué un moment moment tu as
30 secondes contre 45 B ces 15 secondes
là le mec il te joue vite vite vite à un
moment tu peux tomber et c'est une des
armes pour les blancs bon si c'est 15
minutes contre 12 il faut fautir
longtemps quoi pour tomber AC 12 minutes
quoi j'ai envie de dire
donc donc sans cet arme là disons c'est
c'est plutôt avantageux d'avoir les
Noirs c'est pour ça que les gars sont
même peut-être prêt de descendre
quasiment à prendre 7 minutes ou je sais
pas je sais pas queles en ils vont faire
mais euh mais à mon avis sont en train
de lire le format mon avis moi je sais
pas je je serai même prêt à prendre
ouais 7 minutes ça doit ça doit is c'est
une limite peut-être mais mais euh mais
B 15 cont 10 je suis sûr que les sont
favoris allez alors attends je suis ici
euh
Armagedon match format ok
[Musique]
ouais en fait je crois que c'est ça il
parle de
de message attends
ouais c'est ça en fait c'est ça donc ils
vont faire un Armagedon en comme on
faisait avant je crois 54
bah non non non non non comme on faisit
avant commandé sur internet avec leur ah
ouais il faut le en cher parce que il
parle de que chaque player enfin chaque
joueur va communiquer au l'official du
tourfin à l'arbitre quoi euh en message
privé le bid entre parenthèses bid euh
donc je pasce que c'est bid mais
j'imagine que c'est le son petit Paris
quoi son petit bête
euh et que le plus bas gagnera le truc
donc c'est il y a un gros texte de je sa
pas 10 lignes j'ai pas tout lu mais de
ce que j'ai lu en en en diagonale ça
avait l'air de matcher avec ce qu'on
avait l'habitude d'avoir donc euh
peut-être c'est ça voilà bon en tout cas
là j'ai vu sur C qu'on demande les gens
demandent des informations et
apparemment ils disent que on va le
savoir en derni moment euh donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a vraiment un un un un
système de de de bête quoi voilà
d'ailleurs on te voit plus euh Fab c'est
normal parce que je vais regarder autre
chose ok bon on fait une petite pause
pour vous montrer un petit peu les euh
les les pubs vous savez qu'on a des
obligations au niveau des de nos
sponsors et cetera donc je vous dis à
tout de suite pour la suite à
toute
[Musique]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian defense to the
untrained ee this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from Chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfe magnet kit
and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
chess at
[Musique]
displate.com
et nous sommes de retour avec les
joueurs qui sont installés qui ont l'air
de bien réfléchir mais vous savez qu'on
a pas encore la partie nous ça c'est
bizarre j'ai une partie qui commencé
mais c'est celle-là et j'ai pas de coup
il marqué 1 0 j'ai pas de coup
Fab il a pas encore gagné je crois euh
donc ouais juste pour vous dire donc
Carana a fait l'enchère la plus basse
donc il aura il aura les noirs et il a
pris quoi 932 c'est ça alors oui alors
les les ce qui s'est passé donc il y
avait des questions tout à l'heure pour
expliquer un petit peu les enchères
comment ça se ça se passe un peu tout ça
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'on a
eu
euh fais voir Mo
ok non en fait personne peut voir la
partie
euh c'est parti non mais non mais euh ou
non c'est peut-être la même partie que
tout à l'heure qui nous passe en boucle
ouais c'est la partie de de de de de
firou firou qui passe en Bou tout à
l'heure donc c'est pas du tout ça fausse
this is fake news ouais c'est pas du
tout la partie de de Maxime et euh donc
ne vous laissez pas berner ça non non
non là moi je suis sur sur sur slack et
sur SLAC il disent que
euh que ils sont en train de travailler
sur le DGT donc en fait là la partie a
commencé on le sait mais ça va venir un
bel truc pour DGT hein c'est 500 € les
chiier comme on disait c'est ça on parl
salut Arnaud
et du coup en fait voilà alors mvl il a
parié 10 minutes 32 alors que Fabi a
parayé pour 9 minutes
52 donc le le Paris le plus bas et ben
du coup
c'était c'était Fabi donc c'est Fabi qui
a gagné donc il choisit d'avoir les
noirs et donc Fabi peut se permettre de
faire match nul dans dans ce match s'il
fait nul il a gagné euh et bien ben il
gagne ce match euh et Maxime perd Maxime
doit absolument gagner mais il a plus de
temps il avoir 15 minutes contre 952
donc quand même deux fois
enin quasiment quand même presque le
double de temps
ouais ouais le truc c'estçon plus Maxime
il joue vite de base donc il va essayer
de mettre la pression à la pondule c'est
sûr ouais il y a pas d'incrément je
crois en plus non ben non ENF j'espère
pas je dem en amargadon quoi si il me
semble qu'il y a un
incrément à partir de d'un de ouais mais
j'aime pas enfin je veux bien croire
mais en fait en fait l'arme
gueddon ça doit se jouer au k quoi c'est
le principe du truc et c'est comme ça
quoi et tu as les Noirs bah tuas les
Noirs faut que tu acceptes de pouvoir
tomber quoi si en plus on te donne du
rajou un moment c'est ind descend
l'avantage que ça quoi ouais je vois
nulle partcrit qu'il y a un incrément
donc on verra bien euh tombe quoi bah
tombe quoi c'est tout mais pr fois tu
prendre les blancs et puis c'est je sais
pas enfin qu'est-ce que je te dise
quoi je sais pas sinon pourquoi 30
secondes sur l' incrément et puis tu
joues sur ton sur ton incrément
quoi ok bon euh on a toujours pas la
partie j'ai toujours mon il sur SLAC
donc alors je vais essayer si vous
voulez de mettre j'ai un écran où on
voit un peu plus un peu mieux je crois
que c'est celui-là non c'est pas là
c'est celui-là mais les tes sont vides
mais Maxime c'est l'chquier
numéro 4 attendez hein les caméras qui
vont revenir
joue ou quoi mets-moi la
caméra please caméra tu peux revenir
s'il te plaît la caméra qui qui ouais on
voit rien en fait on voit absolument
rien mais si vous voulez on peut rester
comme ça le temps tant que la partie
reprenne c'est on reste
comment
comment c'est-à-dire on bah j'ai mis
grande caméra mais mais on est très loin
et on voit rien du tout hein mais comme
j'ai pas la partie et ben au moins ça
permet de de de les voir eux un peu
mieux mais la position on la voit pas du
tout hein là c'est complètement
impossible de déchiffrer ce qui se passe
euh mais mais du coup on verra bien
alors les enchères bah en fait
normalement si tu veuxarmagedon c'est 5
on a dit tout T avec Fab c'est 5 contre
4 ou 5 contre 6 d'ailleurs ça dépend un
peu mais mais du coup là ils ont voulu
innover dans un truc un petit peu
différent un truc un peu psychologique
de pour combien tu prends les blancs
quoi hein vous savez que
oui ou les blancs ou les Noirs enfin
c'est pareil en fait l'idée c'est que la
partie qui repart mais c'est pas la
bonne partie ça c'est la partie de
non je même pas ah il y a eu le fameux
H4 qui est intéressant
d'ailleurs mais
ça av ok ça j'ai
j maintenant en direct i
début commenc
minutes lae
dir tu veux
direenir du coup sur la positionutre vue
pas préfrez c dit Laue
préfz et du coup alz bizarre en la
pendule il y a
pascrément et
pu bien position qui joue est bizarre et
donc tu as pas de nul facile avec les
Noirs ça se trouve tu es peut-être mieux
avec les Noirs ça je sais pas en fait
juger la position est compliquée mais
mais c'est chaud donc bon quand tu dois
absolument gagner tu veux ce genre de
partie où il y a un combat qui qui
dessine et on verra bien ouais combat de
rue quoi h c'est ça donc bon en tout cas
c'est c'est intéressant cette
positionvec H4 c'est une idée qui est
assez récente quand même qui été j par
tout le monde mais assez récente assez
intéressant mais c'est vraiment beaucoup
Lig d'ordi oui pour l'avoir travaillé
euh et jouer d'ailleurs euh bah
d'ailleurs j'ai j une partie j'ai perdu
il y a pas longtemps contre un 2002 je
recommande pas du coup ben si c'est une
ligne intéressante mais en fait j'ai pas
compris la position euh j'avais enfin
j'ai joué des coups qui paraissaient
logiques mais en fait la meilleure
solution c'était un truc d'ordi qui très
dur à comprendre et du coup bon j'ai
j'ai pas joué les bons coups j'avais une
perpétuelle mais j'ai refusé de la
prendre parce que je voulais gagner et
puis j'ai fini par perdre mais euh
classique ouais voilà mais bon position
très difficile euh en pratique pour les
deux joueurs en fait hein oui oui et
puis le tour A3 tour C3 al j'avais une
tour à 3 qui est pas forcément toujours
le bon coup et mais bon là dans le
seting j'ai pas vu ça allit très vite
hein j'ai pas regardé et on va on va
plutôt euh plutôt euh
euh voir le direct mais
alors là il y a CAV à 3ce que je pensais
il y a une fourchette mais après ça il y
avait une fourchette entre le cavalier
la dame qui force cavalier à 3
maintenant je vais bouger mon roi
probement pour il mauvais coup alors jou
pas trop d'autres coup que CAV 3 moi
alors peut-être qu'il voulait juste
bouger que sur coup de dame il 4 quand
Mme ouais je crois que je crois qu'il
est fâché
avecanaordi tout coup c'est de la merde
je crois qu'il est fâché avecana il lui
dit non en
fait mais du cou semble logique mais non
euh ouais ouais bah le cavalier à 3 il a
de doit être perdu al pour l'instant il
est soutenu par la dame mais bon voilà
tu peux pasessortir B5 comme ça c'est
acrobatique quoi pour les n ouais c'est
acrobatique et puis même regardez là il
y a un pion plus pour les Noirs mais le
pion plus il est où en fait euh c'est
pas vraiment visible c'est tellement
compliqué qu'au final le pion plus euh
c'est même pas on s'en fout quoi on s'en
fout complètement euh tiens là il y a
des vis-à-is de partout vis-à-vis là
vis-à-vis là c'est extrêmement compliqué
et euh B5 on peut pas le jouer là ok B5
euh j'imagine que je prends ouais avec
mon petit fou et quand tu prends C5 ou
al t 5 c'est ok je je je me barre quoi
enfin je fais dame n'importe où je sais
pas pere tu veux t pr 5 tour à 5 ça a
l'air quand même pas mal pour le blanc
je trouve he non faut faire gaffe à lui
quand même mais Françis 5 en plus
qu'est-te regarde
avec pas du tout
pour mais du coup
[Musique]
alorsok pas
content
pourit
voir il est fou en
fait il est fou parce que là
ici il
dit
poura fait la même l'autre jour j'étais
en stream euh et je regardais une
position et puis en fait il y avait un C
qui était très fort comme coup en fait
l'ordi je pense qu'il est branché sur
une autre position je sais pas pourquoi
mais il est branché sur firou ah mais tu
vois les Cook oui il est branché sur
firouja ouais
ouais ne regardez pas la jauge elle est
là mais ah oui don il donne fou prend à
2 cavalier prend à 2 roi G3 tour G3 ah
oui en fait l'ordinateur il est
complètement ah oui là il est sur
cavalier PR7 quoi qui va arriver après
regardez
la deuxème Lig c'est CER prend pr ok ok
ok du coup non en fait il faut pas
regarder l'ordi ce fait nous on faisait
pas tout à l'heure donc ce qu'on va
faire c'est je vais enlever la jauge
ouais boom ça dégage comme ça au moins
on va pas pourer des échecs tout seul s
sans ce truc exactement exactement tour
B4 a été joué et maintenant du coup il
faut trouver des trucs
on a plus la Jae on sa plus on sait
plus Vy regarde les pièces bougé on dit
rien qu'on est là comment on fait du
coup pour évaluer ça non c'est chaud là
don alors avec Lenard je pense3
ouais et fou E5 fou prend puis on prend
tac clouage donc c'est une petite menace
quand même euh C4 5 c'est un coup c'est
un coup qui va arriver aussi bon coup
mais on n'est pas sûr que c'est un bon
coup ça c'est encore l'ordi qui nous dit
des trucs parce que là c'est que s'en
fout prend là ça fou Mme intermédire
mais bon c'est même pas si sûr parce
mais bon est-ce que est-ce qu'on est si
heureux je te laisse manger la T TPR B3
boou sur dam PR8 ah ouais non mais il y
a TPR B3 qui est un très très joli coup
regardez he il y a ça fait une
découverte sur la la tour et ça va mater
hein ça va matterer et
euh mais bon peut-être que là j'ai
intermédire F 4 enfin ok c'est très très
compliqué il y a beaucoup de choses qui
peuvent se passer ici et
euh et euh ouais so il va faire C4 soit
il va faire F PR3 F 5 qui a l'air
jouable soit peutêtre 3 B8 quoi comme ça
tu es tu là non tu es plus là en fait je
vais écouter les gens je vais refres
mais bon refres je pas ça va
changer il parle drit B8 comme moi
effectivement tu as branché l'ordi toi
ouis tu as branché l'ordi moi je va
l'enlever moi j'aime bien l'enlever
j'aime bien on veut pas savoir j'aime
bien réfléchir regarder des échecs quoi
parun truc qui fait du yoyo ouais j'aime
bien et ça me sale les gens même qui
mettent mauvais coup quoi j'ai Mme pas
envie de voir ça enlève c'est bon plus
maais
coup mais en fait depuisb de la partie
te mets que des mauvais coups de car
quand même quoi oui parce que non mais
c'était pas c'était pas la bonne
position en fait donc
ok donc du coup B5
3 et ça beaucoup beaucoup de menac j'ai
aussi foupran et ça qui encore une
menace même si j'ai encore d'amche
là-haut c'est très compliqué et je vois
que Carona a seulement 2 minutes 54 à la
pendule c'est du chos VL qui encore 6
minutes à la
pendule ouais mais être précis dans une
position aussi compliquée c'est
compliqué he même si
même et chacro là
ouais ben tu sais pas et
euh alors f prend j'ai toujours échec et
ça et là ça l'atique c'est pas
sûr ouais mais je pensais à un truc du
style parce que genre ça c'est aussi
possible en fait tu as absolument tout
en prise je sais pas en quel sens ça va
mais si je je me réserve ça on prend pas
c t faut prendre B5 c'est S c'est S
c'est
et bon pourquoi il fait pas bien
peut-être all al peut-être a il y a du
Fou 4 non peut-être pas non non mais
enfin ça doit être mais tuis ro il m'a
l'air pourri quoi en ro tu as pas envie
de le faire après B3 si j'ai envie après
des fois aussi ce ce qui est possible tu
sais c'est quand tu es en not tu aimes
bien essayer d'enchaîner les coups ouais
bien
c'est hyper logique je sais pas c'est
juste j'en ai marre de voir Dame des
éche ouais
T3 joue pas ça
problèmeé il veut aussi sur D
b2end
pas
et du coup je vais je vais où en fait
parce que sur sur ça il y a ça il juste
faire nul
bon mais
oui quo on récupère le matériel
investi non prends la tête d'abord non
mais j'auris fait au li d' pr ah tu
directement ça
ok directement ça oui c'est on défend
tout mais MV va devoir la jouer hein
malheureusement euh éche prendre la nul
ah bah du coup voilà c'est bon ben faut
jouer pour le faire tomber ouais il a un
pion de moins il est foutu mais bon
après bon il y a 2 minutes en face c'est
une position qui joue quand même he
c'est pas si encore tu vois j'ai quand
même des idées aussi j'ai une majorité
logiquement c'est bien pourri quand même
ouais ouais c'est bien pourri mais c'est
pas non plus un avantage décisif quoi
c'est juste mal très mauvais le problème
c'est que c'est très mal quand tu dois
gagner quoi encore pour défendre
peut-être tu as
trouvé préc mais tu as 1 minute 30
d'avance euh tuas une
majorité bon bah écoute ça se tente
encore hein tu jou tu fais tomber quoi
ça se tente prise je
pense al tour 4 a été
joué très bien d' j'aime bien tour 4
c'est bien joué ouais ça fort c'est
centralise pe faire des échecs
pourevenenir vers G4 après ouais et le
RO en plus il garde tour la case D7
d'entrée de la tour à 4 peut-être ou je
sais pas ouais on va pousser ce retour
là au pire tour G4 tranquille je pense
c'est ça qui veut échanger pour du Tour
de échec et compagnie ouis et puis moins
il y a de pièce plus c'est facile pour
pour carwana
donc là il fait il fait le job he c'est
5 du
coup avec mais en fait je le truc c'est
moi je pense que sur chiik c'est plus
facile que sur un ordi ce truc parce que
tu as pas de miscilic possible euh tu
vois l'ARE jouer les coups tu vois tu es
pas là avec 3 secondes euh pr des ou
quoi là c'estou tu vois la main jouer
quoi enfin c'est ou mais les échecs
devraient tout le temps être comme ça en
fait toute notre vie enfin toute leur
vie aussi eux ils ont joué sur sur un
vra échec on quand même plus habitué
ouis à 4 à TR et c'est ça a l'air ça a
l'air terminé pour Maxime
malheureusement tour G4 tour tour 7 tour
7 sûrement c'est pas le plus précis mais
c'est le coup stable pas de contrejeu
pré j'en sais rien mais non mais c'est
bien ce qu'il fait je dire c'est sûr que
c'est bien quand tu es dans une partie
comme ça tu as ça en l'air tu as ça qui
est aussi menacé D5 C4 qui arrive aussi
je sais pas où elle a mal tourné la
partie en fait parce que elle été
bizarre à suivre pour nous parce qu'on
s'est pris tout c on est arrivé direct
au 20e coup euh il y a pas eu de donc
dur à dire je sais pas qu'and ça mal
tourné parce après de toute façon
c'était très compliqué comme position
ouais non mais soit faible c'est POS
sont trop dures c'est des trucs d'ordi
où l'ordinateur il donne des positions
qu'onarrive pas à comprendre en fait
fait euh c'est horrible juste cette
ligne mais après bon si c'est dur pour
tout le monde c'est dur pour tout le
monde des fois le problème c'est quand
c'est que dur pour toi des coup plutôt
logiques m si tu es bien vaut mieux
éviter h un fou des6 bah là il domine le
cavalier avec son fou ou et puis il joue
tranquille he il joue des coup simple et
et Maxime qui est en train de revenir un
petit peu au temps
il va prendre et tour prise tour bouge
et puis comment je ouis ben si fou fuite
quand même j'ai fou F de manger G7
on va faire tour
tour c'est pas mal aussi non c'est plus
propr ENF je sais pas bien mon à la mais
non mais aussi ça m' l'air ça m' l'
quand même pas mal bon il a qume
ok pr C5 attention quand même Maxim
quand Mme ouis mais bon je dis nul
suffit quo donc en fait il f gag ou
abandon abandon là il per une pièce sur
ro il juste roi C6 il avait la tour qui
plus de cas et le fou qui était en prise
par le pion dommage Maxime qui perd du
coup ce match accroché donc on a la fin
de la première ronde du tournoi donc
Victor carwana après après don victoire
de firouja contre Abd à 05 victoire de
carlen contre lazavic et victoire
[Musique]
de ça vous
voyz priori non non c'est juste pour
dire à priori on va avoir une pause là
assez longue ouais euh avant le le
deuxème match alors moi je vais laisser
stff commenter tout seul
euh parce que bah là du coup je suis à
Paris pour pour la B Cup et ça va être
les les matchs de élimination directe et
à 20h15 ça commence je suis censé aller
rejoindre Kevin mais c'est cool de
comter avec toi ouais ben merci beaucoup
en tout cas d'être passé je vais essayer
de voir bah est-ce que est-ce que tu
peux me pendant que tu pars tu vas vite
à me chercher Nathan ok
euh l'idée en fait c'est essayer de voir
est-ce que je peux host B stream parce
que là on va avoir en fait on va avoir
une demi-heure de pause entre les deux
et bon c'est une demi-heure où je peux
rien ok je vais te je vais te trouver
Nathan et je te le renvoie euh disir à
ta place ouais voilà ouais je je je
déconnecte pas le PC dis prendre ta euh
bon ben je dis au revoir au chat euh
c'est un plaisir d'être avec vous euh et
normalement je serai de retour demain
pour la suite de ce tournoi et pendant
toute la semaine euh et puis bah tout
stuff on au Ju quoi ouais on se tient au
jus ça marche merci beaucoup pour ton
tournoi à bientôt merci ciao ciao
ciao alors du coup oui donc comme on
vous l'a dit là on a une on va avoir une
pause d'une demi-heure parce que les
joueurs se reposent entre entre les
parties et euh et du coup ben vu que
c'est une grosse grosse pause quand même
hein je je sais pas si vous allez rester
alors qu'il se passe absolument rien sur
la chaîne du coup on pensait
peut-être pendant la pause partir
ensemble chez BL stream et revenir mais
histoire de ne pas lancer un deuxième
stream je peux pas le raid en fait donc
il faudrait que je le que je le
Hoste ça veut dire qu'en fait je v voler
son contenu pour le mettre sur notre
chaîne voilà mais pour ça j'ai besoin
d'avoir le responsable chesscom qui
puisse le faire manuellement parce que
moi j'ai malheureusement pas la main
dessus sur Obs je ne peux rien faire du
tout là j'ai les main un
peu un peu lié et donc donc du coup on
attend que Nathan
arrive pour essayer de voir ça je vais
voir ave Sami je va je vais essayer de
voir
[Musique]
euh
euh attendez
hein
euh stff tu aurais pu aller à la backup
euh franchement ça m'aurait bien plu
mais bon ça c'est un peu loin de chez
moi j'habite en Espagne j'habite euh
dans la sur la
côte la côteest valence et c'est un gros
voyage
mais mais un jour un jour un jour je la
ferai un jour je la ferai parce que
franchement l'ambiance elle est quand
même très très sympa ça a l'air hyper
cool donc à voir la ronde suivante
commence dans 30 minutes gismou et c'est
pour ça que du coup je je j'attends là
que Nathan regardez Nathan il arrive ou
c'est ou c'est Fab qui arrive je crois
je reconnais
l'allure euh allô stff ouais tu as
revenu ouais je suis revenu non en fait
il est occupé il va pas parvenir donc je
toute façon je lu déconnecté son discord
et compagnie ok il m'a dit bah en fait
les su communique comme vous faites
d'habitude par téléphone WhatsApp je
sais pas ce que tu fais en fait mais il
te répondra comme ça ouais ben je j'ai
écrit à à robinide et et à et à Nathan
mais j'ai pas j'ai pas de réponse donc
bon moi je vais rester là de toute façon
je vais attendre un petit peu ce qui se
passe et puis je vais voir si je peux
s'il y a moyen de voir ça quoi ok cool
et ben écoute je déconnecte tout moi ça
marche merci beaucoup en tout cas à
bientôt à bientôt ciao ciao ciao ciao
alors du coup je passer sur la vue avec
une personne pour ne pas hop voilà c'est
parti on a caché on a caché
et je vais essayer de les appeler pour
les faire
réagir mais euh je pense pas
que que ça va
[Musique]
répondre apparimment on les connaît je
peux vous les donner petite seconde
attendez je vois que ça répond
euh il faut juste qu'il lise
quoi
alors la ronde 2 j'ai les apparims bien
sûr et les apparment devrai arriver
alors tac laissez-moi une petite seconde
les apparment sont là je les ai
ici tac tac tac
attendez j'ai pas encore les appariments
ici je les avais je les ai vu l'autre
jour je ne sais pas où estce que je les
ai vu d'ailleurs parce qu'ils ne sont
pas
ici non c'est pas
ça pas là non
[Musique]
plus les apparimment je les ai
pas je les ai
su
mais je ne les ai plus non plus sont pas
affiché là non plus je les avais tout à
l'heure je les ai vu Sami pe pas je
crois que si tu
peux
[Musique]
euh
ok bon les gars on peut rien faire
malheureusement je peux pas je ne peux
pas faire de quoi de de host à
samif à je crois en fait on est on
est on est on est bloqué les gars on
doit rester là jusqu'à ce que ça
reprenne mais j'ai pas du tout de
nouvelle de l'heure à laquelle ça va
euh ça va va
reprendre une demi-heure environ et en
plus le problème c'est que je peux même
pas jouer de partie avec ce compte j'ai
un compte admin chesscom alors je peux
même pas je peux même pas vous faire un
truc pédagogique ou quoi que ce soit je
peux rien
faire je suis complètement bloqué en
fait les gars complètement bloqué jeme
je peux même pas jouer on peut revoir
les parties si vous voulez rapidement ce
qui s'est passé essayer de
ok ok ok ok ok ok bon il fautan réponde
mais Nathan il est très occupé et
malheureusement on est nous aussi
bloqué tac
tac alors je vais essayie de trouver les
apparentss quand même c'est quand même
cool que je les
ai alors je pense ça va être affiché
ici format
players ok j'ai pas les apparimments
ici si vous avez apparement n'hésitez
pas à me partager he parce que là je je
trouve
pas je les trouve pas mais je les ai vu
quelque part je crois que je les ai vu
peutêtre sur SLAC attendez une petite
secondes je vais regarder je vais
regarder ici pendant ce
temps-là alors j'ai les
horaires
est-ce que j'ai eu les apparments oui
j'ai apparimment ça y est on m'avait
envoyé un truc alors ça va être so
contre
l'zavic lors de la ronde 2 ça va être
Nakamura
mvl ça va être caroana firouja et
Carlsen Abdou voilà ça c'est ce que j'ai
pour pour la ronde 2 donc c'est cool ça
va me permettre de pouvoir préparer en
tout cas
l'Obs pour pour pour la ronde
2 et
euh ouais en fait j'avais reçu ça sur
slack mais malheureusement sur internet
il y avait il y avait pas les info donc
la backup est-ce que je la retransmets
pas ben malheureusement non c'est pas ma
chaîne c'est pas mon truc et en fait
vous savez que là moi je suis connecté à
à à Obs par un restream je suis pas du
tout avec le compte de chcom fr et
malheureusement du coup je ne peux pas
du tout faire de Ra ENF un RA je peux
faire mais si je fais un RA après que je
relance un stream et du coup ça ça va
créer une deuxème vidéo Youtube je crois
que ça va pas du tout pour j'aurais pu
host malheureusement mais
si si nathan est pas là je ne peux
absolument rien faire donc pendant que
vous êtes là je va faire en votre
présence on va préparer un petit peu les
places
donc juste que je sache qui est qui et
je pense que je peux pas encore préparer
d'ailleurs parce que là
les places sont posé mais la caméra ici
je crois que je pourrais mettre les noms
des joueurs et les caméras et tout
seulement quand je saurai qui et où
parce que mais je pense que ça va être
comme ça normalement table 1 je pas de
bêtises norm c'est solzavic on prendre
un petit risque on va marquer ça mais je
suis pas sûr donc on va changer un peu
le nom ici on va mettre
sa
euh donc so le est blanc je pense et
laav qui va avoir les Noirs j'imagine
que ça va être comme ça mais je me
trompe
peut-être je me trompe peut-être
ok table 2 normalement ce
sera Nakamura avec les Blancs contre
mvl je pense
hein mais avec avec la chance que j'ai
ça va pas du tout se passer comme ça hop
contre
mvl voilà table 3 ça va faire un
petit table 2 j'avais pas score table 3
ça va faire un petit carwana firou donc
carwana avec les Blancs
normalement hop donc firou noir il où
firou hop il est
là et caroana qui a battu Maxime en
Armagedon je va en le score d'ailleurs
de carwana ici il s'agit bien de
celui-là on va mettre à zéro salut
Yume hop et le 4 du coup ça va être
normalement Carlsen
Abdou Carlson avec les Blancs
hop mais à tout à tout moment c'est pas
du tout ça qui va être bon à tout moment
il vaut tout changer et je vais doir
tout refaire mais bon c'est un truc qui
a rapide à faire de toute façon c'est
pas du tout un problème Abdou il est où
Abdou je le trouve
pas euh il est
là et le score je vais vous le remettre
à zéro aussi et puis pour moi bah je
pense que je serai bon
hein je pense que je serai bon il y aura
plus qu'à attendre attendre que ça
reprenne je sais pas combien de temps il
reste je vais voir un peu sur slack s'il
a des nouvelles euh donc je pense pour
moi ça va être comme ça qu'est-ce qu'il
dit
SLAC qu'est-ce que vous dites
euh non il disent rien et normalement il
y a bien une demi-heure de pause ça
s'arrêta à quelle heure du coup le
tournoi là que je sache combien de temps
il reste je dirais il reste environ 10
minutes 15 minutes je pense que du coup
on a quand même pas mal meublé et euh
alors non je suis pas du tout en PLS par
la technique en fait hein juste bon de
base il y a eu des problèmes techniques
avant le stream
des trucs un peu pas de chance mais ça s
réglé et puis maintenant en fait et ben
il y a match àer retour avec des pauses
au milieu à chaque fois
et et ce qui se passe c'est que entre
les deux matchs il y a une demiheure de
pause alors que nous on est en stream du
coup c'est un peu compliqué de de devoir
meubler moi je suis sur un compte admin
qui m'aime pas le mien donc je peux même
pas jouer aux échecs parce qu'on on
aurait pu jou d'échec pour meubler un
petit peu mais je peux même pas jouer
c'est pas mon compte et c'est un compte
admin de donc je peux rien faire et
j'aurais voulu essayer de host blitstam
qui est en train de faire l'événement
backup sur Paris mais malheureusement et
ben comme je n'ai pas le compte chessc
je peux absolument rien faire je suis
complètement bloqué et donc voilà il y a
pas de problème hein juste pas de
problème mais mais je suis bloqué voilà
euh du coup ce qu'on va faire c'est que
je vais quand même faire une petite
pause euh là je pense qu'on a attendu au
moins 15 20 minutes depuis tout à
l'heure donc il doit rester pas beaucoup
de temps on fait une pause et et puis
d'ici
normalement 10 minutes j'espère et ben
on aura du coup la ronde 2 qui va
démarrer avec comme apparemment je vous
les redonne on aura so contre laavic on
aura Nakamura contre mvl kwana firouja
et Carlsen Abdou donc Mme de très très
beaux appariments avec Naka mvl et
kwanafou d'ailleurs nak mvl les deux
joueurs ont perdu leur match donc c'est
vraiment un match avec beaucoup d'enjeux
ici hein ok donc va voir un petit peu
comment ça va ça va ça va jouer allez
petite pause je vous dis à tout de suite
euh j'espère et puis reste quand même
parmi nous à tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian defense to the
untrained ey this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displ now with the official
collection from Chess.com Mount them in
seconds with a toolf magnet kit and swap
them whenever you like make your move
get an exclusive discount on all metal
poers shop now with the code chess
[Musique]
displate.com
he
[Musique]
je suis de retour avec les caméras qui
devraient revenir dans un instant et
euh tac tac les joueurs qui sont
installés d'ailleurs j'ai j'ai pas les
bons j'ai pas les bonnes couleurs euh
j'ai mis saut euh sa Cal est blanc c'est
les caméras qu'il faut que juste que je
je je tourne les
caméras je vais je vais changer juste
tout ça donzmoi une petite
seconde je vais faire comme ça histoire
de pas
vous changer on ira voir on ira voir un
peu oups je me suis trompé j'ai fait une
fausse manipe bah du coup vous allez
voir tout ce que je fais c'est pas beau
hop je comptais le faire un peu mieux
voilà du coup ça c'est pour ce match là
on a du coup on a un mvl avec les noirs
et j'ai encore fait n'importe quoi parce
qu'ici voyez je l'ai fait tout à l'heure
ici je vais vous changer un petit peu ça
tout en haut on voit le nom de mvl qui
est avec un autre nom je ne sais pas
lequel et j'ai oublé d'enlever Magnus
Caren donc mvl qui va jouer contre
Nakamura et la partie a commencé
et on a les Noirs ici alors là du coup
j'ai les temps ah oui c'est vrai que
j'avis j'avais fait une erreur tout à
l'heure qui s'était passé c'est qu'en
fait on avait du coup les temps alors
les gars là il va falloir que je fasse
un truc parce que j'ai les temps qui
marchent pas du tout vous voyez que en
fait tout à l'heure il s'est passé un
truc c'est qu'on était dans
la dans la comment dire la scène avec
Fabien et du coup il s'est passé un truc
assez étrange Ave de Fabi bien c'est que
attendez hein vous allez voir
direct je le fais là en même temps que
je vous
parle c'est qu'à la base j'étais pas
prévu d'être tout seul
aujourd'hui donc cette cette scène là je
l'avais pas
préparé et donc euh c'est pour ça que la
scne nétait pas tout à fait
prête et j'aurais dû préparer au cas où
la scène en plus alors que la scène 2
était totalement prête tout à
[Musique]
l'heure hop je en de mettre la scène un
peu mieux là pendant que
vous suivez la partie une fois que ça
sera prêt j'essaierai de passer un petit
peu pour vous expliquer un peu ce qui se
passe réellement dans la
partie je mets un truc peu présentable
là c'est que Fab il a la il a la BUP et
du coup Kevin avait besoin de lui c'est
pour ça qu'il est parti
l'aider est-ce que c'est mieux comme ça
ou c'est un peu cochon quand même je
essaie de changer un petit peu ça mais
quand je mets en tout petit je vois
vraiment rien du
tout et du coup c'est bon chez moi voilà
c'est un peu mieux
déjà même si c'est pas
génialissime allez vous avez le temps en
tout cas dans cette partie donc là je
vous rappelle c'est un match qui se joue
en deux parties gagnées donc alors
qu'est-ce qui passé dans ce début de
partie c'est un peu bizarre je vais
reprendre depuis tout le début pour voir
un peu ce qui se passe ah c'est F5 ilre
déj c'est une sorte
de de trompovski qu'on joue
avec avec les Blancs et MV l'en caisseon
B4 fou échec fou D7 et c'est une PO très
très bizarre
ici
ok il y a deux rondes aujourd'hui BO de
rondes aujourd'hui c'est la deuxiè c'est
la
deuxème
donc donc voilà c'est comme ça que ça
marche dame C7 a été joué donc pour
faire un petit résumé MV perdu son match
contre kwana pendant que firouja a gagné
son match contre absotorov on a aussi
Naka qui a perdu contre so et le dernier
match c'était Carlsen qui a battu
laavic donc on en est là et là c'est la
deuxième partie je vous rappelle que
c'est un tournoi un peu tout ronde pour
l'instant enfin tout ronde c'est tout le
monde fait un match contre tout le monde
et les deux premiers du groupe sont
qualifiés pour les demi-finales les deux
derniers seront éliminés et les quatre
du milieu joueront en play-off pour
avoir deux places pour rejoindre les
demi-finales les joueurs qui seront
qualifiés alors fou G7 a été joué mvl
calé noir ici il y a un pion de plus
pour pour mvl mais ce roi qui fait hyper
peur on peut penser à cavalier G3 F5 qui
peut arriver très très vite il y a aussi
une diagonale qui peut s'ouvrir ici hein
cach blanche avec E4 éventuellement qui
qui pour moi est clairement un coup un
coup jouable voyez que sur par exemple
ça fixerait quand même pas mal les cases
blanches sur une prise j'aurais cavalier
prend sur D4 j'aurais cavalier qui peut
venir en F5 et puis je bloquerai aussi
un petit peu la la case F5 donc c'est
intéressant ce petit coup4 CAV là aussi
est extrêmement intéressant tour B1 est
aussi un coup intéressant il y a
beaucoup de choses et j'ai l'impression
que Maxime a une position très difficile
à jouer en pratique parce que Naka en
fait il a un pion de moins mais il a une
PR très solide et il a beaucoup de
ruptures possibles avec C4 avec E4 avec
cavalier là avec tourb alors que les
Noirs ben ils ont un gros problème sur
le long terme c'est lui quoi Maxine
s'est levé ils sont fous Maxime qui se
lève complètement
incroyable après on ira voir aussi la
partie de d'alireza on voir un peu ce
que nous fait ce que nous fait
Alireza après on peut t imaginer
cavalier G3 et dire que je fais tour
C8 et qu'en fait bon F5 j'ai F et puis
que je m'en fous en fait peutêtre je fou
complet hein mais bon qui a un problème
sur pion C2 je suis pas sûr de comment
on réagit peut-être C4 et Caval C3 on
donne le
pion tour C m'a l'air beaucoup trop
passif comme coup mais le roi il est
quand même extrêmement faible mais c'est
vrai que pour l'instant je défends là
mais en fait la question c'est que
j'arrive pas du tout à attaquer ce
cavalier et il est un peu indélogeable
ce cavalier quoi même desidé cavalier B3
peut-être qui sont possibles sur dame
prend C2 pour je d'AM échec et rentrer
un peu voyez sur case blanche sur roil
là il y aurait mat par exemple sur roil
là il y aurait fourchette entre le roi
et la tour peut-être Cavaille C5 mais
bon j'ai du toursen c'est compliqué hein
on a l'impression que tout est un petit
peu tiens sur un fil pour mvl mais
j'aime pas du tout sa position en tout
cas j'aime pas sa
position cam qui prend son
temps donc compliqué est-ce qu'on fait
un petit tour chez chez Alireza on va
aller faire un tour chez Alireza je vais
essayer de vous choper rapidement déjà
le la la partie où il joue et d'ailleurs
il va falloir que je vous règle les
caméras aussi de cette scène là qui ne
sont pas pas bonnes euh et alira alle
est noir attendez il y a plein de trucs
à régler alors je vous laisse cette
cette vue et puis je vais vous mettre
les les caméras dans le bon
ordre parce que là c'est pas bon du tout
et dès que j'auraai fait ça je mettrai
les caméras et puis je vous mettrai
les parce que là c'est pas du tout le
bon
ordre mais encore une fois je suis
désolé mais je ne pensais pas que
j'allais être tout seul pour finir le
stream et du coup j'avais pas du tout
préparé la scène où je suis tout
seul c'est pour ça que du coup B c'est
les alli encore une fois du direct et on
doit faire avec euh j'avais tout fait la
veille pour la scène avec
Fab mais voilà si j'avais su avant vous
auriez la scène qui était déjà
prête j'ais fait tous mes
devoirs j'avis fait tous mes
devoirs
euh
hop je crois que ça va à peu
près et du coup la Clo des noir je vous
la fait après je vous change un petit
peu on ira voir un peu ce que fait al on
suit vraiment en priorité no français
dans
ceion tour aprs on pour voir aussi un
petit peu les prix du tournoi les prix
sont
astronomiques c'est je pense une des
plus grosses dotations qu'on a pu voir
sur des tournois online alors je dis
online même si là ils sont IRL mais vous
savez que qu'il y a eu quand même six
[Musique]
tournois avant
celui-ci et là c'est la grande grande
finale j sont qualifiés pour arriver
jusque là et je crois qu'on est bon j'ai
réussi à vous mettre les la
[Musique]
scène donc voilà vous avez naam est
blanc contre mvl et changer maintenant
sur la scène de
d'za firouja qui a les Noirs contre
caroana alors mulotou euh pour faire
clair en fait là c'est un c'est un
système suisse enfin Suisse c'est tout
c'est tout ronde tu as huit joueurs qui
font des matchs contre tous les autres
joueurs un par un
euh et en fait c'est des matchs qui sont
en aller-retour donc tu as une fois avec
les Blancs une fois avec les Noirs si
jamais euh il y a 111 à l'issu des deux
parties et ben on fait une troisème
partie pour passer en ce qu'on appelle
Armagedon c'est un système de départage
c'est une partie qu'on fait en
supplémentaire pour se départager
euh et après voilà tu gagnes le match ou
pas s'il y a un joueur qui gagne une
partie et qui fait match nul par exemple
la partie d'après et ben il y aura 1 et
demi à 0 et5i donc à l'essu des deux
parties il aura gagné donc il y a pas de
départage d'accord quand tu gagnes ce
match et ben tu as gagné le match quoi
et du coup à la fin de tout ce tournoi
là tuas tu auras en tout se parties
enfin se matchs parce que tu as joueurs
et et tout simplement à la fin de C se
matchs et ben tu as un classement qui se
fait les deux premiers du classement
sont qualifiés cette fois-ci pour les
demi-finales c'est-à-dire pour un
tournoi qui se déroule maintenant par
élimination direct
ensuite les quatre suivants seront
qualifiés pour une sorte de taebreak où
ils joueront des matchs entre eux pour
essayer de se qualifier pour les debis
fininal aussi donc deux parmi les quatre
se qualifieront et les deux derniers du
classement général seront éliminés
complètement voilà donc c'est un petit
peu l'idée du tournoi pour ça que tu des
T joueurs qui ont un point un point et
demi et cetera il y a plusieurs parties
dans ce de match voilà c'est un tour
tournoi deux matchs c'est assez bizarre
mais mais une fois qu'on comprend c'est
assez
clair donc le roi8 toujours là toujours
un pion de plus pour pour pour les Noirs
mais mais les rois qui se baladent et ça
me ferait quand même hyper peur à la
place de mvl d'illeurs là c'est parti MV
il faut que je change je suis désolé
j'ai travail à moitié on va partir sur
quand Mme Alireza c quand même la partie
Alireza j'ai j'ai changé de caméra mais
pas la partie alors donc ça c'est une
c'est une Espagnole ou une italienne je
dirais plutôt une Espagnole qui a été
jouée non c'est italienne regardez hop
je la fais en accéléré tac D6 C3 H3 A4
tour 1 on sort les pièces fou B2 et au
final on joue comme ça alors j'aime bien
ces positions avec les Noirs
généralement si je devais choisir à
chaque fois je prendrais les Noirs parce
que j'ai quand même l'impression que euh
j'ai qu l'impression que les Noirs
arrivent souvent à attaquer des idées
peut-être avec ça la tour qui qui ve
venir ici F5 qui peut arriver et les
cavaliers un peu style est indenne qui
peuvent venir un jour sur la case F4
alors pour l'instant c'est compliqué
d'aller en F4 il y a un petit pion en G3
mais sur le long termear va vraiment
attaquer ce fou et hyper fort d'ailleurs
qui me fait mentir qu' joue ici le coup
cavalier F4 j'y ai pensé enfin j'en ai
parlé parce
qu'évidemment c'était une idée classique
mais après ici il veut clairement faire
tour G6 dans quel ordre je ne sais pas
est-ce qu'il ve tour G6 maintenant
est-ce qu'il ve d'abord faire cavalier
prend F4 puis tour G6 alors plutôt tour6
je pense d'abord parce que sur cavali pr
f4ut- y a cavalier là qui pourrait
arriver un jour alors que peut-être que
par exemple la tour direct il y a pas ça
à cause de cavalier prend même à cause
de pion prend F4 encore plus fort qui va
récupérer c'est peut-êt c'est plus
précis mais l'idée c'est quoi ici est-ce
que c'est pu on prend l'idée essayer
d'empêcher le C venir ici
continueattaque il fa pr F2 aussi qui
est pas
mal il y a beaucoup de jeux qui peut
arriver il y a eu échec
al qui nous régale he merci beaucoup
pour l'explication mais ça mais que se
passe-t-il s'il y a nul lors de la 3è
partie ah d'accord en fait ok je
comprends ce que tu veux dire en fait
c'est que à la fin tu as un armagadon
c'est tuas une partie avec des temps
différents le genre qui a les Noirs aura
généralement moins de temps à la pendule
que les blancs
mais en cas de match nul c'est les noirs
qui gagnent voilà donc les blanc ont
l'avantage d'avoir les blancs donc là
d'avoir le trait c'est un avantage
d'avoir le blanc on aussi l'avantage de
euh de d'avoir plus de temps la pendule
c'est un truc du style 15 minutes avec
les Blancs
euh contre les noirs avec environ 10
minutes et les noirs peuvent faire match
nul pour gagner le match voilà il y a
toujours un vainqueur les Noirs gagnent
en cas de match nul c'est un peu l'idée
merci d'ailleurs ciel bleu pour ton
petit lien sur l' Rama
Guedon
il vaut mieux faire victoire défaite
victoire que victoire nul non c'est
pareil motou on s'en fout le but c'est
gagner le match c'est un petit match là
tu fais un mini match euh peu importe le
score du mini match il faut que tu
fasses un mini match il faut que tu
gagnes ton mini match quoi que tu gagnes
1 et demi 0 et demi ou 20 ou que tu
gagnes bah 21 parce que tu as eu les
départages bah c'est pareilin tu tu tu
le but c'est de gagner mini match on
s'en fout du nombre de
points c'est tout hein dites-vous quand
on fait un tournoi quand on fait un vrai
tournoi bah le jour a jeôle le J B il y
a une seule partie bah tu gagnes tu
gagnes d'accord mais là c'est pareil tu
fais un mini match mais à la fin c'est
comme si tu gagnais un point dans ton
tourno en fait c'est
pareil bref je pense que je pense qu'on
s'est compris c'est un mini match et et
au final euh ça pas
d'importance le score du match juste
gagner
match alors tour G6 é donc là on peut on
peut jouer roi G1 roi H1 ou roi H2
cavalier là c'est pas du tout un coup à
cause de eu prend F4 on va récupérer le
cavalier avec l'attaque donc sur ro H2
c'est quoi la l'idée moi je pensais à
faire F prend F2
euh mais je sais pas si j'ai du jeu
directement après tour 2 il y a le fou
en prise peut-être cavalier prend F4
d'abord menace ça et sur un truc du
style ça pour bloquer que je prends F2
qui attaque là et là voyez
c'est c'est intéressant en tout cas
j'aime beaucoup ce que fait alirza parce
que vous voyez il a sacrifé une pièce
pour pour l'instant un pion bon qu'il a
pas encore mangé mais qu'il va manger
probablement au prochain cous sur ro H2
donc là j'ai un pion et si défend comme
ça j'ai un deuxième pion et probablement
aussi encore une qualité que je vais
manger la tour donc euh tout ça pour
l'activité puis en plus j'ai aussi même
dame D7 qui peut être être une option
avec le cavalier qui va défendre du coup
H3 ça a l'air extrêmement créatif et en
pratique tellement dur à jouer pour les
noirs pour les blanc excusez-moi c'est
quand même les blancs qui se font
attaquer alors bien évidemment
alirea a une pièce de moins mais a
beaucoup d'attaque donc du coup c'est
lui qui a vraiment l'initiative mais
attention parce que même avec initiative
si je fais un mauvais coup je peux
perdre directement la partie hein donc
c'est pas du tout facile à jouer comment
je j'empêche ça quoi alors ça c'est pas
la fin du monde non plus j'ai encore ro
h mais après ça et tu prend F2 ou même
fou prend F2 ça fait peur quand même
hein j'aimerais pas avoir les blancs ici
hein j'aimerais pas avoir les blancsin
cavalier3 ok ça c'est un coup que
j'allais proposer alors fou prend est
une idée pour faire tour G2 mais après
fou prend pu on prend qu'ici j'ai plus
tour G2 parce que j'aurais roi H1 et
maintenant il y a ça en prise et ça en
prise peut-être que là je suis Jojo
est-ce qu'il y a un moyen de défendre
pas sûr peut-être j'ai
ça ça a l'air assez assez fort ah c'est
très compliqué cette position très
compliqué mais je trouve que c'est quand
même assez facile pour les Noirs enfin
en tout cas c'est plus facile pour les
noirs que pour les blancs je trouve
parce que les blancs doivent tout voir
en défense alors pour les Noirs les coup
d'attaque sont toujours plus faciles à
trouver est-ce que est-ce que dam là
c'est un
coup
déjà je fais une menace je fais une
menace de mat si tu bouges le cavalier
tu le mets au milieu bah je sais pas
peut-être là je prend G4 et là je te
matte de partout franchement c'est
horrible peut-être cavalier F5 bah j'ai
tour G2 prend F2 enfin c'est hyper
compliqué en pratique hein quelle
horreur quoi moi je peux vous garantir
que celle-là il a je D7 hein celle-là
avec avec les Blancs je la perds tous
les jours hein trop difficile trop
difficile à défendre avec les Noirs
aussi je la perds mais ça c'est
différent mais euh mais avec les Blancs
c'est très très dur à défendre he quelle
horreur moi je je pronostique un un gain
d'alir cette partie hein la J il pas
d'accord avec nous mais euh mais kg en
fait la Jose est pas d'accord mais la
position est tellement compliqué pour
les blancs que les blancs vont faire des
erreurs alors que les Noirs vont
peut-être aussi en faire mais c'est
beaucoup moins grave c'est beaucoup
moins grave parce que les coups les
coups noirs sont plus faciles à trouver
quand même il y a toujours du
jeu toujours du
jeu bon qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors
déjàend coup Clement parce que sur tour
pr pr H3 mat en un coup voyz et sur roi
pr bah ok d ici qui se regarde aussi
avec des menaces de Dam G2 cavalier ici
j'ai plein de menac qui arrive je suis
Caval pr qui était aussi
intéressant pas mal de choses et ça a
l'air franchement extrêmement déplaisant
pour pour Fabi pour les blancs j'aime
pas du tout mais alors pas du tout sa
position pendant ce temps je vais
essayer de vous régler les autres tables
pars on ira voir un peu ce qui pass
quand même dans les autres dans les
autres parties mais je vais vous je vais
vous régler la table de Magnus pendant
ce tempsl pendant que vous voyez la
partie en direct mais je pense que que
l'iREA est très bien parti pour pour
gagner j'amène vraent sa
position j'aime beaucoup beaucoup
hop alors pendant ce temps là je vous
mets
je vous mets tout
ça
c'est l'avance tout
prê c'est le coup que
je que je regardais aussi le coup que je
pensais était petre le
meilleur il
fa
coup aussi
donc là je je me le rien d'immédiat je
crois il y a pas de d il y a pas de dame
G2 en je me le F pr cavalier pour
enlever le défenseur de la case G2 pour
mater avec M dame juste après en
G2 imaginer un cou comme Dame des de
peut-être là l'aveugle faire un
truc de choper les caméras des
joueurs Magnus
euh ça a l'air d'avoir peut-être terminé
je vois pas les joueurs à leur
table je pas les joueurs à leur
table je sais pas s'ils font grève ou
pas donc là on menace prend TR quand
même
si ils sont là ils sont là et Magnus a
bien les blancs dans la première
partie donc la scène est prête je vais
maintenant vous changer la scène numéro
1 qui la dernière que j'ai pas changé
puis après je pourrais naviguer
tranquille entre toutes les
scènes soit les blancs c'est bien ça
oui c'est bien ça donc ça c'est bon et
il y a plus qu'à changer du
[Musique]
coup
ça après je pourrais naviguer plus
facilement sans que ça soit moche j'a
bien que soit bien ordonné quand même
mes
trucs
ok je crois qu'on a peu près bon même si
j'arrive pas bien à
voir c'est tout petit chez
[Musique]
moi c'est beaucoup de technique en
direct à chaque
fois j'ai quasiment fini de régler tout
ça
alors bon je pense que j'ai terminé on
IR voir ça après
ok dame G4 pour les blancs alors dame G4
pour l'instant il y a F prend enfin il y
aura cavalier prend
dam pour l'instant canard calpien euh
mais foupran et ah pardon excuse-moi
pour les blancs excuse-moi je suis
complètement à l'ouest euh est-ce que
j'ai pas foupr foupr et3
ici et si tu prends là je prends ta dame
et sur dame prends H3 j'ai cavalier ici
et je vais réussir à mes deux pièce
récupérer là donc comment est-ce que je
joue je sais pas trop parce que genre là
j'ai pe-être cavalier échec et je repars
j'ai quand même une qualité de moins
[Musique]
euh si je prends là et que tu prends là
et que je prends là et ben j'ai qu' une
pièce de moi je peux faire échec et
partir là c'est quoi la position 3 4 5 6
contre 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
ouais j'ai quand même un cavalier et
deux
pions voyez hein
contre une tour donc ça fait 55
et donc matériellement égal je P passer
ici mon qui peut s'activer intéressant
en tout cas comme
position al très créatif dans cette
partie il C5 qui veut défendre ce ce
cavalier à tout
prix aussi cavalier pr TR qui peut-être
aussi pouvait pouvait être pas mal j'ai
quand même de base j'ai une tour de Mo
quand même du laadam donc je suis pas
sûr que tu as envie de récupérer juste
un pion je pense que le cavalier ici tu
es plus appétissant que ta
ligne euh donc c'est 5 alors
l'ordinateur aime pas là vous voyez la
jauge et je vois le coup de l'ordinateur
et je comprends très bien et euh et
c'est extrêmement dur à trouver le coup
que les l'ordinateur propose pour les
Noirs ici c'est extrêmement bah il a
joué ouf il a jou tempo
g bien entendu la grosse déense G4 la
grosse déense des blanc bien entendu
avec H5 j'êche G4 c'est pour ça que H5
très très fort
jou j
par quiment tempo qui une très très
grosse
position est-ce que
coup men c'est pas pas c'est moi menace
ça et mat c'est ma petite menace
mais l'ordinateur il aime pas ça il
propose plutôt tour8 il dit que c'est
gagnant en fait il veut juste mater
comme ça et je crois qu'il dit que c'est
c'est le plus simple et d F3 avait l'air
quand même pas mal du tout mais av juste
tour bouge et sur échec en fuy la tour
défend ici donc il y a pas de ma et sur
là je pars et je pars au final mon va se
cacher de l'autre cé côté quoi il y a eu
tour 8 bien joué dame F1 a été
joué rappelez-v vousous aussi que que
j'ai j'ai un petit peu de décalage avec
vous malheureusement j'ai une j'ai j'ai
une minute de décalage avec vous avec le
chat quand vous proposez des coups je le
vois une minute après et c'est un petit
peu difficile de pouvoir discuter avec
vous à cause de ça alors cavalier prend
de su tour ici ça l' extrêmement logique
hein donc cavaler prend2 l'
logique paf paf paf et on a du mal à
voir quand même comment ça va se
terminer peut-être cavalier g de tour là
une fois que tu défends manger là et
ouvrir ici ça a l'air quand même
difficile à jouer pour euh pour les
blancs
en tout cas ça je vous l'avais je vous
l'avais dit hein que ça être très dur
pour pour pour Fab cette partie dès
qu'il a dès qu'il a bensé qu'av F4 ça
avait l'air extrêmement extrêmement dur
à jouer
pour pour les blancs ça c'était clair
avec le roi qui est complètement à
poil donc dame F1 a été joué comment son
continue même dame dame F3 aussi
intéressant attaque la tour menass
cavalier H3 la je est jamais d'accord
avec moi mais euh mais
euh mais mes coups sont pas si mal je
trouve quand
même
et euh ok donc dame
[Musique]
F1 cavalier donc là il il a joué ça et
on va tour 6 maintenant
euh
h t aussi
[Musique]
ça comment est-ce qu'on continue c'est
très dur pour les blancs je vois pas de
défense à part dame F1 cavg 2 ou cavali
dam F1
enfin c'est
[Musique]
euh
impossible et oui j'ai m de retard en
fait ça c'est c'est tscom qui nous qui
nous impose
ce décalage donc les caméras elles sont
bien les chquier il est bien tout est
c'est du direct mais par contre avec le
chat on a une minute de décalage donc ça
je sais pas pourquoi il nous l'ont
imposé c'était comme ça tout le monde
est comme ça vous voyez aussi avec
tesscom international tesscom espagnol
ce que vous voulez c'est pareil ils ont
leur minute de décalage donc je sais pas
pourquoi mais donc c'est difficile
d'interagir avec le chat dans ces
conditions mais bon c'est c'est les
volontés c'est les volontés de de
chesscom donc bah écoutez on fait comme
ça
euh plus qu'une minute chacun dans cette
partie en diablé entre les deux joueurs
j'ai toujours pas de résultat dans dans
ce match les joueurs qui
qui qui jouent encore alors rapidement
je peux voir un œil iici 3 4 5 je vois
que so il a un avantage assez
intéressant contre la zavic je vois que
Maxime s pas fait
maté il aampion plus toujours et je
pense qu'il est pas mal Maxime j' bien
sa position ON IR voir après ala vous
l'avez ici et Magnus qui a les blanc
Magnus qui a une position de travail
mais qui a de belles chances de faire
nul je pense Maxim MV par Magnus contre
Abdou ouais c'est vouses qui en retard
moi je suis normal donc maintenant
est-ce que il y a pas un truc du style
H4 damelin
H3 H4 a été joué voilà dans l'idée hein
l'idée de bouger la dame et de faire H3
je vois pas comment tu défends ça en
fait et ça benah cette pression là on
s'en fout un peu quand tu prends je
prends c'est la vie
hein c'est
[Musique]
euh même la triche en fait il y a il y a
je vois pas même
pas pas du tout pourquoi pourquoi il a
c'est la triche en fait vu que les
joueurs jouent sur un vrai chquier je
vois pas du tout comment on pourrait
c'est assez bizarre tout
ça mais bon peu importe peu importe
peut-être il y a pas de public là-bas le
seul moyen de faire un truc c'est
d'avoir quelqu'un sur un stream bon j'en
sais rienen plus les liens pour suiv les
parties ils
sont décalé je pense aussi bon je sais
pas à voir tour C a été joué alors
peut-être qu'il veut faire un truc sur
la colonnage A5 a été joué ok sur dame
F3 il y aurait probablement eu ro H2
pour se déclouer de tout ça et sur H3
cavalier bouge peut-être quelque
part 5 en la volonté de
vouloir ouvrir ici et l'idée c'est que
si tu mangeais là je mangeais ici et je
pense que maintenant avec dam là menace
H3 sur dam là ro H2 il aurait eu F pr F2
avec problème sur G3 aussi ça aurait été
la cata c'est pour ça qu'il veut ouvrir
la position dam G4 massage 3 roage 2 qui
m'a l'air assez obligatoire et sur roage
2 les joueurs ont 11 secondes contre 17
avec un incrément de 3 secondes par coup
c'est extrêmement chaud Caval 3 d' F3
probablement ou d' F4 roichin j'ai des
échecs j'ai la perpétuel hein j'ai la
nulle mais j'ai envie j'ai envie de te
mater quand même hein j'ai envie de te
mater
h
comment mat si cavalier bouge j'ai ch
donc ce serait l'idée vraiment d'ouvrir
ce fou quoi dame F4 il prendra pas la
nul
alza il prendra pas la nul il est pas
comme ça il a pris ici ok d'abord pour
empêcher ça ça m'a
l'air fini je pense surprise j'ai fou
prend je menace de manger le cavalier
tout le temps je menace des plein de
trucs échec prise
prise et là je menace beaucoup de choses
de style s prend 5 je do avoir fou là et
tourger pr F2 c'est abandon là abandon
ça j'ai ça sur cavaler là je tout
reprends je crois que c'est abandon
complet de carwana qui donne du coup
avantage alirea dans ce match donc
alirza aura les blancs dans la deuxième
partie pour tenter de gagner ce match
contre kwana ala qui fait un très très
bon début de tournoi en battant abov et
là en battant maintenant ana on va aller
voir Maxime Maxime qui joue non je me
suis trompé de caméra c'est celle-là
Maxime qui dort sans sa chaise euh la
position de Maxime il a les Noirs ici et
j'ai l'impression que ben il est pas mal
du tout parce que Nakamura n'a pas
réussi à profiter de la faiblesse du roi
noir donc là il y a deux pions plus
maintenant pour mvl et un pion qui a
l'air d'avanc quand même assez vite les
joueurs ont plus de temps 12 secondes
contre
7 ikarou qui qui secoue la tête qui
n'est pas content du tout ikarou qui
fait aujourd'hui son anniversaire en
perdant toutes ses parties il a perdu
contre sa 1 et demi 0 et demi mais la
partie qui fait nul qu perdant mais il
fait nul parce que so n'a pas besoin de
gagner dame C6 dame C3 donc là il veut
garder le cavalier pour essayer de faire
des menaces de mat un jour quelque
part mais bon c'est un Malard difficile4
prise on mange le P trois pions de plus
maintenant échec et le roi qui s'échappe
par ici j'ai
l'impression mais attention ça me fait
peur quand même C soir là ça me fait
peur il a pas fait échec c'est que
j'aurais eu fou F tout le temps sur
échec là j'aurais eu fou F8 qui couvrait
j'ai encore un un échec là-haut j'ai un
échec là ro ici est-ce que c'est pas une
nulle ça dans surchec j'ai
ça ro 7 qui av F5 je m'échappe je
crois il se passe plus rien alors ça on
va défendre ici F7 et on est prêt à
pousser maintenant aussi F2 en l'air qui
est l'AR très très appétissant ce pion
avec échec et mat qui peut arriver donc
là il faut bouger la dame le roi donc il
donne le pion
ici le fou le fou qui est perdu mais
j'ai des pions qui avancent très très
vite c'est très compliqué là il peut
tous passer il peut tous passer en cette
position là VI B2 pour
bloquer probablement
il pousse le pion C montée droit était
pas mal
[Musique]
aussi
tac non il est pas éliminé là c'est
c'est un
tournoi tout ronde et et à la fin les
deux derniers de du classement général
après élimination seront éliminés les
quatre du milieu joueront des play-offs
les deux premiers seront euh qualifiés
pour les
demi-finales il y a une nulle possible
par Nakamura j'ai l'impression avec ça
et ça mais est ce qu'il va la prendre
c'est pas clair j'ai cavalier C à l'
aussi intéressant je crois qu'il va
prendre la nul il il a plus de temps la
pendule et
ça a fait nul et bah j'ai envie de dire
quand même que donc là il marqué 1 1 et
demi c'est assez bizarre alors c'est la
première partie hein donc là faut pas
regarder ce qui se passe là mais on a
l'impression quand même que c'est
euh c'est gros match
cont de fa je pense par que il passé
plein de chos il reste une seule partie
c'est la partie de Magnus
contre on va aller voir magnusable 3 je
crois 4 on les retrouve il Magnus
contre dans cette partie les cam à jour
problème ça fait nul ça nul mais très
probablement Magnus qui ESS de la
pression
même s'il y a très très très peu de
chance de gain ici F F8 est-ce que c'est
5 c'est un coup il ro B5 tout le
temps cavaler B2 alors il pe un CAV H5
mais ça fait rien malheureusement tout
se défend et je peux jamais passer
quoi même C 5 F prend voilà c'est pas
une
amélioration
malheureusement
c'est nul il y a pas grand-chose à faire
ici pas grand-chose à
faire pour
Magnus Magnus qui pourrait essayer de de
espérer c'est que le fou parte pour
cavalier prend F6 suivi de G7 ou même si
le fou partait même faire cavalier H6
Chion prend il y aurait ça ce qu'il
fouttait pas là et après rentrer essayer
de faire un truc quand tu es rentré là
mais il arrivera jamais à passer le
cavalier
il fait échec mais attention quand même
de pas te faire ch le cavalier parce que
la finale
complètement perdante cavalier prend5
est une menace voilà il a défendu sur
pion pr il y avait F6 peut-être et donc
là il a défendu le pion
ici c'est juste nul en fait Magnus il
tente il tente il tente de toute façon
il a zéro chance de perdre à priorie
donc il a raison de la jouer au
final mais ça va faire nul dans cette
partie sans trop trop de difficulté pour
lui roi B3 c'est la partie r B4 bon là
ça va répéter et ça fait nul et ça fait
nul dans ce match donc là on a encore
une fois 2 1 mais là ça n'a rien à voir
c'est chesscom c'est c'est pas bon donc
il y a eu il y a eu victoire de so
Westley contre deil aavic on a une
victoire d'alireza très convainquante
sur carwana et on a eu deux nuls entre
ikarun camur et maxima chellagrave et
aussi de Magnus contre nodiberg abov
voilà donc ça c'est le score actuel donc
on va voir maintenant la partie retour
d'ici euh je pense environ 5 10 minutes
petite pause et à notre retour et ben on
aura du coup la partie retour et un
éventuel Armagedon si jamais l'égalité
persiste entre les joueurs donc on fait
une petite pause je vous dis à tout de
suite ne partez pas restez connectés et
euh sooso qui vient d'arriver donc salut
à toi content de te voir mais il y a une
pause donc du coup euh on revient dans
un instant reste parmi nous euh reste
parmi nous SOIC et je te dis à tout de
[Musique]
suite
nei would a Sicilian defense to the
untrained ey this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things new open for yourall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displ now with the official
collection from ch.com M thems with mag
and swap themever you make your move get
an exclusive discount on all metal
posters shop now with the code chess
[Musique]
displate.com
back
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on reprend je suis ici les joueurs qui
devrai commencer d'ici un instant est-ce
qu'on suit plutôt mvl ou plutôt
alira j'ai envie de suivre plutôt mvl
moi perso je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez parce que
mvl bah il a fait match nul lors de la
première partie
du coup il a encore tout à jouer alors
qu'adira joue avec les Blancs pour la
nul
mal à s'apporter même si bon bien sûr en
face c'est
carwana peut se passer plein de choses
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez est-ce
qu'on se fait plutôt un mvl avec les
Blancs contre Naka ou est-ce qu'on se
fait
plutôt un alirea moi je suis plus pour
pour mvl mais dites dans le chat ce que
vous
préférez dites-moi ce que vous préférez
et puis on on va regarder tranquillement
ensemble dites-moi dans le chat ce que
vous
préférez il a
gagné de mettre le score en
place et Magnus ça fait
nul
hop plutôt mvl parce que la partie est
décisive rajabof non
ban euh oui oui je suis plus sur MVN
parce que parce que bon il s'est encore
rien passé alors que j'ai envie de dire
que alira quand même de plus de chance
hein de de se qualifier là vu qu'il a
gagné la première partie avec clé noir
mais après on ira voir aussi les deux
hein bien sûr comme nous dis dans le
chat
hhgus on ira voir les deux mais on va
plutôt suivre en grand écran notre petit
mvl d'ailleurs question vous préférez
cette vue
ou est-ce que vous préférez une vue avec
des grandes cames alors je vous montre
hein vous me dites un ce que vous
préférez euh ou la ligne de cavalier
prend le4 par Naka ça c'est une ligne
qui est censé pas être très bonne waouh
t prend D6 D4 puis on prend et il y a
une ligne qui est pas mal ici pour les
blancs bon c'est D4 puis on prend puis
on prend il me semble que c'est il y a
il y a un cavalier
C6 je crois que là il y a un des coups
qui est très très sympa c'est le coup
ici cavalier C3
très facile parce qu'è d prend5 dame
prend5 cavalier prend5 et cavalier B5
est très gênant et sur F la théorique va
les prend puis on prend on a une
meilleure structure avec les Blancs et
la paire de fou après il y a des chances
quand même c'est qume sol chez les Noirs
mais c'est très très c'est quand même
mieux pour les pour les
blancs réfléchi il y a plusieurs
possibilités mais celleel quei donné
c'est la possibilité où les blancs sont
mieux sans qu'il y ait trop de
complication donc rapidement vous
préférez cette vue là ou la vue que la
Big
caméra je peux vous mettre la je peux
vous mettre la vraie caméra ce qui veut
dire que je peux vous mettre mvl je
crois que c'est celle-là voilà bon ça a
disparu j'ai pas ma caméra mais est-ce
que vous préférez celle-là ou est-ce que
vous préférez
l'autre moi en
soi en soi ça me va très bien je mets
les chquill je le mets
bien parce que les chqu je peux metre
bien si vous voulez
hein est-ce que vous préférez ça on VO
quand même pas mal on va les jouer en
grand euh où est-ce que vous préférez
plutôt
l'autre je sais pas faut me dire un peu
ce que vous préférez je peux vous régler
la
caméra je peux vous la mettre très très
bien comme ça
al je sais qu'on a un gros délai le chat
c'est pour ça que
[Musique]
que c'est pour ça que j'attends un petit
peu dites-moi si vous avez des
préférences je suis en train de régler
un peu la la scène au cas
[Musique]
où je l'avais pas fait avant parce que
bien évidemment je ne savais pas que je
seraai seul
aujourd'hui
grand échquier grand échquier l'autre
ok ok la première alors attendez je fais
quand même je finis quand même juste de
faire
ça histoire
de même si elle marche pas
bien j'ai un problème de caméra là
enquoi marche pas ah ça y est je l'ai
trouvé j'arrive he je je vous remets le
l'autre hein mais juste je suis un peu
maniaque des fois donc j'ai juste envie
de de
mettre de terminer de de mettre cette
caméra juste parce que je suis
maniaque mais c'est
tout hop là
allez on REP sur la de du coup là j'
tout bien fait en plus c'était bien beau
on part sur
celle-là
là on voit mieux quand même voyz des
joueurs est plus grand et MV est parti
sur celle voilà m est parti sur la ligne
que j'avais proposé regarde il a joué
Caval C3 il Cali pr cavalier B5 F B4 je
connais pas je CIS fou
D6 pr prise ro D8 ça paraî quand Mme
assez
bizarre mais bon alle F
C4 S c'est très ça ça c'est très
possible très possible que ce soit
l'idée de Laurent
euh Laurent des fois qui n'aime pas
répondre aux provocations du public
et et oui en fait c'est un contrôle un
peu antitriche je pense c'est des
mesures un peu qui ont été prises et du
coup nous on est obligé de suivre ça et
un peu de subir parce que franchement
moi j'aime bien interagir avec le chat
mais le problème c'est que là je peux
pas du tout interagir vu que
euhah tout simplement je vois vos
messages une minute après que vous les
poter donc c'est le problème qui est
vraiment dommage j'arrive pas du tout à
suivre le chat enfin je suis le chat
mais je peux pas vous répondre au moment
où vous l'écrivez et c'est c'est ce qui
est dommage mais bon c'est comme ça
c'est la vie hein c'est la vie
euh sachez que je vous vois une minute
après donc si vous me posez une question
dans la position
ça sera pas vu je pense donc fou des ça
a été joué alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut
jouer ici mettre les tours là ça quand
même une bonne idée je quand même mon
roi milieu qui pose un peu problème
salut Léon salut à
toi je nouveau coach d' mvl ah oui ah
oui bon c'est connu ça c'est connu he ce
que j'ai montré j'invente rien j'invente
rien un filtre enlever la barbe de mvl
oui oui je peux le faire si tu veux
je peux le faire je peux Mme mettre tu
peux mettre un Pikachu sur la tête de de
Naka
euh un petit casque
Pikachou pour être pas mal aussi je peux
tout
faire
al il a j qu' la 3 alors j'imagine
qu'une des menaces aussi c'était
peut-être de jouer F pr B5 et de jouer
la
finale donc euh là avec cavalier C3 on
garde un peu les pièces et mvl qui se
lève il aim bien se lev mvl he dans le
canance rapide alors généralement quand
on joue en rapide il y a pas trop trop
de moyen où on se lève ça ça arrive pas
trop généralement parce qu'on a quand
même pas trop de temps à la pendule 11
minutes enfin là 11 minutes plus 3
secondes par coup généralement c ça tu
te lève pas trop mais après c'est un peu
psychologique aussi c'est euh voilà mais
MV on on on voit souvent se lever même
on l'avait même vu au champelat du monde
des fois mais normalement tu
tu
c'est pas trop ça quoi et l'air qui est
chez moi c'est c'est c'est pas chez moi
l'airin c'est la salle de jeu je pense
parce que moi j'ai pas de Hings chez moi
malheureusement je n'ai pas reçu
l'appareil quelqu'un pour me résumer ce
qui s'est passé dès le début du tournoi
oui Shado avec grand plaisir alors on a
eu des matchs qui se sont passés donc on
a ici lors de la ronde 1 on a soley qui
a battu Nakamura 1 et demi à 0 et demi
on a Magnus car qui a battu 1 et demi à
0 et demi den laavic on a Alireza qui a
battu abantorov 1 et demi 0 et demi
aussi on a mvl qui perd enedon
malheureusement contre carwana lors de
la ronde 2 du coup on a Carlsen qui a
fait nul la ronde 1 contre Abd là c'est
la R 2 on a Alireza qui a battu kwana
avec les Noirs donc là se joue la round
2 on la partie en direct de Maxime
contre ikarou la première ronde a fait
nul et dans le match West lo contre
Denis lazavic il y a eu aussi 1-0 pour
West lo donc je vous rappelle là c'est
un tout ronde tout le monde joue contre
tout le monde des match en aller-retour
s'il y a un partout il y aura une
trisème partie d'ARM magadon pour
départager et à l'issue de ce tout ronde
qui va se terminer dans la semaine et
ben on va avoir des demi finale
euh les deux premiers de tout rondes
sont qualifiés directement en
demi-finale les 3è 4e 5e et 6e vont se
disputer
pour jouer enfin il y aura que deux
places qualificatives parmi ces 4
joueurs pour les deuxièmes demi-finales
et
ensuite les deux derniers des tout
rondes seront éliminés de la
compétition donc là il y a eu une nulle
un petit peu B bizar de mvl contre
Nakamura nakamur quiêtre assez content
parce que tout simplement il a les noirs
et c'est un bon résultat faire nul donc
il y a une répétition
ici même pas répétition propose nul et
c'est dans la position il s pas passé
grandchose c'est assez égal donc les
joueurs font nul Maxime l'
blasé sur sa chaise on va vite aller
voir ce que ce que nous fait du coup
c'est quand même le joueur qu'on va
suivre donc le 3 il a les blancs et
c'est une position assez assez
bizarre qu'est-ce que c'est comme
ouverture àreavis c'est une scandinave
peut-être
ou est-ce que c'est une
carocan non je pense c'est scandinave
avec avec de cavalier F6 je dirais à
voir non même pas cavalier F6
là rien à voir avec ce que j'ai
pronostiqué il s complètement senti
battu et
apparemmentarment ça l'air très très
fort ici pour pour les blancs ici je
crois que G5 éta ride quimentur il est
bizarre
aujourd'hui ça ça et
ça mais il change d'AV maintenant qu'on
joue les coup
bizar C PR6 il va manger comme ça plus
tard le pion cavalier G5 et voir
maintenant ce qui va se passer donc alaz
qui a des blancs dans cette
partie
et et il a besoin d'une nulle pour
gagner ce mini
match juste une nulle je vais voir ce
qui se passe à côté donc on a Armagedon
de sûr entre mvl et kamura après on
parler peu de de de ce qui se passe dans
l'armagadon cont pass quoi un petit peu
de d'ici rien spécial j'ai l'impression
et dans la partie de Abdou contre
car passe pas grandchose non plus pour
l'instant donc je pense qu'on r d'avoir
des en tout cas Magnus c'est position
qui l' ass assz plate
et celle-là je vois pas trop quand même
àa perdre celle-là avec les Blancs je
pense que je pense qu'il va réussir à la
tenir les se aujourd'hui non pas du tout
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est c'est a
que deux matchs donc le match qu'on a
fait avant et celui-là donc il y a cette
partie là làagedon et aujourd'hui c'est
terminé demain il y aura d'autres rond
et un peu tous les jours d'ailleurs
demain c'est le retour de Kevin et Fab
qui rentreront de la Cup et qui vont
commenter à ma place l'événement donc
toute la semaine d'ailleurs moi je fais
qu'aujourd'hui
hein je fais que
aujourd'hui à moins qu'il y ait un
problème mais normalement je fais
qu'aujourd'hui bonjour t du futur oui
merci pour ton message
euh alors non shadox tu sais que toute
l'année en fait il y a eu il y a eu
plein de tournois de champion chest tour
il y en a eu six et euh et à l'issue de
ces tournois il y avait des des points
que tu gagnais à chaque étape que tu
jouais ces pointsl était qualificatif
pour cette finale qui a lieu maintenant
à Toronto tu vois généralement ces
joueurs étaient tous sur Internet et là
aujourd'hui et ben on les voit
directement derrière les chiquier donc
là c'est IRL les joueurs sont tous allés
à Toronto au Canada et et maintenant ils
jouent leur leur tournoi comme ça les
prix sont monstrueux je vais vous les
montrer un petit peu hop regardez le
premier prix du tournoi gagne 200000 €
alors 200000 € c'est quand même pas mal
hein 100000 € pour le 2e 50000 pour les
3 et 4è 5 25000 € donc on parle en
dollar plutôt hein 25000 dollars pour le
5e 20000 dollars pour le 6e 15000
dollars pour le 7e et 8000 dollars pour
le pour le 8e pour le
dernier et parmi tout ça chaque match
gagné quand je dis match c'est pas parti
he c'est match remporte 1000 dollars
donc du coup c'est pas mal comme comme
prix mais il faut gagner bon même 8e
c'est pas mal hein moi moi je signe
direct pour me qualifier mais évidemment
premier c'est quand même beaucoup plus
important que que que que le 8e prix
voilà pour les
prix ils vont être frais bah ouais je
crois qu'il rentrent ils prennent le
train alors je connais pas leurs
horaires de train tout ça mais euh a
priori c'est eux qui qui prennent la la
suite
ouais c'est la finale c'est la finale
shadx donc les prix ça rigolent pas hein
ça rigole pas quand tu es champion du
monde hein
et encore ces prix là nous on les voit
c'est super mais comparer ça avec avec
un autre sport c'est pas si fort que ça
quand vous voyez un peu le foot comment
les Jeur sont payés vous voyez le tennis
comment les les top joueurs sont payés
au final au
échecs c'est bien on gagne de l'argent
mais au final si tu compare avec tout ça
on est très très loin du compte hein
mais bon tu prends 200000 € sur un
tournoi qui dure une semaine tu as fait
une belle semaine quand même hein tu as
quand même fait une belle semaine mais
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que voilà il y
a beaucoup quand même de de sports qui
sont qui sont plus intéressants que
celui-là quoi niveau
financier c'est aussi un en terme de
popularité aussi he les échecs c'est
quand même beaucoup moins populaire on
regarde moins la télé mais bon c'est
quand même de plus en plus populaire là
on voit un peu tous les streams tout le
tout ce qui se passe tous les événements
c'est de plus en plus populaire donc on
va pas cracher un peu dessus mais c'est
vrai que que là c'est ça fait plaisir de
voir des beaux tournois comme
ça lireza qui a les blancs cette partie
après petit rock fa attention au temps
quand même Alireza qui qui a besoin
d'une nulle et alira avec sa nul dont il
a besoin il est capable enfin il est
capable de de jouer le gain à fond et de
perdre euh parce que c'est un jur
d'échec avant tout et qu'il a envie de
jouer qu' a envie de bien jouer il a
envie de faire des bons coups et cetera
même si clairement ici alira devrait
jouer pour la nul parce que en faisant
nul et ben
euh il gagnerait son match donc c'est
important de gagner son match avec tout
l'enjeu qu'il y a dans ce tournoi tu as
envie quand même de pas trop prendre de
risque donc là il a gagné la première
partie maintenant la deuxième partie il
devrait jouer solide mais euh mais jouer
solide jouer solide
avec c'est difficile par qu'za il a un
style très offensif il aime beaucoup
attaquer il aime beaucoup il est très
créatif et c'est un joueur qui est pas
du tout pleutre il aime bien balancer il
aime
bien c'est aussi pour ça qu'on l'aime on
aime bien les joueurs créatifs on aime
bien les joueurs qui prennent des
risques on a bien les joueurs qui qui
qui font des vrais échecs qui ont pas
peur de de
jouer 12000 sur la semaine je suis
content mais je pense que il y a très
très peu de monde sur le chat qui
cracher
ri mais mais c'est vrai qu'entre 12000
et
200000 il y a quand même une grosse
différence mais bien entendu je pense
qu'on crache pas dessus
ensuite bon maintenant à haut niveau
voyez les joueurs les joueurs qui
participent à ce à ce tournoi là pour
eux c'est très standard ces prix là bon
là c'est le gros prix c'est c'est la
grande finale donc c'est quand même même
même je pense même pour un mvl c'est
quand même des gros prix mais je pense
Caren ça lui fait ni fois ni fr Caren je
pense qu'il veut gagner le tournoi parce
que c'est un joueur qui veut tout gagner
quoi mais c'est pas mais c'est pas pour
l'argent que que que Carsen il veut
gagner le tournoi c'est parce que c'est
un joueur qui gagne tout et que c'est un
joueur d'échec il est très très combatif
et il veut gagner tous les tourno au
participe mais c'est pas pour l'argent
c'est beaucoup plus
pour pour jouer quoi pour le principe
quoi alors que les autres joueurs je
pense tu enlèv Nakamura caracen tous les
autres sont intéressés quand
même mais Nakamura et Carlsen pe-être
c'est les moins moins intéressés pour ça
par ça ils veulent juste j d'échec quoi
je
pense après bien sûr 200000 200000 c'est
prix hein c'est prix hein mais bon quand
tu as 100 million d'euros sur ton compte
est-ce que 200000 € çaintéresse en ENF
fou quoi
mais je comprends hein mais euh je suis
pas sûr que Nakamura pour 200 pour
200000 € je pense que c'est vraiment
pour lui c'est un pour boire ça c'est un
pour boire c'est un gros pour boire mais
mais c'est pas du tout un truc
ok donc A5 é je tour D1 a l'air très
très logique leg3 il veut essayer de
d'ouvrir un peu ça il veut jouer son jeu
he il va
attquer Championnat du Monde c'est les
mêmes prix je crois pas je crois que
c'est beaucoup moins je crois que c'est
beaucoup moins les prix mais je les ai
pas je les ai pas en tête les prix
Championnat du Monde Guillaume mais je
sais que pour championnat du monde les
joueurs ont des
tickets ce qui veut dire qu'en fait pour
participer à un tour à un tournoi les
joueurs la FIDE est très contente la
FIDE sil y a Carsen qui vient jouer par
exemple et du coup euh et du coup ah tu
parles Championnat du Monde euh pardon
ch championnat du monde par par oui oui
pardon oui c'est c'est encore plus je
pensais qu' par Championnat du Monde en
c'est rapide alors oui en Pary lant il y
a environ 1 million ou peut-être 2
millions et quelques je crois 2 millions
qui sont qui sont divisés en deux et le
premier c'est un truc du style 12 et le
deuxème c'est genre 800000 un truc comme
ça je crois j'ai pas les prix après ça
dépend des sponsors je sais pas comment
ça pass mais je crois que c'est environ
il y a environ 2 millions partagés truc
comme ça mais Championnat du Monde le
Championnat du Monde Blitz et rapide et
ben les prix sont beaucoup plus bas je
crois mais chaque joueur a vraiment
enfin ont des tickets pour participer
c'estàd que pour que Magnus vienne jouer
le tournoi il va recevoir un caché bon
déjà il est payé pour venir jouer et en
plus il a le prix quand il gagne donc il
se mettent bien les joueurs il se
mettent bien les joueurs avoir une belle
retraite
200 K de plus sur le million mais c'est
pas c'est pas le million
r C'est les centaines de millions non
c'est
pas nous à notre échelle à notre échelle
tu fais un gros tournoi tu gagnes 20
€
voilà je pense que c'est pareil pour eux
je pense c'est pareil pour mais je parle
surtout de
Naka que le reste je pense que c'est
quand même c'est un peu moins mais mais
bon alors H4 a été joué donc là j'aime
bien ce qu'il fait alirea mais il joue
vraiment sans la peur et il joue son
style malgré tout alors vous savez que
des fois quand on joue pour un résultat
on finit par perdre c'estàdire par
exemple vous savez que si vous faites
match nul vous gagnez le match bien vous
allez jouer serré solide pour la nul bah
le fait de jouer ce jeu-là ça vous
empêche de jouer vraiment fa coup à vous
par exemple Anira c'est un joueur qui
est hyper actif qui aime beaucoup
attaquer et ben s'il se met à jouerp
défensif il il va mal jouer il va
relâcher ses coups il va pas jouer les
coups qui que vraiment il voudrait faire
et du coup il préfère prendre des
risques quand même même si et ben il a
gagné la première partie et qu'il joue
du coup pour faire nul mais il joue pour
faire nul en attaquant et euh et du coup
euh je trouve que c'est intéressant
quand même ce que fait
il se retient pas et si après il peut
faire nul dans une position bah c'est
bien il apprendra probablement parce
queah ça change rien pour lui de faire N
ou de gagner vu que gag la première
partie
mais mais voyez que des fois il faut
juste jouer son style ça que je veux
dire moi ça m'est arrivé plusieurs fois
j'avais joué il y a de nombreuses années
en Open à CAN et dernière ronde si je
faisais match nul
et ben je faisais une norme de MRE donc
à l'époque avais pas encore donc au
final maintenant je m'en foutrai mais à
l'époque j'avais pas de norme et j'avais
les Noirs contre un M 2450 et et moi
j'avais 2200 comme ça et du coup je nul
donc j'ai les noirs et C et puis je suis
content ça se passe pas trop mal et
cetera et puis un moment donné j'ai une
position je peux attaquer mais je fais
pas je sais pas trop en fait comment
comment jouer
et au final j'avais une grosse position
je pouvais mêmeêre la gagner j'étais
mais j'ai tellement essayé de jouer
serrure pour pas perdre que j'ai retenu
mes coups j'ai pas frappé et j'ai fini
par par par me faire retourner
complètement et perdre la partie voilà
et en fait avec l'expérience maintenant
et ben je pense que si tu veux jouer ton
jeu tu joues d's j'avais encore une
autre histoire j'avais fait encore une
fois pour une autre norme que j'avais
fait en en National 1 et je jou un grand
maître à 2500 et et il faut que je fasse
un et demi sur de sur le weekend donc
j'ai deux matchs je joue un 2500 avec
les Blancs et un 2200 avec les noirs et
1 je joue un 200 je sais que si je fais
nul faudra que je batte le lendemain un
2500 pardon un 2200 avec avec les noirs
du coup j'ai quand même des chances de
gagner
et dans ma tête je voulais faire nul
contre le grand maître pour avoir mes
chances contre le 2002 et cont le grand
mètre j'ai balancé mes pions H4 de
partout j'ai fait petit j'ai fait H4
aprs un peu commeisin et euh je me que
pendant la partie je me suis posé la
question est-ce que je joue serrure ou
est-ce que je joue mon jeu et pu
finalement j'ai dit putens on s'en fout
je joue mon jeu et j'ai joué mon jeu
j'étais content parce que l'idée en fait
c'est que que tu joues il faut pas jouer
contre son cile en fait même si tu joues
pour la nul et j'ai joué mon jeu et j'ai
gagné la partie contre le grand maître
j'ai gagné en 20 coups un truc comme ça
il m'a donné une pièce bon ok j'ai eu un
peu de chance peut-être il a pas il pas
vu un truc tout con mais j'ai gagné la
partie et du coup le lendemain bah ça
changé je devais faire nul contre un
2200 plutôt que de gagner à la base donc
j'ai fait n assez facile et j'ai fait ma
norme ma première norme de d'ailleurs
en mais voilà faut pas jouer absolument
pour le résultat alors C5 a l'air quand
même intéressant maisam prend G3 donc là
F2 G4 faut trouver une solution pour
venir défendre le P G3
salut
alors chadoc pour être payé en jéchec il
faut être très
fort très très très fort donc tu peux
toujours essayer mais mais
vas-y mais il vaut mieux gagner en
faisant victoire défaite victoire qu'en
faisant victoire nul pourquoi
Kevin si on gagne le match c'est une
prime oui mais quand tu quand qu tu
gagnes le match avec Armagedon bah tu
gagnes le match quand même je comprends
pas en fait c'est pareil non enfin je
sais pas à moins que tu gagnes que quand
tu fais comme ça mais je pense que tu
gagnes peu importe à moins que le match
c'est que
en en deux parties je sais pas Kevin je
sais pas du
tout je j'ai pas vu
ça bon après voilà c'est c'est pas si
important quand tu prends 200000 € je
pense pas que tu calcules B une partie
tu à gagner quoi enfin que prend 200000
€ ou 204000
[Musique]
€ sont pas après quoi toujours bien bien
sûr
mais ça ça
tourne Fabi qui joue vite qui joue des
coups simples il essaie de mettre un peu
la
pression lesirea ben il monte sa
position il va faire des trucs qu' H3 un
jour pour enlever du vis-à-is je pense
ça va être un coup qui va être joué un
jour donc ici alira il est beaucoup
mieux mais il a une position quand même
vous voyez qui est assez compliqué dans
le sens où c'est assez ouvert sur son
roi et malgré tout il il est mieux mais
euh il faut faire attention que ça peut
quand même être dangereux au niveau du
contre-jeu parce que le roi blanc est un
petit peu à l'air donc si alira il
pousse trop ses pions trop ses trucs il
se met toujours un petit peu en danger
de se prendre une tactique ou de rater
quelque chose cavalier F5 cavalier prend
C3 peu des fois menac aussi le cavalier
prend H4 avec dam H2 faire attention
voyez ça peêtre dangereux quand même sur
fou F4 il y a peut-être alors je suis
pas sûr cavalier prend H4 je pas sûr que
ça marche si tu prends là je prends là
peut-être là j'ai roi H3 qui attaquerait
là et là compliqué tu vois mais il y a
plein de choses à à voir en tout cas il
fou prend F5 prend F5 fou F4 d D7 il a
pris et là c'est bien j'ai bien aimé ce
qu'il a fait comme séquence parce que
maintenant il va arriver il va réussir
un peu à calmer le jeu avec tour1
peutêtre
T5 il faut s un petit peu F4 quand même
qui peut être dangereux pour ouvrir
vraiment le roi blanc à voir si c'est
possible alors je vais baisser un peu
mon micro pour faire plaisir à mine qui
me dit ça te va
mieux alors je réponds à des questions
qui sont pas sur twitch oui je réponds à
des questions qui sont sur Youtube euh
hgus on est un peu de
partout record hello à 101 en rapide
euh écoute
shadox c'est pas contre toi he
mais ces mecs là c'est c'est les
meilleurs joueurs du
monde donc tu veux gagner 200000 € sur
un tournoi à Toronto l'année prochaine
il va falloir que tu fasses de sacré
progrès ça fait deux points au lieu de 1
et demi donc meilleur classe pour
accéder au demi non mais Kevin c'est
pareil c'est pareil à la fin que tu
gagnes le match 2 et demi à 1 et demi ou
1 et demi à 0 et demi tu gagnes un point
peu importe le le résultat on s'en fout
en fait ça ne change
rien c'est pareil Kevin faut juste
gagner le match on s'en fout du
score tu une caméra qui est partie chez
moi caméra de Fabi qui qui ne qui marche
plus apparemment ah non c'est un mec qui
s'est mis devant
ok les gens respectent pas les
caméras les gens qui respectent pas les
caméras alors mon micro tout à l'heure
il était bien je l'avais changé parce
qu'il avait j'étais par rapport à par
rapport
à à Fab j'étais un peu trop
bas est-ce que le micro ça va mieux je
sais pas si ça a changé des choses ce
que je montre
mais
alors tac
tac je fais des tests je pas ça va mieux
mais dame F5 a été joué attention à Dame
C2
j'ai pas vu la j j'étais en train
de alors rapidement je voir ce qui s
passé de
jauge la Jae quime pas mal descendu
ou il fallait jouer autre chose là
peut-être la apparemment mais compliqué
ok là j'ai un peu peur qume pour son
quand Mme faible sur le long terme son
roi est faible ça pose des problèmes 30
secondes à la pu pour Alireza demandez
au mec là de de se bouger là il est
devant la cam de devant la cam de de
carwana ça me gêne un petit peu s'il
vous
plaît micro est très bien merci à vous
en tout cas
euh vas-y bouge-toi quoi reste pas là
quoi [__] les gens
quoi en terme de ça marche comment ce
format
oui de
parties deux parties tu joues en
allerretour et en cas d'égalité et
ben en cas d'égalité tu auras une
dernière
partie pour départager vraiment tout ça
et qui joue avec plus
que 15 secondes à la pendule fa jouer
faut jouer un
coup6
il y a plus de temps à la pendule c'est
très
chaud il faut m'expliquer alors car a
fait un puis un demi au premier match et
un pour l'instant au
deuxè donc il a,5
[Musique]
classement
alors on verra ça un petit peu après la
avant la pause Kevin je te montrerai le
classement tu vas mieux comprendre parce
que là je crois qu'on comprend pas j'ai
très très peur pour le roi de d'ireza on
regarda après après Kevin parce que là
on va quand même rester sur le direct de
la
partie le prix des pièces est plus fort
alors ça par contre j'ai pas
changé je vais vous baisser un peu sens
si vous
voulez je baisser un peu le son de
pièces
euh si vous préférez
hop après je peux vous changez hein moi
j'avais mis du gain sur mon micro si
vous voulez je peux vous en mettre un
peu plus hein on va on va monter un
petit peu je vais monter
à est-ce que c'est mieux au niveau du
gain ou est-ce que c'est beaucoup trop
ou est-ce que c'est pas
assez là j'ai changer un petit peu les
choses l'arbitre est parti fantastique
on voit on voit notre ami Fabi et non je
parle trop vite encore une fois
euh fa par contre faut pas qu'il se
mette en parce que ça peut mal tourner
cette finale pour les deux
joueurs
alors je te réponds après Kevin sur
Youtube je te réponds après parce que je
je vais te montrer en fait le classement
tu vas
comprendre mon classement tu vas mieux
comprendre parce que là on je crois
qu'on qu'on se comprend pas en
fait je crois qu'on se comprend pas
juste
Magnus a fait nul
Abdou donc ça part en break je vois que
Nakam n cont MV l' vu et que est
[Musique]
qualifié un chou
plus plus
alors
voilà le chouya est
rajouté j'espère que c'est bien
maintenant allez change plus rien je
change plus rien je touche plus à
rien 3 H3 G6 donc là l'avantage d'avoir
mis le pion chqu en D7 c'est que la tour
pourra pas participer au math vous voyez
parce que le pion bloque donc là a quand
même des chances de tenir pour euh pour
alerza même si
même si euh il y a plus de temps à la
pendule je Rapp y a quand même 3
secondes par
coup il joue
B5 alors dame3 attention que je peux
gagner la partie un jourin si tu pousse
trop loin je peux la gagner quand même
hein là il y a plus d'échec
possible dame F2 il ve manger F7 he le
malin dame 1 il empêche la prise en F7
dame
D4 en fait il veut juste attendre par
que la tour elle est elle est immobile
les pions une fois qu'il vont avancer
ils vont finir par être bloqué et le Roi
peut pas sortir de son truc
donc dame D5 pour défendre là mais il y
aura échec là il prend
B4 allez bouge ton roi t prend D7 le
clouage ou c'est compliqué là tout est
en prise sur roi là il y aura échec
attention attention ce roi doit y avoir
puttin ça me fait peur sans ça il y a
peut-être ça je sais pas trop comment
faire il faut venir là je pense là il y
aura tour ici qui pouvit faire
échec non fait quoi sur ça il y a ça je
peux mettre mon roi ici al ça ça marche
toujours pas prend le
7 tour ici ah ça me fait très très peur
pour le roi de de Alireza mais là vous
voyez qu'il y a plus de temps ni pour
l'un ni pour l'autre donc c'est
extrêmement chaud mais j'ai
l'impressionand Mme est pas bien du tout
en tout cas le RO noir est extrêmement
bien
protégé P
chacun per je pense ça va perdre ça va
perdion sont perd en plus la finale qui
pour les Noirs non plus parce que trop
vite échec sur ple d'échec plus de temps
pour les joueurs c'est extrêmement
compliqué éche
T4
il faut terminer échec après je peux
aussi à un moment donné faire échec
manger là et manger en g5in et essayer
de pousser hein c'est aussi possible
mais bon je sais pas trop qui va gagner
la
course mais en tout cas c'est clair que
enfin que que il va tenter
ça
Fabiano au pire des cas il faut tenter
un truc he ça c'est un coup ou pas
peut-être que oui hein avec des échecs
Tam c'est de de l'autre
côtéas l'arbitre qui est toujours devant
devant devant Fabi l'arbitre qui veut
pas nous laisser
hein on ne va pas avoir Fabi tour prend
prise et d prend G5 c'est ce que je
pensais mais d prend à4 probablement et
maintenant on va faire la course des
pions c'est très très
chaud et là du coup alors là MCK c'est
pas les pion qui sont important hein
c'est pas les pions qui sont ant c'est
euh plutôt euh c'est enfin c'est pas le
nombre de pions qui ant c'est euh on va
dire là où tu es plus proche de la
promotion quoi un pion plus avancé et
plus dangereux que en fait la majorité
enfin fut la majorité ce qui m'intéresse
c'est euh c'est les pions quoi donc là
je perd ici et là c'est dommage quand M
de perdre ce pion parce que lui il
pourra plus
avancer très très dur comment on joue
ici dame ici on va attaquer F7 tu prends
là je prends là il y a quand même des
chances de nul quand même mais
bon je pense que ça pas mal quand même
tu défends ton pion et tu essayes de
défendre comme ça mais c'est pas
facile mais là il est clair qu'il faut
venir défendre le pion d'une manière ou
d'une autre ah il il a joué avec ça G4
va arriver donc peut-être 3 F3 était
possible il y a plus de temps c'est très
compliqué
l'arbitre il est il est insupportablein
Fran frement
quo l'arbitre allez G3 peut-être avec
échec
ça l'impression que je peux peut-être
faire un
truc
H6 ok il y a ça et ça donc il anticipé
donc pr F7 maisain c'est des pions
doublés et il y a pas d'échec qui gagne
la dame peut-être qu'on peut faire ça
F3
je crois que ça
gagne F3 c'est gagné en C en fait je
crois parce que après j'ai l'opposition
il a abandonné direct je crois sur dame
2 bon il y a eu ça en fait voilà dame
F3 pr F3 prend prend j'ai H5 qui fait
opposition diagonale et cette position
c'est élémentaire ça gagne pour les
Noirs donc Fab qui REC le score et qui a
le droit à un deuxème Armagedon après
avir battu Maxim magedon il va revenir
en Armagedon donc là le seul point
positif du match c'est que so a battu
lazavic dans ce match et on va
maintenant droit à trois ragedon mvl
Naka euh Alireza Fabi et on a aussi
Carsen contre
Abdou pour du coup cette dernière ronde
alors pour revenir à Kevin Chartron qui
est sur Youtube qui je comprends pas
comment ça marche je te montre
rapidement regarde bien écoute-moi bien
pour pas me poser la question
après on a h
joueurs d'accord ça c'est les h
joueurs chaque joueur fait un mini match
cont les autres joueurs dès que tu
gagnes un mini match peu importe le
score que tu gagnes que tu gagnes 2-0
que tu gagnes un et demi0 et demi que tu
gagnes avec la magadon peu importe le
score que tu gagnes et ben tu gagne un
point tu vois que là Magnus il a un
point pourquoi il a un point Magnus
parce qu'il a gagné son match contre
lazavic lors du premier de la première
ronde pour il un point parce qu'il a
battu
absof lors du premier match car pour il
a un point parce qu'il a battu mvl en
magedon so il a deux points parce qu'il
a déjà gagné les deux matchs il a gagné
le premier match contre Nakamura et il a
gagné le deè match contre lazavic lui il
a pas d'armagedon
les ils ont tous zé parce qu'ils ont
tous perdu leur match lors de la ronde 1
maintenant laav a zé parce qu'il a perdu
les deux matchs mais Abdou Maxime et
ikarou eux aussi ils ont zé point mais
là ils jouent des arm ça peut changer
donc que tu gagnes 1 et demi 0 et demi
que tu gagnes 20 que tu gagnesadon c'est
exactement pareil
Kevin il faut juste gagner ce match
c'est tout donc
maintenant par rapport au prix tout à
l'HE on a parlit qu'il a une prime de
1000 dollars pour le joueur qui gagne
son match bah pour l'instant West lesau
il a gagné ces deux matchs donc il a
2000 dollars des G qui sont 11 et et et
et Nakamura Maxim Abdou etav son zé
c'est exactement ça donc j'espère que tu
as bien compris Kevin hein comment ça
marche voilà voilà pour revenir un petit
peu à ça en me demande des questions sur
l'Armageddon alors l'armagedon c'est
très simple c'est un truc qu'on a déjà
vu plein une fois depuis le début ça se
passe par enchère c'est en fait les
joueurs vont écrire sur une enveloppe
euh avec quel temps ils sont d'accord de
prendre les noirs et
euh le joueur qui aura mis le temps le
plus bas commencera avec ce temps-là
mais aura les Noirs euh donc les Blancs
ont 15 minutes contre le temps
l'adversaire qu'ils ont mis en en secret
ça peut être 8 minutes 9 10 ça peut être
n'importe quoi
et les Noirs en cas de nul gagneront le
match tout simplement donc euh je vais
voir un peu sur mon slack est-ce que
j'ai des infos est-ce que j'ai des infos
par rapport par que généralement ils
nous mettent ils nous mettent
les
euh norm il nous mettent les les bêtes
les paris des joueurs hein on dire pour
la
magadon voilà c'est comme au tennis
Gignola exactement que tu gagnes 6-0 ou
75 tu as 17 mais c'est pareil merci très
bon exemple voilà donc c'est exactement
pareil ce soir il y a une se il y a que
deux rondes ce soir sis TV ça c'est la
deème rounde donc du coup une fois
que ce match enfin l'armagadon sera
terminé et ben on se dira au revoir pour
aujourd'hui voilà donc du coup dernière
ronde enfin dernière amagon maintenant
et pour aujourd'hui sera terminé euh
donc petite pause ah dernière pause pour
aujourd'hui je vous dis à tout de suite
ne me quittez pas je vous dis à tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez on est de retour hop j'ai mis la
mauvaise
scène est de retour avec Al
FO et mvl Nakamura pour ses armagedons
alors là j'ai du coup si vous voulez les
paris qui ont été donnés pour les temps
qu'on va donner aux joueurs on va
avoir
Maxim mvl avec les
Blancs Magnus avec les Blancs et Alireza
avec les Blancs donc on a
vraiment MV
et firou qui doivent gagner avec les
Blancs et mettre la
pression je changer le score
de de carwana ici et c'est parti Al qui
commence sa
partie est-ce qu'on suit mvl est-ce
qu'on suit on suit
qui on su
qui
dites-moi ce que vous préférez
suivre je sais que y a un délai d'une
minute à chaque fois donc c'est
difficile à se parler le chat on est
bien
d'accord Magnus est blanc du coup
changer ça petite seconde
mais alors qu'est-ce que vous voulez
voir plutôt
mvl
plutôt ça à Toronto
Canada
[Musique]
Canada Toronto Canada il faut juste que
je change les noms
[Musique]
là
et ok mes scènes sont
prêtes mvl
firou firou
aussi bon on va essayer de suivre les
deux hein on va Esser suivre les deux
suivre les deux parties entre mvl
et mvl contre carwana et Maxime contre
firou contre
ikarou Maxime contre ikarou c'est la
même position qu'avant sauf qu'ils ont
changé Maxim une autre ligne sur la
fameuse la
fameuse ligne regardez alors là je vais
pas changer la camé à chaque fois je
peux le faire d'ailleurs MV a vraiment
l'air avoir marre complètement vous
allez voir un petit
peu c'est la même ouverture qu'avant on
a
eu
j F4 ici mvl avant il avait j
D4 tac tac
[Musique]
f5631 et apparemment c'est une bonne
ligne je vois qu' joue très très vite
mvl et çaon exactement
paton pour tout le monde très
compliqué théorique
et donc VL qui un peu surprisme dans
l'ouverture
ici et carwana qui des trucs jolis
franchement ils font des belles choses
il no français t H5 qui vient attaquer
le pion D5 joué par par Al ici les
pièces boug bien sûr
[Musique]
pas les pièces boug mais Lesur
réfléchissent c'est des
fois et l'ouverture com l'ouverture
cétait ça une sor de système de londr
joué par par
Alireza et tourage 5 avec l'idée
d'attaquer le petit pion en
D5
intéressant là c'est important ici qui a
13 minutes à la pendule contre seulement
8 pour Fabin Carona je vous rappelle
aussi que dans cette période là
darmagedon on joue sans incrément donc
ici Fabi avec 7 minutes 40 à la pendu
sans
incrément c'est chaud prendre des
décisions rapidement il faut jouer des
coups F c'est assez
étrange mais le RO blanc pas non plus
beauoup beaucoup d'abri genre grand R ça
fait peur avec tour C8 d 5 ça fait peu
peur 3 F1 c'est une idée mettre le r g
pour le le roqu à la main si vous voulez
pere c'est
possible n' pas l'air si débile de faire
roi F1 aussi mais il a joué ici grand
rock il pas plus être un pas pltre du
tout
euh
euh euh notre petit
[Musique]
Alireza alors dame2 cavalier B3 va
arriver fou F6 a été joué je commence à
bien aimer les Noirs en fait d'ici après
ro G7 j'ai l'impression que l'attaque d'
noir peut vraiment bien se passer et
j'ai un peu peur pour alirea je vous le
dit
sérieusement j'ai un peu
peur cavalier C4
waouh cavalier C4 alors pion prend c'est
impossible j'ai ça il surûr fou prend là
il veut peut-être dame prend je pense
attaquez là attaquez là
hyper hyper créatif à chaque fois euh
euh
firou hyper créatif hyper créatif en
plus il menace TR prend des 5 tu va
gagner un pion donc je pense qu'il va
forcer un petit pe fprend E5 ça m'a
l'air extrêmement bien joué de la part
d'alireza en tout cas très très créatif
et maintenant bah j'ai ça et ça et euh
bah il faut j des coups avec les noir
c'est très difficile de trouver les bons
coups F6 pour mettre le roi pe-être par
là plus tard
donc là j'ai dame pran qui est possible
mais j'ai une qualité de moins donc tu
as pas forcément envie de changer les
dames quand tu as du matériel de moins
peut-être dame D4 c'est un coup pour
garder la pression et un jour venir
essayer d'aller manger le pion genre
cavalier3 et cavalier prend pion là il
aussi ça en l'air cavalier mais'est pas
pas simplein de comment je
passe mais pour les paris pourquoi les
joueurs ne misent pas une minute par
exemple parce que les Noirs ont 9
minutes tout le temps
alors alors je t'explique Abdel en fait
en fait ce qui se passe
euh en fait ce qui ce qui se passe c'est
que
euh c'est un Paris chacun met un temps
le temps le plus bas gagne euh gagne les
Noirs ok donc c'est tu tu as les Noirs
en fait quand tu gagnes la le truc donc
si tu mets une minute à la pendule tu
vas gagner le Paris mais tu auras les
noirs avec une minute donc tu veux faire
un bulette contre alirea je t'en prie
mais les Blancs ont 15 et les Noirs ont
le temps qu'ils ont misé donc je te
conseille de pas mettre ça donc
généralement ils mettent neuf c'est
quand même bien d'avoir les Noirs parce
que en cas de nul tu peux gagner hein
mais 9 minutes c'est quand même
peu donc là par exle là voyz la PR est
très compliquée et et car a plus que 6
minutes quoi contre 11 donc tu es sous
pression parce que tu as les tu as les
Noirs tu es sous pression parce que tu
es mal au temps et pendant ce tempsl les
blancs
ben doivent gagner quoi donc c'est ça
intéressant en tout
cas
ok donc tour 8 a été joué ici
euh mais là j'ai encore une fois je j'ai
peur hein de la position vraiment de
d'alirza j'ai tour de qui arrive j'ai
c'est vis-à-vis là j'ai un vis-à-vis qui
arrive là bien sûr faire attention aussi
ce qui se passe sur le roi mais
euh sur le long terme j'ai peur quand
même pour ce roi
ok cavalier H4
[Musique]
ça men
quoi pr c'est pas une menace je
crois dame G4 c'est une menace G5 de
faire cavalier F5 ESS de faire des
choses un petit peu comme ça mais pas
facile les gars j'ai ouvert l'ordi ou là
là j'ai ouvert l'ordi et carwana a joué
le coup de l'ordinateur le seul coup qui
donne avantage noir c'est T et la
position est complètement perdu pour
Alireza complètement perdu sur tour
prend fourchette royale avec le clouage
je gagne la dame extrêmement jolie de la
part de de carwana en plus tu cavalier 3
maintenant cette position est juste
abandon c'est abandon en fait il y a pas
de coup c'est
abandon c'est dommage que s'il y a pas
tour les blan sont très bien en fait de
ce que je vois et ça a été raté ça a été
raté par al qu'est-ce que c'est joli
tour 1 extrêmement joli alors k
mvl mvl je vais vous dire un peu ce qui
se passe on peut aller voir rapidement
si vous voulez mvl hein on va revenir
après sur alirea
euh mvl c'est comme ça le Roy et blanc
est en D1 il est sur une cabane il a C
petite cabane devant lui là et il vient
du B4 pour ouvrir la dame et passer sur
A7 donc là là il y a un pion de plus
pour mvl si je sais bien compé mais la
paire de fou chez les noirs et une
position quand même qui a l' quand même
plus solide même si le roi est ouvert
ici les ces blanches sont pour les noirs
et le roi blanc il fait toujours un peu
peur ici alors C4 c'est un coup aussi
mais d prend à 7 peut-être C4 c'est pas
un coup du coup on va laisser ça mais
comment je joue alors si je joue pas ça
parce que ah il a jou C4 d'ailleurs il
me fait mentir sur dame prend
probablement dame là peut-être empêche
ça essayie de menacer c'est ça
ou autre chose j'ai peur quand même de
de B5 un jour tu un prend G2 ça fait un
peu peur quand même tout ça à voir si
euh possible de faire des choses mais
euh mais en tout cas la position hyper
intéressante les deux parties sont
extrêmement extrêmement compliquées
euh on voir un peu ce que nous fait
aliresa qu'est-ce qu'il a fait je pense
ça peut être la fin immédiatem ça peut
être la fin directement de za
euh si répond pas bien directement il y
a eu quoi là il y a eu tour 1 dam D2
ouis il y a eu ça maintenant j'ai plus
trop d'attaque j'ai plus dame G4 grâce à
Dame D7 qui bien joué menass tour
D8 l'impression que noir euh pas tout à
fait SR guissmou
mais ça dépend on avait eu ce gros débat
lors
des lors des éditions précédentes on
avait déjà eu des débat avec le chat qui
pensait un peu comme toi des fois mais
avoir les blanc c'est quand même aussi
intéressant donc c'est c'est assez
équilibré au final je crois tout
ça je suis pas sûr qu'il choisisse
justement parce que quand tu
gagnes je crois que ça ça te fait avoir
les Noirs je suis quasi sûr en fait
sinon il y a pas d'intérêt sinon je mets
une minute à chaque fois je mets une
minute pour te pour pour non parceen
fait je crois que la question du Paris
c'est avec combien de temps tu prends
les Noirs voilà avec combien de temps tu
es prêt à prendre les noirs et tu mets
ton Paris voilà ben moi je vais bien
avir les Noirs mais du coup avec 9
minutes 27 quoi sinon ça m'intéresse pas
et puis voilà chacun je crois que c'est
plutôt comme ça ça m'a l'air plus
logique en tout cas donc B4 cavalier E4
alors B4 c'est je comprends hein euh le
cavalier ici était vraiment très très
chiant il y avit t des trucs ici donc on
le chasse mais maintenant le roi il est
encore plus ouvert
donc mais bon cette position elle est
juste perdue je
crois
et political qui qui revient
political qui nous avait qui nous avait
euh euh qui nous avait comment dire euh
euh
entraîner vraiment à débattre hein avec
avec toutes ces choses là sur les blanc
noirs blanc noirs qui revient à la
charge euh ouais encore une fois moi je
crois que c'est assez équilibré mais
c'est vrai que political il a fait des
stats et il pense que c'est mieux
d'avoir les Noirs peut-être hein c'est
possible mais là c'est vrai dans ce
tournoi là on a l'impression que ça
serit quand même plus au noir pour
l'instant parce que les Blancs quand
même jouent de manière plus énergique
blanc essaie de forcer les choses plus
donc il y a aussi des fois des chaos qui
se passent à cause du fait que les
Blancs poussent un peu trop donc mais
c'est intéressant en tout cas en 5 vs4
euh oui c'est différent c'est vrai qu'il
y a il y a plus de skill quand tu fais
15 contre 10 quand même plus de skill de
je d'échec 5 contre 4 c'est quand même
plus du Blitz il y a du flag il y a du
flag on peut le voir donc prend le 6 sur
roi prend j'ai une découverte qui gagne
la dame on peut penser que le roi est un
un petit peu ouvert mais quand même
c'est vrai que je pense que là les
Blancs n'ont pas du tout de BACE il a
pas d'échec du
tout
ah benah Hus Hus je sais pas du tout il
me semble qu'avant c'était comme ça ça a
peut-être changé mais bon à voir mais
moi ça m'a l'air logique que tu est noir
mais bon peut-être que c'est pas le cas
je sais pas mais en tout cas à chaque
fois que moi je vois les moi je vois les
paris he bah à chaque fois le joueur qui
qui a dit le moins de temps à chaque
fois c'estel qu'elle est noir pourquoi
pe bizarre quand même je pense que ça je
pense que le plus petit all est noir je
je je suis je suis vraiment quasi sûr
alors cavalier là et peut-être d' prend
ici malheureusement ah non je pensais
qu'il y avait il y avait mat mais je c
là j'ai échec probablement et je sors
Deah c'est la part probablement ça et T
je suis pas sûr par contre derrière ah
il fait ça direct regardez s'il prend je
fais ça et sur cavalier échec dame pr je
prends là c'est marrant sur cavalier
éche il y aura peut-être 3 F8 on va
sortir
des des échecs de partout je pense que
c'est fini on va aller voir mvl si vous
voulez parce que ALIR je pense je pense
c'est foutu donc à moins qu'il a une
surprise on le verra à la fin mais je
pense que mvl quand même il y a encore
plus de pièces plus de choses à voir
peut-être c'est plus sympa de suivre mvl
euh ici donc plein de coup ont été j d
pr 7 dam C6 B5 dame
G2 là c'est la guerre entre deux joueurs
il s'envoie tout
et pu ils sont
complètement incontrôlable avec le fou
en prise il y a A7 qui est possible et
l'ordinateur est tranquille l'ordi égal
ouais c'est
égal mais nous en en qu c'est absolument
impossible les Noirs ils ont quandme de
pions passés li et la part de fou donc
sur le long terme les noirs peuvent
vraiment être mieux mais les blancs ici
il faut qu'il Fass quelque chose avec ce
P passé je pense sur le long terme les
blancs sont mal encore
pass qui pe facilement bloqu par des
pièces donc les blancs do trouver des
solution très
rapidement sinon il vont se retrouver à
être extrêmement mal
alors
prise donc là je peux
manger C4 aussi peut-être en disant que
sur F je
fais7 l' chaud ok il a eu prise ro B8 il
veut mettre son roi en A8 pour être sûr
que le pion n'ille pas à Dame comment on
continue franchement moi j'aimerais bien
avoir les Noirs
ici ça m'a l'air très dur en pratique
pour les blancs parce que c'est du
concret alors que les noirs sur le long
terme ils ont juste à pousser leur pion
et tu sais pas trop comment tu empêches
ça en fait avec avec les Blancs ça a l'
ça a l'air imparable alors que les
blancs doivent trouver des des des
choses immédiates peut-être à 7 tourc1
est-ce que c'est possible de jouer à 7
voil là tourc1
d'aller bouffer pion C7 peêtre
c'estidée peê pe-êre c'est c'est l'idée
roi2 vient contre les pions noirs ok bon
j'ai envie de faire ça quand même pour
voir il fait G4 d'accord sur ro là il va
sûement essayer de pousser le pion
jusquen G2 euh
[Musique]
c'est hyper compliqué cette position
j'ai beaucoup de mal à
[Musique]
comprendre comment on la
joue de visu j'ai envie de dire que son
beaucoup mieux mais la j fait
mentir j'arrive pas à voir comment les
blanc peuvent se défendre en fait face à
la Maré de P qui avance face à ça j'ai
l'impression que lui et lui ça avance
pas al qui pr on
l'impression sur un vra éier donc on
va ce P G2 il est il est vraiment très
fort parce fait il oblige les blancs à
rester passif quoi à cause du
pion d'ailleurs maintenant F4 c'est le
menace peut-être si prend il y aurait
échec et tour donc ro là pour pour
fermer la fermer
la la la
colonne sur la capitale pour conduire
les n rcment intéressante les j
généralement privé le temps qu's sont pr
pour ja la couleur de leur choix celui
communiquant le nombre le plus petit
remporte les enchères et droit défendre
sa couleur
tandis ok ça marche ben écoute merci
pour
euh pour euh pour euh pour ça je pensais
que c'était vraiment les Noirs ok bon
ben je me suis tromper je me su Tromp au
moins c'est clair maintenant on est sûr
à 100 % que que c'est comme ça merci
pour pour ton petit message au moins
c'est plus clair donc tour H7 et voz
maintenant on va essayer de passer la
tour ici alors je contre ja clairement
mais bon alors si je fais ça est-ce que
tu fais pas genre juste
ça tu prends je te fais écheac ah non
mais le fou cont le Pr c'est que ça
c'est ma en fait regardez c'est ma avec
ça grâce à mon cavalier mon pion c'est
mat du coup je peux pas
continuer ce pion est toujours là quand
même ma tour quiement
bloqué
la bouge pas à cause du Fou du pion la
bouge pas à cause du
pion c'est assez marrant comme position
chacun a for
faiblessesarrive pas à bouger t G6 j la
qualité ça peutêtre une
option pour continuer avec ce pion passé
et la tour mais bon j'ai peur qu'un jour
je perde aussi le pion si jamais je fin
par sa ma tour une minute pour Naka
contre 3 et c'est du CH je vous rappelle
he c'est du
chos roi là je pense ou roi
là faquer la tour tour
ici comment on joue maintenant est-ce
que je peux pas faire ça ah non il a
prend ici pardon là je bouge mon
cavalier j'imagine à C intermédiaire 1
minute 22 pour Nakamura contre 246 pour
mvl ça va peut-être se jouer autant ici
cette partie ça peut peut-être se jouer
autant ça c'est intéressant sur Retour
pr il y aurait roi prend tour vous voyez
sur ça roi prend échec
ou même ça échec échec il peut y avoir
du CH là est-ce queab c'est un coup
est-ce qu' c'est un coup qu'est-ce qu'il
leur dit ah il fait il fait dame l'ordi
il fait qu' vaer prendre
C7 et après je vais-être manger ici à la
fin le P dur à
défendre et Nakamura qui doit tenir la
partie avec les Noirs en fait il a l'air
d'être difficile tour ici échec on va
manger
làhaut en fait il va perdre ici est-ce
qu'il y a une nul ou pas non ça je fais
ça c'est perdu Naka qui a perdu tous ses
matchs
aujourd'hui Naka qui est complètement
largué
ça a l'air complètement perdu en faitin
mvl qui va battre Naka les gars mvl qui
bah qui a une pièce de plus maintenant
mais ro en C3 on va manger le pion quand
on
veut complètement gagnant en plus c'est
très facile
he très très facile Nakam qui est
dégoûté vent sur sa tête c'est son
l'anniversaire aujourd'hui il per contre
Wesley et contre mvl vraiment pas en
forme le
Naka il va pas
passer
deminal je rappelle que système suisse
sy avec les joue et les de derniers
sontlimin de la
compétion il sur de c'est pour moi le
plus gros client à pas qualifier quand
Mme fort et n camura c'est Quême la
surprise ça se qualifie pas mais on va
voir can
C4 allez on mange en2 bon ça va être
abandon hein ça va être abandon de la
camura je pense alors Caval là il y Ava
toutme T4 attention C
cloué cavalier al là on peut jouer tour
là tour là tout gagne assez
facile complètement terminé
et d'ailles tout à l'heure le joueur qui
se devant la caméra c'était so Wesley
j'ai vu dans mes ce qu'on m'a dit là so
Wesley qui est
venu qui est venu nous gêner tout à
l'heure et on a Maxime en direct qui
vient de gagner son Armageddon et donc
battre
Nakamura dans
ces système tout donc super al il joue
encore al il joue encore VO qu'est-ce
qu'il fait il vient de faire nul Alireza
avec les Blancs il vient de faire nul
malheureusement on arrivé juste au
moment où il a perdu enfin oùù ça s
terminé et nul avec les blanc ça veut
dire que Ben tout simplement il a aucune
chance de gagner c'est les noirs qui
doivent essayer de passer
euh donc du coup alira qui fait nul AC
cl blanc donc qui perd ce match Carlsen
qui gagne avec blanc vous voyez
l'armagadon Carsen carlen avec les
Blancs a gagné l'armagadon
Caren donc c'est pas que les Noirs qui
gagnent en Armagedon
euh mvl il a gagné avec les Blancs donc
mvl gagne avec clé blanc Carsen gagne
avec clé blanc et alira fait nul donc au
final bah là les stats vous fait un peu
mentir mais bon après ça dépend c'est
vrai que peut-être que les Noirs gagnent
plus en général mais encore une fois ça
dépend donc maintenant petit tour sur
euh sur les résultats en tout cas qui
sont passés ici
paf on a sesley et Carlsen et carwana
qui ont gagné leurs trois matchs alors
sesley il a gagné les deux matchs
propres sans même aller une seule fois
en armagadon Carlsen a battu lazavic
normal puis a battu Abdou en armagadon
carwana a gagné les deux matchs re les
deux Français euh Alireza et Maxime les
deux en Armagedon
alirea a
battu a
battu abov pardon il a battu Abdou dans
le prier match et perdu contre euh
carwana dans le deè match tandis que mvl
a perdu
contre Fabiano carwana puis ensuite
gagné contre carou donc à Z0 point on a
lazavic ikarou et
Abdou les de deux derniers à l'essue des
se matchs et ben seront éliminés de la
compétition on pour leur dire au revoir
donc laavic c'est quand même le joueur
qui est le moins fort de la compétition
c'est un bon favori je pense pour être
éliminé et tandis que Ikaru et Abdou
c'est quand même des belles surprises
bon enfin tout le monde est capable
hement le tournoi il est relevé euh je
pense quand même que Nakamura pour moi
c'est une plus grosse surprise hein
vraiment de de de d'avoir zéro mais
c'est comme ça bon en tout cas demain
euh demain on se revoit euh je vais vous
remettre la cam demain on se revoit à
partir de 18h enfin pas avec moi mais
vous allez voir demain euh tout ce qui
est sur blitzstam donc d'ailleurs on va
le raid parce que on m demander de le
raid à la
fin donc demain 18h en compagnie de
Kevin et euh
et Fabien libevski sur la chaîne TCOM
FRR encore une fois pour la suite
roundond 3 et 4 de l'événement je vous
dis à tous un grand merci d'avoir suivi
ce stream comme d'hab je vous dis à très
bientôt passe une excellente soirée et
bon courage pour pour votre semaine qui
commence du coup demain à très bientôt
ciao